please be seated
opening the executive session now on
House Bill 185 relative to the
determination of parental rights and
responsibilities based on shared
parenting and shared access to the
child's records
a lot of work has gone into this you
should be getting amendments
758 coming around
both ways
and if you we run out of amendments
before we run out of people we probably
have the opposite problem so just make
sure that you have uh 758
representative posts
um
Bill and her Amendment she got all her
many of her co-sponsors to sign on as
well
and when you have had a chance to read
it over this uh purports to solve the
problems that we saw with the original
um
Bill and some of the earlier amendments
this
has been worked on quite extensively I
noticed my notes from the original
hearing I think
representative post has tried to take
them into account and you can read it
and see if you think that
foreign
okay
Mr chair
over here are there any other amendments
on this bill
um
I think so
is it possible we could compare or uh
you may if you wish yeah there's another
one that landed out or they've been
withdrawn uh that is to say I got a copy
but the sponsor did not wish to proceed
with it there is an amendment 712 also
by representative post there is an
amendment 551 also by representative
post and she has uh wished that this is
her amendment to be considered okay
that's all I want to see is what's
what's being presented to the committee
so this is the total of what's being yes
there is no amendment to my knowledge
that comes from any other party okay
okay
good morning Morgan
I I have a question
related to the amendment and it would be
a question for
Richard head
is that I'm just curious if it's a
factual question it is possible
consulate would you mind coming up
I'm
you may State your question once he's
turned his mic on
does that all the time good morning good
morning I'm just curious if joint
parenting schedule if that is a current
term in the family courts you're
referencing line five line five of the
amendment four so
um
we had referenced equal parenting time
that there was a new definition and now
we have joint parenting schedule in this
amendment
so I'm curious in terms of the family
courts if that is language that
so RSA 461 a colon 1 which is
definitions has a definition of
parenting schedule and parenting
schedule means a schedule of when the
child is in the care of each parent
so I don't know that adding the word
joint changes that okay definition okay
thank you
good question thank you anyone else yes
uh do I see a representative Moulton
foreign
thank you Mr chairman
um could you just repeat what you said
um what the definition was for parenting
time sure so parenting plan is defined
in RSA 461 A1 parenting plan I'm sorry
parent what I read before was parenting
parenting schedule
um parent so parenting schedule which I
read before it means the schedule of
which the child is in the care of each
parent
and then parenting plan which I think
was your question means a written plan
describing each parent's rights and
responsibilities
sure
any discussion on the bill as amended
before we entertain a motion
representative
thank you Mr chair I'm sorry Mr head I I
is it okay to ask him another question
I think he's good for several yay
thank you both
um I I have a question
uh concerning uh line six
of the amendment of the amendment it
says including overnights with the child
by both fit parents what determines fit
or is there a determination in 461
um I don't know what that means thank
you
one more question please you may ask
another question
um on line eight it's uh it
continues from line seven UH
responsibilities best interest
what does the RSA say that that means
please sure
um
you give me one second
I think A2
describes it uh well A6
there we go
okay yeah a62
um so
so let me go to a couple places
so RSA 461 A2 has a statement of purpose
um which has as part one e or because
children do best when both parents have
a stable and meaningful involvement in
their lives it's policy of the state
unless it is clearly shown in a
particular case it is detrimental to a
child two and then it lists those things
that identify the the purpose that the
legislature has identified
uh consider both the best interest of
the child in light of the factors listed
in 461 A6 and the safety of the parties
in developing a a parenting plan and
then 461 A6 has the definition of uh of
what best interest is
um
and then in the section that you just
pointed to in the in the amendment would
add a new paragraph into A6 which is a
list of of
um
those factors which go into what is the
best interest of the child
thank you very much it would not replace
the ones at present
as far as I can see I believe this is a
new paragraph that is lines 10
into the next page is all a new
paragraph it is an insertion after 1A so
I would say it keeps the rest in place
yes so we could then presume that the
court in making a determination of what
is best practices have has a definition
with which they work
I I apologize I didn't understand that
question I didn't either okay
um
when we read the phrase best practices
that's not just something floating
and the interests are best practice the
courts know what that means because it's
here in the law we the the courts would
apply the the definitions that have been
identified through this A6 and then as
amended by
um by this new paragraph that's correct
thank you any other questions
representative Nelson thank you Mr
chairman um I wanted to point out on
page two line 20
um where it says limited to I believe
that's a typo it should be t-o and not
t-o-o
these things are cleaned up along the
way it does not okay I put this in any
Jeopardy okay uh when this is it goes to
enrolled builds they clean up the
grammar and any inadvertent false
references to the existing law
appreciate your clarification thank you
chair will entertain a motion if there's
no other uh questions
representative Bickford
foreign
that is the amendment you would just
handed out
that is the amendment the prime sponsor
wishes
yep
uh do I have a second
representative Seidel it's the first
hand I saw any further discussion
uh
representative Raymond hi thank you I
want to thank representative post for
um really listening to the questions and
the discussion that we had at our last
hearing regarding this Bell because I
think that they went back and they
really looked at the previous Amendment
and the questions that the committee
asked and try to address quite a bit of
it and I appreciate how they have kind
of expanded on this to make it a lot
more understandable for the layperson
having said that I categorically opposed
this amendment for the following reasons
one the legal terms are a mess the
standard and family court is not clear
in convincing evidence that's a criminal
court statute so every other
um case that is heard in the Family
Division is a preponderance of the
evidence so to suddenly for parenting
time raise that bar to clear and
convincing is completely irrational I
just I don't understand the logic there
and they've used clear and convincing
multiple times the second issue I have
again is language the word fit parents
that's not defined joint parenting
schedule is not again consistent with
current state law it should be parenting
plan on page one line 22 it says
um if one of the parents is convicted of
child abuse or neglect again that is a
criminal term it requires it
specifically refers to being convicted
in a criminal case
now is it in the best interests of
children that we only restrict people
from parenting time if they've been
convicted criminally or is it okay to
say listen if you have a finding of
abuse or neglect under family court
maybe you shouldn't have unrestricted
parenting time so really I feel like
there was some effort but this really
needs a review by an attorney who's
familiar with Family Division and
familiar with the Rules of Evidence
before we move forward with it
representative Moulton
thank you Mr chairman
um I have an issue with line 20 on the
amendment uh where it says
so leading up to it
um it's talking about the The Joint
parenting schedule
um but it's saying that
if one of the parents does not request
sole primary or joint responsibility for
the child reasons may include but are
not limited to one parent lives or works
out of town so what kind of radius are
we talking about here and just because
someone commutes to work doesn't mean
that they can't have joint parenting
that's not that's not a reason to not do
50 50 parenting you know unless
unless out of work was like across the
country then that's one thing but if
it's like
we have a ton of people in Manchester
alone and Nashua as well they commute
into Boston that has nothing to do with
their ability to parent you know 50 50.
so I have a major issue with that thank
you
excuse me where were you where were you
reading yes uh hand representative
Pickford oh what this one or that one
either one okay or both
I was in the amendment
um Point number I so it's two i b
three
line twenty yeah line 20 and onward like
20 to 22.
yeah okay any further comments
representative D Simone thank you Mr
chairman the the way I'm reading line 20
is
I think the the first few words are very
important it says if one of the parties
does not request Soul primary or joint
responsibility it's whether the parent
is requesting or not it's not that the
court is determining it's whether the
parent is requesting
parents don't request joint for many
many reasons that's their prerogative I
think that's how I'm reading it
representative Moulton thank you Mr
chairman and thank you uh representative
D Simone for for that interpretation I
appreciate that
um my concern is for the divorces that
are contentious what if the other party
says well they work out of town and
therefore I should have more parenting
time so whereas the person who's working
out of town might be like no we can do
joint parenting time and it should be
fine
but if if the parties are contentious
among each other and one is trying to
weaponize it against the other
um
then
the the judge would have to go back to
what is in the law and if this is
written in the law then that's a concern
representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman so I think
I think that um you know we have a
tightrope in the state
we're talking about
you're talking about divorce cases that
are often contested and whatnot I think
that on this something like this another
thing to think about that I don't think
was necessarily thought about in you
know the perfect world where you have an
amicable divorce you're not going to
disagree about these kind of things
however even in that case you have hurt
feelings you have other things happening
if we go in saying okay we have joint
parenting that's the standard we're
going to start with joint parenting
you're actually asking one parent to say
oh actually I don't want joint parenting
or I don't want like I can't do this
particular and even though that seems
really benign
and I understand I respect why this was
all brought up because there are parents
who want their kids that cannot get
their kids and I think that that's
that's honorable I think that this is
not the way because I think we're then
asking good parents to even say why they
don't want joint custody and to say to
your kid well we didn't do joint when
they come down the line why why am I not
with you half the time well I had to say
because I have to work or we're putting
that burden of responsibility rather
than letting a judge look at the
situation and say well this makes sense
right because we're asking we're saying
going into this all right there's joint
now tell us why there's not joint
custody so I think that's just a further
complication I need I think we need to
think about thanks
representative ball
thank you chairman Pearson
um when I'm reading this what I'm what
I'm seeing is that we're trying to find
a starting point and that starting point
would be at 50 50. and then we move away
from 50 50 as the parents find necessary
or the court finds necessary it's just
saying that having one person say that
person can't do 50 50 Carrington can't
be the only reason there's got to be
other things you can't just have an
accusation that we can't co-parent but
there's many reasons why parents would
step away that children would understand
it could be
um
military commitments it could be First
Responders it could be medical
professions where they can't do 50 50 if
they're on call on the weekends it's
what we're looking for here is just an
even starting point and from there the
court and the parents can decide what is
in the best interest and I think it
allows parents to start
on a level ground and they need to put
their animosity away and they need to
put their children's best interest first
thank you
representative long
thank you Mr chairman
um
yeah we certainly know what parents need
to do that doesn't always happen that's
why we're here
um I what I haven't found in here for
example I I would be one to say yeah I'm
not about to turn down joint
joint parenting that's going to be
embarrassing for me and my to my child
so I'm I gotta get up at four in the
morning to go to work I'm going to drop
my uh child off at my brother's house
who by the way my ex-wife hates
um where did you know I I just think
we're we're looking for more conflict
here you know we're setting up something
that's going to create more conflict uh
just the sole base of getting a starter
point for joint uh uh you know joint
parenting I you know again it's not
reviewed through the whole line it
certainly begins the process however I
I'm afraid of The Snowball Effect that
is going to happen when
um
you know I'm I'm taking a court because
I don't have joint parenting because I'm
dropping them dropping my child off at
my
brother's house or what have you
seeing nothing further the motion before
us first of all is on the amendment
I just want to comment I
respectfully disagree with
representative long on the idea that
it's going to cause more uh Agony
um I don't I think it's going to be the
opposite as uh representative ball said
this is something that's needed to make
it clear that parents
are equal parents and that's where
they're starting from
and if they can't do it
that's fine or if they don't think they
should do it that's fine but if the
other parent wants to show and
demonstrate that that apparent
shouldn't do it there should be a a high
bar to to say otherwise because this
really goes hand in hand I think
dovetails with the parenting plan
uh position we have
in 2005 when we we passed the comparable
parenting bill which is almost identical
to this bill we have before us it passed
14-0 from this committee the only thing
that held it up was the administrative
jump into the courts asked us not to go
forward with it yet because they were in
spending so much time re uh what do I
want to say reforming almost the courts
uh the family court system particularly
with the uh parenting plan but um it was
it was quite popular so it stalled only
because of that
um when we when I looked at um Iowa back
in 2004 because this has been around a
long time uh I originally filed this
back in 2008 it was a favorite of mine
that's why I jumped in to say yeah
I'll uh go for it
um
anyway in Iowa if the Court denies a
request for joint physical care the
determination shall be accompanied by
specific findings of fact
and conclusions of the law that the
awarding of joint physical care is not
in the best interest of the child it's
something that's been gathering over
time and I think it really I think it
really works very well for society and
instead of we've been seeing so many
bills that just do a little incremental
things within the court this is
something that I think will help Society
a great deal
thank you
Mr Mr representative Raymond thank you
Mr chairman um I just want to be clear I
do not oppose the idea of having
um a neutral starting point for court
for parenting time I think that we can
all agree that courts should be neutral
going in there and they should look at
both parents on the same footing right
from the get-go and then let the
evidence come in my objection to both
this amendment and the original bill is
the inconsistencies with the language
and the terminology for used in this for
legal terms that are contrary to current
standards in Family Division this bill
consistently uses terminology that is
appropriate for Criminal Courts not
Family Division and so to me I think
it's lazy because we've been over this
multiple times in this committee but
also
um I I just don't think it's in the best
interests of children or or families in
the state to start confusing different
standards of evidence between criminal
and civil courts so should the sponsors
at some point come back with language
that matches what the standard of
evidence is in Family Division
most of my objections would be relieved
anything else provided you're not
repeating what has been said we have a
lot of bills to get through we've been
kicking this one around for about 25
minutes now if this is not if this is
something new put your hand up if not
please don't
give it a shot
thank you Mr chairman I'm one of the
sponsors to this the original bill and I
liked the original Bill to begin with
um
I don't support this amendment first of
all like I don't know that I was
talked to about this amendment before it
came out this is my first time reading
it now
um
but also like I just I I have issues
that I already mentioned so I'm not
going to talk about again
um but I would
I would move maybe when we're done the
vote on the amendment I would move to
maybe retain this so that we could keep
it you know and fix fix more issues
Mr chair
I'm confused
if we have a motion before us first of
all on the amendment then on the bill is
amended if the bill is amended passes it
passes if it ties or therefore is
defeated we can entertain another amen
another motion
seeing I hope nothing further
the motion before us is on Amendment
zero seven five eight H to Bill 185 it
was moved by representative Bickford it
was seconded by representative Seidel on
the amendment with the clerk please call
the roll
Jim and Pearson
yes
representative long no
representative DeSimone yes
representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes
representative ball
representative Panic yes
representative Seidel yes
representative Grossman no
representative Levesque no
representative Petrino will be voting no
representative Perez
no representative Greg no
representative Moulton no representative
Raymond no
eight to eight the emotion for the
amendment fails we are now back to the
original motion of ought to pass moved
by representative Bickford and seconded
by representative Seidel this is on the
original bill
and the clerk may call the role please
Jim and Pearson yes
representative long no
representative DeSimone
yes
representative bigfoid excuse me I I
missed what you said this is on the
original Bill well I thought we were
going to have a motion to retain not yet
we still can do it it is still on the
table on the floor to vote the original
bill so if it fails we can still do a
retain this is correct
okay uh
yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
Seidel yes representative Grossman no
representative Levesque no
representative Petrino will be voting no
representative Perez no
representative Greg no representative
Moulton no representative Raymond no
828 now the chair will entertain another
motion
a move to retainment
um chair calls on representative long a
move to retain the motion is to retain
is there a second to that representative
Bickford
you do have the right to discuss you
don't have to exercise it
representative Moulton thank you Mr
chairman I would love to retain this I
would I like most of the things in it
most of them I just would like to tweak
it a little bit
and then we can present a new
um a new Amendment I'm one of the
sponsors on this original bill so
obviously I liked it for for most of it
I would personally rather talk to
representative post and and some of the
whoever was the original sponsors
and get my own input into this
um we can address the issues and maybe
we can bring it back like relatively
soon so I would I would personally like
to retain this
seeing no other hands up the emotion
before us is to retain move by
representative long seconded by
representative Bickford on House Bill
185 Dash FN the clerk please call the
roll
Jim and Pearson yes to retain
representative long yes representative
DeSimone
begrudgingly yes
representative Bigfoot yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
Seidel yes representative Grossman
yes representative Levesque yes
representative Petrino will be voting
yes representative Perez yes
representative Greg yes representative
Moulton yes representative Raymond yes
16-0 to retain
House Bill 185 is retained this ends the
uh exact session on House Bill 185.
and uh
those of you who have taken extensive
notes on this may I want to review them
and funnel them through representative
Moulton who will be the extensive
note having been taken Repository
to be to be fair I will do the work and
I will reach out to representative post
and and work with I don't even know who
this person is but I will do the work to
to make the amendment the way we think
it should be thank you very much
okay
I have something to read before we go on
to the next one this comes from Paul
Smith Clerk of the house regarding
committee reports
if you're writing a committee report and
we do not need one on the previous bill
it's been retained but going forward if
we don't retain something in a committee
report or two needs to be written please
pay attention
if
the bill we wrote voted on and you are
writing a report on
has an amendment it is such and such a
bill as amended the report must State
what the amendment does
okay
secondly
this is not a problem with some who
write half a page of report this is for
those who write one sentence or two and
he gave an example the committee does
not think that we need this bill
why
because there is a gang out there he
used to harder term uh of people who
love to pull things off consent and all
they need is half an excuse to do so so
we want to make sure that we write as
best to report as possible so should the
bill get pulled off consent there is
good reasoning behind how we voted as a
committee so be a little bit more
forthcoming those who write sparsely
also in your reports do not say the
Republicans voted this way and the
Democrats voted that way because
sometimes
it's mixed on both sides but we do not
identify the party even if it's
unanimous
the reports simply explain why this
group or that group is for this or
against it that's what we do we read a
narrative and somebody from outside the
process might not necessarily be able to
guess which party did one and which
party did the other
also he said do not State something as a
fact
that is an opinion for example if this
bill passes
it will bankrupt the city of Atkinson
that's what you think
it may not and I would simply fight hard
with my colleague here if that ever took
place just simply say we believe that
this would harm gopher tortoises or
something not it will uh you will have
to consult other things for facts it is
a report it is pretty much an opinion
also we are coming up on deadline
everything's got to be out of here by a
week from Thursday which now means if
you're going to write a minority or
majority report the chair needs to know
that
at the end of executing the bill and
your report needs to be in
mucho Pronto very quickly
um next langsam right yeah okay
so please work on those reports over the
lunch hour
um
also hearings
this afternoon later this morning maybe
when we do hearings they're
informational we do not debate with the
person who's sitting before us we can
give our opinions in an exec session we
ask for clarifications of fact and so on
so I have now fulfilled my
obligation to the clerk of the house
we're going to move on to 583 simply
because that's the one I can find
um
well I could here it is and this is
there is an amendment forthcoming uh I
opened the exact session on House Bill
583 which is relative to termination of
child support
and there is
an amendment
from the prime sponsor and I'll pass
some down this way and that way
um
and this is amendment 714.
and the uh
uh sponsor believes that this cleans up
questions that we had during the
original
hearing
and if you have another amendment to
this from representative Spillane toss
it out because he wants Amendment 714 to
be the one he is going to present to us
representative long so representative
slain doesn't present an amendment to
the committee one of us Committee Member
that yeah Committee Member does I I'll
do it anybody any one of us can do it
can you do what
I I really
you may remember from the original
hearing there was a question about uh
somebody turning a certain age and
hadn't finished school yet and so he
taught it around and talked to some
various people and
the amendment 714 is what you see before
you
again we now look at the other
amendments
if they're by him
I'm not going to present any of them if
they're by him this is his Amendment but
are there any others that have been
presented to the committee I don't know
of any amendments that have been
presented to this committee on this I
thought representative ball had one
coming uh if she does maybe that's what
she's going to get I wasn't quite able
to hear what she was talking about okay
I just want to do a comparison of the
amendment you can do that that are being
presented to the committee
okay thank you Mr chair that's exactly
what she went to do is pick up another
amendment to this bill whisper
ing right
now
I I have a husband and a daughter who
are hearing impaired I get it
but I said
get a convenience
Instagram
there she is
foreign
coming both ways is representative
Ball's Amendment on 583.
and thank you representative Bickford
for uh reminding me there was another
amendment coming I'm afraid I dropped
the ball on that
my pleasure to remind you
drop the ball on that oh
so we have side by side by side and just
a reminder of anyone leaving the room
you may but once I call the question
well oh
oh you get to look at the bill
representative Spillane's Amendment and
representative Ball's Amendment
are there any other amendments
okay chair calls on himself
um I like on the ball Amendment lines 15
and 16 because in my understanding age
21 is valid for most of the folks but if
there's a approved state board of
education program that goes stage 22. I
think I remember that uh representative
[Music]
um
uh from my work with the DD Community
that's 22. so I think representative
ball certainly on lines 15 and 16 uh is
a more accurate rendering of what we
wish to do any other comments we should
have representative ball speak to her
Amendment representative spall in ball
May indeed speak to her Amendment
thank you chairman Pearson
um when I did this amendment I did some
research on the social security for
children that were receiving
benefits survivor benefits and this
wording is taken right from there so it
aligns with the same way the government
decides when to terminate
um child support and on the bottom again
I looked at both the
Board of Education with our extension of
allowing children to now stay in their
special education programs till age 22
and I also looked at again Social
Security
requirements and that's where the
wording came from thank you
foreign
representative Raymond's hand thank you
I this is this the sweet spot where I
should put it from now on uh we'll see
one can hope okay
but to a point I just wanted to thank
representative ball for um the work that
she did on this I know
um uh representative Greg also had
looked that up and sent it to
representative splane and when I was
reviewing this one
um over the weekend
um I was like oh we're still missing
that language about
um kids who are in programs until 22. so
um you have resolved my biggest issue
and I appreciate that
I know it's a lot of work to get this
done and in so quickly
representative Perez
yes I do have a question
um
it this uh programs that it would
include
um for example
um when I back in the days when I moved
here
um they make me go back and then did
some
um go back into high school
um and so when I graduated I was like
already past the uh 18 because you know
they got English or the second language
at this amendment would include those
students that they come in with the
programs with like English as a second
language sometime we have to go back and
then take extract classes so we have to
go back couple grades because the
education for another country it doesn't
comply with the education here
thank you for the question
no go ahead
I believe that it it closes the mic
sorry thank you um
I believe that it does cover it because
it would be under the special education
that you're continuing continuing your
education in an edu special education
program and it does go to give that
extra year of children who may have been
retained a year or need an additional
year in high school so they don't
graduate until they're 19. so it does go
uh till 19 and two months if you're not
in special education there's also the
provision that says that the judge can
also say it's going to go beyond age 18
as well
and I would also like to mention that in
2021 there was a court case and the
determination was that Home Care
Services continue for children that are
enrolled special education children
disabled children who are enrolled in um
home services and extra Services they
don't lose that because they're a
student where they did previously
would someone wish to make a motion on
House Bill 583 and with the
um Amendment
0793 the chair recognizes representative
ball
if you would like to make that motion
thank you chairman Pearson yes I would
like to make a motion that we owe OTP
the amendment
to move
yes to move my Amendment I'm sorry I'm
first time I'm doing this so
um
to move the amendment number 0793h
I'll second
Mark who is that that was you
now any further discussion
uh
seeing none the motion before us is to
move Amendment
0793h on House Bill 583 FN moved by
representative ball and seconded by
representative D Simone would the clerk
please call the roll
the motion is ought to pass
on the motion
my name on the amendment well that's
they moved the amendment yeah I just
wondered if I said OTP or not
everything I said before
OTP
got it we are moving the amendment right
now
represent uh chairman Pearson yes
representative long yes
representative DeSimone yes
representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
Seidel yes representative Grossman yes
representative Levesque yes
representative Petrino will be voting
yes representative Perez
yeah
representative Greg yes representative
Moulton
oh
okay representative Raymond yes
the amendment passes 15. to zero would
one absent
representative Bickford would you look
out in the hall and let her know that
we're about to move something else
please
the motion before us moved by
representative ball and seconded by
representative DeSimone is now House
Bill 583 FN as amended by Amendment 0793
H would the clerk please call the roll
ought to pass as Amendment
Jim and Pearson yes
representative long yes representative
DeSimone
representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
Seidel yes representative Grossman yes
representative Levesque yes
representative Petrina will be voting
yes representative Perez
yes representative Greg yes
representative Moulton excuse me absent
at the moment representative Raymond yes
ought to pass as amended passes 15-0
and representative all of you all
Representatives do you have any
objection to going on to consent you
shouldn't I have a question
how do we handle the spleen Amendment
now which is active in them it was not
received and entered in
oh
unless somebody chooses to present it
from the community okay it is a dead
Amendment
that's right
representative Grossman
I'd be happy to put it on consent but it
has a fiscal note attached
I do not believe it is a second
committee Bill and let's take a look at
the fiscal note from the original
bill it says at least my copy says
due to time constraints they didn't give
one
so therefore we can send it over and if
the clerk says we're wrong he can bump
it along its happy way not for us to
determine so let's put it on consensus
I may have missed this
representative ball would you write a
very wonderful committee report for us
please thank you
all right
and this concludes uh the exact session
on House Bill 583.
and let's see what do we have next here
all right the next thing that was given
to me is
548 opened the executive session on
House Bill
and this is an amendment that the
sponsor representative spelane asks me
to present and it is amendment 617.
foreign
on House Bill 548.
and this was basically you'll remember a
patch job
um
the lines five and six on the original
Bill had a strikeout through the words
and has obtained or maintained health
insurance coverage as required by a
legal order of support that was not
requested by the prime sponsor it was
stricken
erroneously and my Amendment 617 simply
restores the words that never should
have been taken out
so what you get in the amendment 617h is
the bill as the prime sponsor wished it
to appear and you may remember from the
hearing that was about the only
discussion we really had
it's they've been going around in fact
okay
you may remember the reason for the bill
was if somebody has
um let's say a fifty thousand dollar
salary and it's divided among a number
of pay periods sometimes the check might
be let's say
499.98 and
that technically puts you in default of
if you're supposed to be giving 500
you're in default by two cents and the
computers do not understand that
apparently and as a result some people
have been penalized for being in arrears
when it's two cents so what the
sponsor's bill would seek to do is
simply bump it up to twenty five dollars
where this kind of error which
apparently has happened to some people
uh shouldn't happen that's what this
bill is very simply all about
yeah
seeing no hands up the chair then wishes
to move
ought to pass
as amended
on house on the amendment zero six one
seven h
on House Bill 548.
uh and is there a second
were you waving for second end
no I moved it
and it so moved you that you seconded it
okay thank you
any further discussion
what's that
okay
does it I do have a question a
representative long thank you Mr uh
chairman uh
25 is the
minimum
child support pay
is that what that is
no I don't think so it's not is there
might be is there a minimum
we know the Mr head no attorney had do
you know if there's a minimum child
support payment in law
all right that's fine
50. 50.
so 25 would be considerably under that
yeah and it's primarily for those
rounding errors of dividing something by
an odd number
yeah I brought up that uh excuse me
thank you Mr chairman I I brought that
up at the hearing whether this should be
fifty dollars or not because of that
reason
but you say it's
if it's based on artificial intelligence
that we're trying to correct then I
guess it doesn't matter
too much but we can always get a another
amendment
won't take long for them to do that well
I don't think he's interested in the
minimum payment of Child Support he is
interested in being not burned anymore
when something's off by two or three
cents anything I'm thinking of
Representative long
question representative long
so uh
yeah this is in regard to the passport
issue
I think so yeah in my understanding is
that it's a 2500 arrearage that
the feds
um
Implement that on your passport
so
but we were told that it was like four
dollars and something cents
so I I don't understand I I get the need
from what I heard the sponsor telling us
but it's not the case
unfortunately he is cheering fish and
game at the moment and cannot be
with US Representative desamoni
thank you Mr chairman the issue was the
4.89 or something like that
the what happened was
the feds contact
the state
when when they need to know whether a
person is in a rearage
and when the feds in that case did the
uh DHHS did not disclose the amount they
just said he was in arrears
period end and they did not disclose the
amount that he was in arrears that's
what happens all too frequently I I
agree with you about the twenty five
hundred dollars but that's not what
happened in this case and it's happened
in other cases he seems to be addressing
one problem not another in this
particular bill
and therefore not to be penalized for
not doing something that another bill
could have done
so anything further representative long
that's not so so this bill does nothing
to the issue that he had with the fit
because the feds aren't listening to our
25 or or
you know it could still happen if
nobody's given them the amount
representative D Simone for an answer
thank you but in this case the DHHS
would not be able to report that he was
in a marriages if it is less than the 25
they would not be able to tell the feds
yes he's in arrears they would have to
say he's up to date
representative Greg this is where her
daughter pays attention
or not
um I would like to get actually Claire
can we get clarification I know the
people that work with child support
services are here can we get
clarification on at what point they
would say because I believe it's higher
than four dollars and I did read the
federal statutes on that passport it
does not kick in until 2500 can we get
clarification from them please
is there anyone from Child Support
Services that can answer specifically
this point I think we're making this
more difficult than it is but let's
let's uh sure that's why they're here
good morning good morning
thank you Mr chairman
um and thank you representative Greg my
name is Lisa dakitowski Bureau of Child
Support Services Department of Health
and Human Services bureau chief
attorney Matthew Hayes staff attorney
for Bureau of Child Support
um if I understand the the question
correctly uh the question is uh what is
the exact amount of arrearages that the
federal offset program for passport
denial
criteria is the Bureau the Federal
Regulation is that when an uh or on a
rearage balance
is twenty five hundred dollars or more
does the uh
a rearage balance gets reported to the
federal offset program if all criteria
are met
so on that basis it would seem that this
bill may be addressing another issue and
not a passport issue
Perhaps Perhaps Perhaps yes Mr chairman
thank you
representative Greg
so if I I just want to make sure I
understand so if they're twenty five
hundred dollars that's when the federal
program kicks in to say the passport
can't happen however is there and that's
the state reporting to the federal
government correct that is correct that
is the requirement so is there a point
where the federal government like calls
and says like is there in a rearage and
you would say it's just a yes or no it's
not like oh it's four dollars or it's
fifty dollars
um thank you representative Greg for
that question in the event that an
obligor may have applied to have their
passport perhaps renewed or requested
for a new passport to be issued to them
if there is a indication on the federal
passport side that there may have been
in a rearage reported they may reach out
to the department to clarify whether the
case is or whether that a rearage is
still active and still eligible for the
continuation of the program
yeah representative long thank you Miss
chairman so
is there a time when you would tell
anybody even within the state somebody
going for their license a yes or no
without an amount
for example if this bill were to pass if
it was 24 you would have to say no
they're not in their marriage correct
so
thank you representative for the
question I I appreciate that
um let me just look at the amendment
again
well that's my understanding um that
this compli whether or not I don't know
I don't have never personally answered
that question I'm not I'm not a
caseworker but I know that this statute
it seems like the theme of this
executive session is that the statute we
wouldn't answer that Federal uh that we
wouldn't answer the federal entities
question by referencing the statute
most likely just give them near
rearrange and they would make their own
determination based on their own
regulations I don't think that we would
say uh somebody was in compliance or not
in compliance
in terms of this statute
are you stating that your regulations
Trump state law
should this pass into law
I guess I just don't have enough
information on exactly what the sponsor
was looking to get from us
I'm really not going to the bill as much
as I am your Pat your recent statement
you had said that if somebody asked you
you would make that determination on
your regulations and not on state law
and I'm challenging that statement
I guess I'm not really sure what's being
asked
I never I'm not sure what the specific
issues that we're addressing I'm just
saying that
I don't know I can't speak to whether or
not we're giving a yes or no answer to
some federal entity that's reached out
to us on an individual case that's fine
I mean you don't have to have the answer
to our question I just
and if you don't that's fine unless
um
akitasking has something to offer about
that point
um Mr chairman what I would offer is
that the Social Security Act does
require that states that are
administering the child support title 4D
program have within their state plan a
regular regulated provision uh in
reference to the collection of past due
support from federal tax refunds so the
title IV program uh does uh require that
states participate in that program
through the administration of
said program
thank you
all right does anybody remember why he
brought us this bill I mean the passport
2500 thing
seems to be a red herring and I have
terrible notes on this bill
representative panicked you remember
what he's trying to say
my God
representative speline was going to take
a trip
he needed to submit for his passport
yeah he was in the rears by one penny
right and because if he was in the Reyes
for one penny
his passport was denied because he was
yes or no in arrears by one cent
that's what he told that's what I
thought I remembered so I don't know
where this 2500 thing comes in then
representative D Simone the 2500 comes
in to where the federal government will
then attach your income tax return
as far as I I understand and they the 25
hundred dollars will at that point not
only attacks your tax return but it will
deny a passport in this particular case
he did not reach the 2500 Mark so they
did not attach his
um tax return however they did refuse
his passport okay which he had applied
for because he had to go to another
country because of his employer
uh that was a demand on the employer's
part representative Perez yeah I do have
a question because I believe I wasn't
here for the hearing and so this bill
was introduced Because unless they
represented it had an issue with his
passport or that something that happened
often in the like with our constituents
that's something that I you know I
wasn't here so I don't know this is a
personal issue and he introduced the
bill this is something that really
happens all the time and and that's why
we're doing we you know we introducing
this bill to be honest I just want to be
you know when I'm voting for something
or when I'm I'm thinking about a bill I
just want to make sure that we're doing
because this is going to help our
constituents
um no because you know it was affecting
one state representative
and and you know the personal matter
that's all I I want to know because I I
wasn't here so thank you representative
Grossman
I came in at the end of this day's
testimony were there any other
books that came forward with issues
related to this the clerk will be
checking on that and if anyone else has
a another comment or question while he's
doing that
um you can do it now representative D
Simone thank you Mr chair I I just
honestly find it very difficult to
believe that
this is a one-person issue if it's
happening to one person we don't know
how many other people that it's
happening to because not everybody
realizes that they can come to the
legislature to get it fixed
um so I I personally find it difficult
to believe that it's a one-person issue
I do remember at work I periodically
oversee my billing department and
um there was somebody whose wage wound
up being let's just pick an arbitrary
number uh
699.99 and she trotted her check over to
me and said I thought I got 700 and we
had a good laugh on that and looked at
it'll probably come out at
700.4 cents in a few months and we
laughed at that uh because she she
thought it would be funny and it was and
so it does happen but if there's
penalties saying you're under
699.99 technically I suppose means we
underpaid her that month and don't tell
anybody I just said that because we
don't do it now we made sure we don't do
it now just in case but so yeah I would
kind of think this would be the case
representative
um Perino
only representative Spillane spoke in
support of the of his bill there was one
other individual who did speak but
testimony was irrelevant and one other
um
folks in front of us spoke in opposition
okay
I think my opinion is this may not
address other issues but it seems to
address this issue for one person in my
assumption it would be a few others too
and it isn't going to hurt anybody if we
pass it
Mr chairman May the bureau be excused
I'm sorry man up here will be excused
you may be excused thank you so much
would you like me to write a note that
you were of great importance to this
exact session for the people who pay you
0.99 cents a month thank you well I I
would like to call the question here
um seeing no objection the question at
hand is auto pass is amended by
Amendment zero six one seven H moved by
the chairman and seconded by
representative panic and we are now
voting on the amendment zero six one
seven with the chair please call the
roll
I mean with the clerk please call the
chairman Pearson yes
Vice chairman long no
representative DeSimone yes
representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
Seidel yes representative Grossman no
representative representative Levesque
no representative Petrino no
representative Perez no
representative Greg no
representative Moulton no
representative Raymond no
that would be eight to eight on the vote
eight
yeah the amendment fails and now we will
be considering the bill unamended
House Bill 548 FN
move by representative Pearson and
seconded by representative panic
the clerk may call the rule
representative I'm sorry chairman
Pearson yes
Vice chairman long no
representative DeSimone yes
representative Bickford
representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes
representative Seidel yes
representative Grossman
no
representative Levesque
no representative Petrino no
representative Perez
no representative Greg no representative
Moulton no
representative Raymond no
the motion fails seven to nine
we need to have a positive
motion and that will be itl
if somebody would choose to move
itl on the bill we have to have a a
motion going forward that has a larger
number first
I'll make the motion representative
Raymond moves
itl is there a second
second representative Perez
the motion before us is an expedient to
legislate on House Bill 548f and would
the clerk please call the roll
represent chairman Pearson no
Vice chairman long yes
representative DeSimone
no
representative Bickford yes
sorry my time just ran out
okay representative Nelson
no
representative McMahon no
representative ball no representative
Panic no
representative Seidel no
representative Grossman yes
representative Levesque yes
representative Petrino yes
representative
Perez
yes
representative Greg yes
representative Moulton yes
representative Raymond yes
the motion itl passes nine to seven the
chair would ask representative Raymond
if she wishes to write the committee
report yes that's fine if you could pass
me the sheet I will take care of it at
lunch time
and I will write the minority reports so
it is seven to nine uh
what's up
don't put this here right
I don't put that there I just do this
and I put the bill number
I know yeah okay I know we are
this ends the
um
executive session and a house bill five
four eights
it's all right
something there we won't take them for a
while
so if you did the um
yep
since we are about 45 minutes late
I am going to defer the rest of the
executive session to
I hope later today
and with that uh do you have a regular
calendar
thank you
it's ordered pens
thanks
and now open the
hearing
we've moved off of the executive session
people we are now on the hearing on
House Bill
475 establishing a right to submit
evidence and testimony in Family Court
proceedings the chair
recognizes representative post to
present your bill
and I'm going to make an executive
discussion and a decision in our reset
House Bill 475 until the prime sponsor
can present her bill we are already also
running late on the next bill which is
uh 4 17.
and uh
thank you
chair now opens
the hearing on House Bill 417 and the
chair calls representative testerman to
present his bill for 17.
we also have a pink card from Emma
savini that does not list a house bill
number on it and if she is present she
may come and fill it out come on up
Mr chairman
yes
seeing as we have a lot of speakers can
we present the bill just so that we can
start hearing the speakers
would somebody wish to some a Committee
Member who's likely to be
you want to do it
okay
I mean I'm willing to do it too I mean
sure
Mr chairman forgive me if I for not
knowing how to do this but I do you are
doing a better job than the prime
sponsor so far do I just read the bill
the title all right
um
just give me a second
you want the bill no I've got it I can
just oh wait I just I typed in 417 I
have to type in HB 417. Okay so
um
House Bill 417
says an act relevant relative to the
definition of child abuse
that's it okay well done thank you for
teaching me how to do it thank you
let me say at the outset is Chairman
that there is a much bigger bill on
an aspect of this subject being
presented in Representatives Hall at
this moment and there will be all day
on two bills on this very subject I've
discussed this with a number not all but
a number of members of this committee
and my inclination is when it comes to
an executive session I will push for
retention because many of us were of the
conclusion this is an evolving subject
let my former Committee in reps Hall
have all the fun with this and we can
look at it later that's just me speaking
but that's letting people at the outset
know where I would hope we will go down
the road I'll second that
I've got a whole bunch of pink cards
and here's the rules of the road
you get to speak for two minutes
two write it out ahead of time
because at a minute and 45 I'm gonna go
like this and that means you have 15
seconds at which point
the reason we do that is not to be mean
but to be fair
there are people who I know in these um
hearings with a lot of strong opinion
and pink cards measured in inches
that people have taken a day off to come
and if it comes to five o'clock and
we're still on a subject and more than
half of the committee has left
that's because somebody spoke for 15
minutes before you and before them and
before them and before them
and that means you who took a day off
you'll speak to an almost empty room and
I don't want to do that that is not fair
to you
so as a result irrespective of what
one's views are on any particular
subject
we have adopted in the house this kind
of a protocol
so you get two minutes
if you have written copies
when your name is called please bring
the written copies to representative
Bickford and then he will pass them
around and then go to your seat there's
a little button you push and when your
microphone and turns red that means your
mic is on
so two minutes irrespective of what you
wrote on the card it is a two-minute
speech Mr chairman yes
if you don't mind can I just very
quickly say something yeah
I would like to say thank you to
everyone who's here to SFI and and I'm
hope and I'm hoping that everyone
remember that we're talking about humans
and then we talking about a person and
then we all keep it respectfully
and up I believe humans deserve dignity
and respect and I hopefully we keep it
that way
thank you and this is true for those who
disagree with yep as well thank you for
that representative I very much
appreciate that
chair the chair calls uh Frank Knack and
you have written testimony please drop
it off with representative Bickford and
the clock starts once your mic is turned
on
and you may begin thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee for the
opportunity to testify today my name is
Frank kinack I'm the policy director
with the ACLU New Hampshire we are here
in opposition to HB 417 as you as you
know I'll know there's a lot of people
here behind me so I hope that you all
just take some time to read the fact
sheet that I handed out it really points
the the fact
um that not from the ACLU perspective
but from the perspective of major public
health and medical associations this is
a dangerous Bill if you look in the
footnotes of the fact sheet I handed out
you'll see from the American Academy of
Pediatrics American Psychological
Association American Association School
psychologists the American Association
of medical colleges and the American
Medical Association all have deep
concerns with any policy like this
because it'll harm our youth uh our
trans youth in New Hampshire
so I urge you to heed their warnings and
oppose this Bill thank you very much
thank you sir appreciate
you made your point and to the point and
you were quite brief thank you so much
the chair now recognizes Stephen is it
Lafond or Le Ford
Lafond yeah
and you have written a testimony too
thanks everybody my name is Stephen
lafon I live in Concord I was born and
raised 15 minutes from here my
grandfather owned the Park Street Barber
Shop for about 40 years just right here
by the State House
I'm a father I'm politically independent
I'm a homeowner and I oppose this bill
so many of the new and incumbent members
of this Governor body ran on a platform
of parental rights
one of them who is my aunt let you know
that everyone should be able to make
their own choices regarding medical
decisions for themselves and their
children
this tiny little bill with a fiscal
impact Ledger larger than they changed
the law itself is not doing that
the way it's sold to the hard-working
people of our state is that you're
protecting pre-adolescents from a
radical agenda and irreversible
surgeries it goes after medication
Interventional therapy and is vague
enough that every parent that is looking
to do what they can to even just to
understand what their kid is going
through the mental health care can be
put at risk as well
we're told it's a major epidemic
here's some stats that I'm in clinical
research that I can give you based on
Reuters and Komodo Medical
over five five year period there's only
been about 121 882 kids that are
diagnosed with gender dysphoria
that's Nationwide
in that time less than 5 000 reported to
be gone any puberty blockers less than 4
300 started hormone therapy in the last
year
there's only 282 instances of adolescent
surgery and the scary one that
everybody's worried about the one below
the belt only 56 of any genital
surgeries for adolescents zero for any
under
I want to compare that to something that
might be a little embarrassing for some
of the gentlemen here in the state alone
eighty percent of people born
biologically male we all had
circumcision
we were babies
we didn't make this cultural and
religious Choice it didn't make us more
men
it's a ridiculous idea
but my parents did it because they're
good folks it was with our cultural
ideas that were in mind and it was
protected
but they also raised me to stand up to
the idea of pushy folks that think Live
Free or Die was expressing a preference
for our neighbors who don't agree with
us do the latter
so I'm just advising you as a taxpayer
and proper your own owner just keep
investigating this bill run from it it's
not too late to stand for the Liberty
that we're trying to instill in our kids
thank you
would you take a question or two happily
all right
I recall from testimony on some previous
bills
from folks who
often vote opposite to me sure the
quotes
I don't always trust children to make
the right decision for themselves and
quote I don't always trust parents to
make the right decision for their
children and quote we need a village
um how do you square those and that's an
honest question I like that I like that
question
and here's why
I was
I'm not a Democrat
for my folks they were basically
squaring the idea of what they wanted to
do for vaccination for Mass mandates for
keeping our people free
if my kid's gonna mask they're gonna
mask I'm not gonna make your kid I'm not
gonna make your kid do it it's
ridiculous
that said if I have multiple doctors a
therapist and everyone else looking into
what's going on with my child
and they're like this isn't a phase
I'm a skeptic I'll keep going
as a parent you don't jump into things
carefully and you don't lazily just hope
it's gonna work out
I don't think anyone doing this is like
high-fiving and running their way to the
surgery table
did that answer your question sir
very well thank you sir I appreciate
your answer any other questions
representative Bickford thank you Mr
chairman thank you you've stated a few
statistics here you could go back and
repeat those for me so I could jot that
down absolutely I've also had them you
only had like five handles I guess I
only had six to be fair but I'm happy to
give you mine please
oh okay I'm literally gonna give it to
you I thought they were
oh yeah absolutely 56
yeah sure I'll give it to you so this is
this is actually coming from the Reuters
report that was done with Komodo medical
sure from what Reuters Reuters and
Komodo medical they are a they're an
investigative medical firm sir
okay uh we are running very short of
staff today because of the large group
in reps Hall okay what we will be doing
I hope at the end of the hearing over
the lunch hour is somebody will be
running the reports where there weren't
20 copies uh to a photocopier to get
enough for everybody else
so my contact information is on the pink
sheet I'm happy to send it for you
okay thank you thank you
and thank you for your testimony thank
you chair recognizes Holly Stevens from
Nami a frequent visitor to our committee
chairman Pierce members of the committee
my name is Holly Stevens I'm the
director of public policy for Nami New
Hampshire I'll try to keep this brief
because there's a I know there's a lot
of people behind me
um who aren't wearing
an orange badge who want to speak today
we know that right now we're we have a
mental health crisis with our youth we
know that our suicide rates are rising
um
the yrbs survey in 2018
showed that hang on a second
18.8 percent of New Hampshire High
School students seriously considered
suicide in 8.9 attempted that we know
that there's a small substitute subset
of that group of individuals who have
even higher rates of suicide and that is
the lgbtq plus Community
a bill like this only goes to disaffirm
their own identity and and in a sense
attacks it and I do find it a little bit
ironic as you just heard and this will
be my last point I think of the day
that there are two bills being heard
today on parental rights
and this bill would devoid parents of
their rights and as far as taking a
village I mean I think you heard that
the villages the doctors the therapists
the parents the the Family Support
around those kids
it doesn't need government interference
so Nami New Hampshire is in opposition
to this Bill thank you
representative Nelson with a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my questions it's a quick one
um what was that survey you referenced
the youth behavioral risk survey it's a
survey that's done every two years in
the in the schools the youth behavioral
risk risk survey thank you you're
welcome
and
thank you so much thank you
chair recognizes uh Richard Owen embley
and your testimony is one copy yes would
you object once you hand it to the clerk
after you're done that we photocopy it
that's fine
as a disclosure I do not own stock in a
paper company but I should
uh good morning thank you for having me
my name is Dr Richard Owen emberly I
live here in Concord
um I'm going to shorten my comments for
the sake of time I would like to say
that every major medical organization
both in America and around the world all
supports gender affirm and care and to
answer your question
um chairman is not just a child's
decision it's not just a parent's
decision there are multiple medical
providers who are also making these
decisions and we're all trained on this
this isn't made up this isn't something
new this is something that's support and
backed by a lot of research I'd like to
just read my last statement here
hb417 seeks to add sexual reassignment
to the definition of an abused child as
a health care worker who has reviewed
the literature on gender affirming care
it is very clear to me that gender
affirming care is not child abuse in
fact when considering the increased
risks of depression and suicide that
come with denying gender affirming care
it would appear that denying appropriate
gender affirming care is child abuse
thank you
and thank you doctor and if you could
bring up your testimony to the clerk
that's either one
thank you
chair recognizes Amelia Brock
excuse me I'm quite nervous
hello my name is Emily Brock
I'm sorry
and I am a mother to two teenagers one
who is transgender
I am speaking today in opposition to
hb417 to project my child my family
and others like ours whose parental
rights will be taken away if this bill
becomes law
his every parent's responsibility to
ensure that they do all they can to keep
their child healthy in fact to ignore a
health concern of your child is
consistent considered neglect a form of
child abuse
if my child had cancer or diabetes or
bipolar disease the state of New
Hampshire would require and expect that
I make every effort to see that my child
received appropriate Medical Care
a transgender child who has been
clinically diagnosed by medical
professionals with gender dysphoria is
no different than a kid with cancer or
bipolar it is a medical condition
as a responsible parent
under New Hampshire law I am obliged to
provide access to medical care for my
child
if this law were to pass the state of
New Hampshire would require that my
husband and myself deny our child the
necessary medical care that has been
recommended To Us by board certified New
Hampshire licensed medical doctors and
psychologists
therefore causing us to our neglect our
child
this law proposes that a small number of
politicians know more about taking care
of my child than me my husband my
child's primary care doctor psychologist
and endocrinologist
as far as I know none of you are
licensed psychologists or
endocrinologists and have never met my
child
the government does not know what is
best for my child my husband and I do
would you criminalize a parent of a
child with cancer because they chose a
medical treatment that a politician did
not like
the arrogance of this bill is astounding
some politicians are putting a sick
Twist on this hateful Bill to say they
are proposing these laws to protect
innocent children
we all know this is a pack of Lies
the true intent of this bill bills like
hb417 is to shame and scare transgender
children and push them back into the
closet
are you aware that transgender children
teenagers in particular have the highest
risk of suicide of all children 82
percent of transgender teens have been
suicidal over 40 percent have attempted
suicide you've got 15 seconds now the
statistic from this National Library of
Medicine
proposed laws like hb417 that are meant
to shame and scare transgender children
and their families will only cause more
distress to an already very vulnerable
population of children this law
supposedly protects innocent children
Lives May in fact be the thing that
causes children to take their own and
now would you wish to hand that
testimony would you like us to have
copies of it okay if you could hand it
to the end please thank you so much the
chair now recognizes Dr Jennifer Smith
from Pembroke
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I do not have written
testimony
um I want to strongly urge you to itl
this bill the last time this I think
identical text was heard in this
committee it went to the floor 20-0 was
supposed to be on consent calendar
though it was pulled off
and this is ridiculous how long will we
have to continue to make the case that
this is care that is done carefully it
involves parents if there's going to be
any unless there's a appointed Guardian
for someone who has had to flee their
parents
and it it does not make any sense
that one would call this child abuse not
only am I transgender I have extended
family members in the generation that
this would affect who are also
transgender
thank God their parents are very
supportive of them as are the rest of
their Community their parents have
gathered and yes everything takes a
community
people who live in communities that are
abusive need to be held to account our
community among people who are
transgender and the supporting allies is
not abusive
we are careful
we listen to others
and we help people make the decisions
that are very hard to make and 15
seconds doctor I'm done and I'll be
happy to take any questions
thank you so much I remember you
testifying before Health and Human
Services numbers of times uh do you wish
to take a question from representative
Moulton absolutely
thank you Mr chairman I'm just wondering
um what you're you're a doctor of oh I'm
a family medical practitioner and I have
a public health degree which I put on my
pink card but the chairman failed to
mention that I do a lot of research and
I've done a lot of research on
transgender stuff because I am
transgender and have relatives who are
in friends who are so thank you very
much
and thank you so much doctor the chair
recognizes Ryan aquilina
if you'd like us to have copies of it uh
we're buying a paper mill
welcome two minutes thank you
oh there we go thank you so much for
your time and for hearing Our Testimony
today
um I'm a licensed clinical mental health
counselor in the state of New Hampshire
I was born and raised here in The Lakes
Region and I currently live in
Manchester with my spouse
um and I run a group practice of 25
clinicians
I write to you today appalled by the
very idea of hb417 and anybody who works
uh to protect children in the state
should be as well in my opinion
I find fault with several points in this
bill and I will outline them quickly for
you here
so the process that any person has to go
through including minors to obtain any
kind of gender confirming care is
extensive
it starts with somebody's primary care
provider but then they have to get
hooked up with mental health clinicians
and then an endocrinologist and there
have to be letters written this is an
intentional process and it's
evidence-based
and somebody doesn't just wake up one
day and decide that they're trans and
then poof they get all the medical care
that they need that's necessary that's
not how this works
um
but even going through the
evidence-based process there are still
many providers who will not provide
gender confirming care
a child who approaches their caregiver
requesting these Services sets in motion
a chain of events involving all the
things that I just
um talked about
and it has to start with consent of the
caregivers the caregiver has to be given
the autonomy to be able to consent to
their child being given these services
um to assume that children would be
subjected to this is false and it's also
discriminatory
also statistically providing gender
affirming care as some of my colleagues
have stated up here already can
literally save the lives of those who
receive it
suicide is the second leading cause of
death in people ages 13 to 24 in the
state of New Hampshire
lgbtqia plus youth are four times more
likely to attempt suicide than their
peers
there's a suicide attempt of an lgbtqia
plus youth approximately every 45
seconds
45 of lgbtqia Youth have seriously
considered attempting suicide in the
past year and more than half of them
transgender or non-binary
that statistic Rises sharply with
lgbtqia plus youth who live in homes
where they do not feel supported by
their caregivers and their families
next I want to talk about enforceability
as a clinical mental health counselor
who works primarily with kids
I interface with dcyf consistently
you have about 20 seconds okay
um dtyf has a difficult job to be sure
um and the way that current child
protection laws are written dcyf is
tasked with sometimes impossible
standards already and so how are we
going to add this to their plate and
expect them to to continue to be
effective when the laws are written in
fact in a way that makes them not as
effective as they could be one more
sentence yep
um so
it can be a complex compound sentence
um
I don't necessarily think I have the
bandwidth for complex because I'm going
to the other hearing as well but thank
you so much for your time I really
appreciate you on the way over would you
take one question please yes I do have a
staff of Family Practice
providers and counselors so I'm just the
liberal arts guy in the building yeah
you know but I have asked them this
question
about how many
youngsters
age 10 11 12 13.
have a
same-sex affection
or a sense of
I'm something other that then transition
out
in your research because I have mine
so
in my research which we I glean a lot
from
um the Trevor Project so if any of you
are interested that's a really great
resource the Trevor Project
um
I don't know because and it's hard to
look at it from my experience because
like we work the practice that I work in
and as my practice as well we work on
the exploration process okay we kind of
let it be what it's going to be as
opposed to saying oh this person's going
to transition or this person's not okay
yeah
folks that may have had a sense for and
I'm trying to use polite word I really
sure am and there's so many impolite
words all over the place
folks youngsters who feel a certain way
for a month or two or three or a year
and then don't feel that way anymore
um is a statistic too and you know like
I said I've got some it sounds like your
practice is not with that population
it is and it isn't because we encourage
exploration of that because it's a
normal developmental process sure the
explosion of gender and sexuality is
absolutely normal so we encourage that
okay we don't necessarily
we don't necessarily actually take data
on how many of those people come out as
lgbtqia plus okay yeah appreciate that
thank you
yes
so thank you so much and the chair is
now looking for
uh I think it's Henry Feldman a
counselor named Henry Feldman
my handwriting is not the best that's
all right I deal with medical people by
day
um and if you have written testimony
when you finish you can pass it put it
on rep representative Bickford's place
thank you are you all concerned they
call me Henry if you need to that's no
problem
um I actually have an answer to the
previous question sir if you'd like it
um there was research done uh
came out in the summer of 2022 that said
that generally kids who start a social
what we call a social transition
um will
97.4 of them will persist into
um a medical transition at some point in
their life so the clinical standard is
insistence consistence and persistence
and so what that data tracked was kids
five years after initiating a social
transition
this is for transgender not same-sex
attraction right so okay thank you I
just wanted to get absolutely yep kids
who are assigned a gender at Birth as we
all are and then assert that their
assignment at Birth was incorrect
okay sure
um my name is Harvey Feldman thank you
to the committee for hearing my
testimony I am from Concord I'm here
today to voice my strong opposition to
House Bill 417 I'm a licensed therapist
in New Hampshire and I have clinical
expertise in working with lgbtq youth
and their families every day I see the
life-saving nature of gender affirming
care and if there ever was an opposite
to child abuse and neglect gender
affirming care would be it before I
entered Private Practice I was a
clinician working primarily with youth
in systems of care and partnered often
with dcyf offices and workers throughout
the state I've seen child abuse and
neglect up close and spent the early
part of my career supporting families
through the process of reunification
when possible and Foster Care and
Adoption when it wasn't
the dcyf workers I had the chance to get
to know during those years were some of
the most dedicated professionals I've
ever seen and their commitment to Youth
and Care was and is unending
this bill quite frankly is horrifying it
would require those already over taxed
workers to open cases investigate
families and perhaps remove youth from
loving safe families if systems of care
in New Hampshire were functioning at a
hundred percent capacity and perfect
this bill would still be horrifying
however I can say confidently that the
system is broken there are not enough
caseworkers safe Foster families or
clinical resources to support the amount
of children and families in the system
now today
lgbtq youth who are in systems of care
are already disproportionately subject
to discriminatory harmful practices
including conversion therapy and tactics
and removing them from safe affirmative
homes is truly one of the most unethical
unsafe decisions I can imagine
as a licensed therapist this bill would
require me to report families who are
accessing gender affirming care care
that is accepted to be the safest and
most protective families can give to
their children it might require another
provider to report me for practicing
ethically and within clinical standards
as I said I've seen child abuse up close
and equating gender affirming care to
what I've had to witness is deeply
deeply offensive just give you 20
seconds to wrap it up okay if this bill
were to pass it would mean that the
therapists and providers would have to
choose between ethical practice and
state law thank you very much and I urge
you to retain or kill or stop this bill
please thank you if you'd like us all to
have copies please sure and I'm
available for questions if folks have
them now or later
representative Bickford uh thank you Mr
chairman I have a nagging question
please do you need to ask a question
they're getting really tight on us
asking questions
okay
um why does it need to be done at a
pubistant as opposed to at the adult age
do you mean what can you just tell me
what it is
um why is the issue here is because it's
done below at the younger than 18. right
why does it need to be done at that time
as opposed to waiting until they're
adults well what we know from research
is that mental health outcomes improve
significantly when kids can access
medical affirming care and so the why is
because anxiety depression self-harm
Health disparities all go down when kids
can access medically affirming care so
you might be asking why medically and
I'm answering with a mental health
outcome because the data is very clear
that mental health outcomes are
significantly better for kids who can go
through medical transition when they're
ready to do so
and we don't in this country as far as I
know
um there's no other medical care that's
divided out by age this way there might
be different phases of it or different
steps in it but there's no other
prohibition I know of around 18 versus
not 18. there are kids who get breast
augmentation there are um kids who go on
puberty blockers for precocious puberty
all that happens earlier in their life
than 18 and so I think we also have to
ask why we surveil and question certain
kinds of medical care and not others
thank you thank you
representative Nelson thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking
um my question
um I'm a big like survey and data junkie
so I was just curious
um I I wanted to know more about
um if you could tell me or remember you
know that the um
the statistic the 97.4 percent continued
to transition can you tell me where you
yeah remember where you got that from
yeah so it's called the trans youth
project it was initially started out of
uh University of Washington and then the
researcher Christina Olsen moved to
Princeton and that's where she is now
and it's the first
um it's the first longitudinal study of
trans youth over time so we have so if
you're a gender nerd like me we have the
five-year data came out in 2022 we'll
have more data in five years so she's
essentially the trans youth project as
this cohort of kids growing into adults
and she's going to follow them and so
that initial data was 97.4 okay great I
appreciate that and I was actually
typing what you were saying I don't know
what you think I was being rude okay no
no representative panic
thank you uh chairman Pearson for allow
me to ask the question
and thank you for taking the time to
come up here and explain things to us
sure
um
you said that the five-year dad just
came in at 2022. and this it was
released published in the summer of
2018. so how long have these studies
been going on that the puberty blockers
and hormone therapy
is the correct answer right to introduce
it to these children that are like 10 13
years old so we've been using maybe not
me personally but you know the big we
have been using puberty blockers for
what we call precocious puberty since
1980.
um and that's for kids who are not
transgender but medically enter into
puberty before they should
um and so they're given puberty blockers
to stop that from happening and then
they stop they stop taking the blockers
that are puberty resumed so we have that
data from 1980
across hormone therapy and puberty
blockers for Trans kids we can trace
that probably back to the late 80s early
90s and so it is correct that we don't
have you know 40 or 40 or 50 year
longitudinal data on this what we do
have is the statistics and the
information about self-harm and suicide
follow-up
thank you
um
the puberty blockers and the hormone
therapy that are being prescribed yep
um
are these FDA approved
for that specific
or are you using this like off label I'm
going to consult with a doctor
I thought yeah it's it's off label so it
is if so I guess I would say it's FDA
approved but use
off label it's not going to say it
yep there's lots of things sure sure so
yes it is used off label
like ivermectin for example yeah thank
you that's a good example
um
I think there's many more I'm blanking
on them but there's many more
okay
thank you so much Council appreciate the
testimony the chair now recognizes Emma
savini from new futures
um thank you as stated my name is Emma
savini I'm the children's Behavioral
Health policy coordinator at new Futures
my comments have largely been stated by
The Fabulous folks who've spoken so far
and I'm sure others would appreciate
having a little extra time so I'm going
to yield my time and just underscore the
importance that this bill should be uh
voted in inexpedient to legislate and
that the gender affirming care is not
child abuse and is in fact critical of
care for children's who need positive
mental health outcomes thank you so much
and welcome back thank you
and now the chair calls Beth margison
from dcyf another regular
you know committee if you've been in a
committee for a while you get to know
who comes and comes well prepared and
even if you disagree
um can take good questions so welcome
thank you very much Mr chair and members
of the committee I appreciate your time
to speak this morning I'll be very brief
I do not have written comments uh dcyf
is in opposition to this bill it does
not consider gender uh assignment
procedures or surgeries to be a form of
child abuse and I'm willing to take any
questions if anybody has any
thank you I'm very grateful for that
to be honest
the chair is going to disagree with that
we've appreciated your answers to our
questions chair recognizes sales Karsten
from the New Hampshire youth movement
okay
and you've got written testimony and if
you want us to each have a copy you can
pass it down at the end if if you don't
that's okay too and you got two minutes
perfect thank you uh on sales Captain I
live in Dover I'm here representing New
Hampshire youth movement a Youth
Organization with many trans student
members uh should this bill pass parents
who follow Professional Medical guidance
and from the gender identity of their
children would be charged with child
abuse it's the ridiculous attack on
chance gender transgender children and
supportive parents and it would result
in young people across the state not
being able to receive gender affirming
medical care when needed I think there's
a lot of misinformation about what it
means and looks like for young people to
go through a gender transition and I
hope to clear some of that up
gender transitions are not child abuse
there's consensus among medical
researchers that gender transitions
effectively treat gender dysphoria and
improve the well-being of transgender
individuals by far the most common of
these treatments among youth is hormone
blockers which are pills or shots that
delay the effects of puberty the effect
of hormone blockers is entirely
reversible and the use of blockers is
associated with improve improving
overall well-being reducing depression
self-harm anxiety and suicidal thoughts
and social interactions with other kids
in addition in many situations all
parties agree that a transition is a
good idea parents are supportive of
their child transitioning the child or
young person wants to wants to
transition and the medical professional
involved is also supportive
in a situation where parents the
individual and the medical professional
are all on the same page why should the
state be involved at all no one is being
unharmed and everyone is in agreement
gender transitions are well researched
safe procedures that improve the
well-being of a transgender person we
aren't asking for a lot we're only
asking for the government to stay out of
people's personal medical business
please itl hb417 and thank you
next time you come you get 15 extra
seconds thank you
thank you
and the chair recognizes Amy Whitney
from Ghost Town
hello I do not have a written testimony
I was actually inspired while sitting
there that I wanted to say something so
I'm going to wing it with some notes I
made on my phone I am here as the mother
of a transgender teenager
while I've done my research over the
years I am not here with data or figures
I am here to tell you what this parent
what being what this what being a
transparent trans my goodness gracious
I am here to tell you what being a
parent of a transgender teen is for me
it means watching your child withdraw
into themselves without any idea why it
means learning that your child is
self-harming without any idea why
it means fearing that your child could
take their own life without any idea why
I have always been an open-minded Ally
even received awards for that when I was
working before I had children but when
my son finally told me that he was my
son and not my daughter I internally
freaked out I sobbed in private I talked
to my therapist I dove into research and
I hoped this wasn't real
and none of that was because I wasn't
willing to accept what I was being told
by my son but because I knew that his
life would suddenly be so much harder
that he would be bullied and
discriminated against and I feared for
his future and his safety
over time through continued therapy soul
searching and open communication that
I'm lucky enough to have with my son
I came to accept that this was his truth
he wasn't transgender because it was fun
I think it is in fact far from that for
him
he was transgender because he was simply
born in a body that didn't match who he
is and he finally had a voice and an
understanding to share that with us
I love my son unconditionally I would
die for him
and by supporting and providing him with
access to affirming care that is not
what child abuse is to me that is what
being a loving parent is
thank you
if you wish to hand the phone over to
representative Bickford we will make 20
little phones and pass them around I'll
email it to you thank you
chair recognizes Erica Perez from the
New Hampshire youth movement
hi I'm Erica Perez I'm a director at New
Hampshire youth movement this is
testimony written
from one of our members if I get cut off
it has been emailed to all of you
already
um
I'm writing to ask you to oppose hb417
my formative years were not my best I
faced regular emotional abuse I was
molded to believe that I was not good
enough in any regard my grades were not
good enough my interests were not good
enough and my personality was not good
enough when I let it slip that I might
be bisexual I faced its high rate of
slurs that drove me out of my home
I learned to never let it slip that I am
transgender
all of this led me to being an adult
struggling with my sense of self the one
thing I know is that if I had parents
that were accepting of being back then
my entire life would have been different
and I would be in a better place now
I'm telling you this because there are
thousands of children across the country
with parents like mine children who will
not be supported in their interest and
Endeavor and face backlash for not being
an exact replica of their parents and
who might be put in dangerous situations
if it comes out that they're a member of
the lgbtq plus community and then there
are children whose parents are the
opposite they are warm loving and
accepting no matter what this bill will
criminalize those types of parents while
the parents who really do abuse their
kids will likely never have to face the
same consequences this is wrong gender
affirming care is life-saving especially
for young kids we're not talking about
things like surgeries gender affirming
surgeries are incredibly rare for Trans
children as it is with things like
hormone blockers can make all the
difference to Insurance child's mental
health therefore their life path
the parents who understand this and take
appropriate action should not be
punished they are doing what the parent
is supposed to do they are taking care
of their child that they brought into
this world not only not everyone is born
into a family that will accept and
support them which is terrible
enough reality you have 15 seconds
please okay
um those who are lucky enough to receive
that type of love should be able to
basket it not worried about their
parents being reported to CPS anyways
please
itlhb14 14.
417. thank you thank you
chair recognizes Ben Cramer
I have a copy of this and you can feel
free to make options too thank you
well hi everyone my name is Ben Kramer
I'm a resident of Newmarket here to
testify in opposition to this bill I
worked with young people and children
for about five years as a camp counselor
adventure trip leader and camp director
those years were the single most
impactful experience I've had giving me
insight into lives and experiences of
young people and children worked
extremely closely with kids ages 6 to 18
and their parents I also have a degree
in outdoor education
I know kids who are navigating being
transgender at a young age
some were presenting as their true
gender for the first time at Camp some
had recently begun receiving gender
affirming Health Care those children who
for the first time were seen as their
authentic selves were some of the
happiest kids I've worked with and their
parents some of the most loving I've
ever met
I've also known children experiencing
abuse and neglect
I've interacted with parents who were
abusive I've reported suspected child
abuse as a mandated reporter I was
trained extensively in how to recognize
it and trained others
the experiences of these children
experiencing abuse could not be more
different than the trans kids being
affirmed in their identity those parents
are not the same
not once did I as a mandated reporter
and a child care professional consider
that abusive parents and parents who
affirm their trans child would both be
abusive because they are simply not
as a parent affirming their trans child
is the exact opposite of abuse they
could not be more dissimilar affirming a
child's identity is an act of love and
support to classify it as abuse is
simply wrong
urge the committee to vote in experience
legislate or retain this Bill thank you
thank you sir
chair recognizes Kendra Ford
well hold on ah there we are
good morning I will email my testimony
to you
I'm Reverend Kendra Ford and I am a
Unitarian Universalist Minister I served
the congregation in Exeter for 21 years
and now I am a climate activist with 350
New Hampshire
what kind of activist climate claimant
climate I'm sorry climate change is the
issue I am working on but I am also here
for this bill because
standing up for life on this planet is
part of my work in the world
so I oppose this bill strongly
because
because I'm here for life and for love
and for making sure that life gets to
bloom in its fullness and its complexity
I think it's important that religious
people stand up even in this context
maybe especially in this context to say
that in our society at Large
the religious claim includes this claim
that being lgbtq is just life being in
full bloom
so you've heard from the medical
professionals you've heard from the
mental health professionals you've heard
the statistics and the studies all of
which support that gender transition is
just part of life
and I want to tell you something about
my religious tradition in particular
which is that Covenant is really
important to us Covenant is a promise
that we make in community
promise about how we'll live together
and how we'll live in this world
and one of the pieces of our covenant is
to respect the inherent worth and
dignity of each person
that means letting each person discover
who they are in community and you've
heard that described now about gender
transition over and over again that it
isn't something that's just someone
wakes up someday and says oh let's do
this
it's something that they discover very
deeply about themselves and I think many
humans find that their gender isn't a
really important part of their identity
and we want that acknowledged and
expressed in community
and so of course that's going to be rich
and varied in this life so
in my Covenant
I affirm that for all people and I
affirm people to find their own way with
that
with support in community so the folks
who wrote this bill maybe want to take
care of children
which is such a great thing and there
are so many ways to do that I've heard
from people from dcyf today they could
use a lot of funding and some funding
for that department would help a lot of
children
we could increase food subsidies we
could increase school funding we could
increase mental health funding in our
state those are things that would really
protect children
and I hope that those things can be
taken up and done so that we can indeed
take care of people well in our culture
thank you
thank you any questions
see you none thank you
next I'll call up
Lori walnock
good morning my name is Lori Warnock and
I live in Hampstead I wanted to
specifically address a comment made by
representative Pearson I'm sorry he
stepped out of the room when he equated
the use of ivermectin and its off-label
use with the use of FDA approved and
long used and tested medical
interventions to prolong the development
of secondary sex characteristics which
is a temporary and reversible process
that has been used medically and has
been used by medical practitioners and
recommended by medical practitioners as
opposed to the use of horse paste as an
unproven method of preventing or
treating covid-19 while Ivermectin is in
some cases available for human use it is
not in any way shape or form used
previously for the prevention of virus
transmission it's used to treat
parasites I think it was a very false
equivalent to compare a drug that has
been used off label recommended
predominantly for animals in an untested
manner
to compare that to the use of FDA
approved medications in the appropriate
way for which they were developed and
have been tested and have been applied
as a comparison when we're talking about
identifying child abuse this is an
appropriate medical treatment it has
been long practiced and proven these are
medications which have been proven safe
in exactly this age group for exactly
this purpose so I think to create the
impression that the off-label use of
these appropriate medications that are
in fact reversible so that a child as
they grow can fully realize their
identity and make their own decisions as
older children or adolescents or adults
comparing that to the off-label use of a
veterinary medicine
is inappropriate
I work as an educator for the Northern
New England poison Center I'm speaking
on behalf of myself today not as a
representative of the poison Center but
I can tell you we have seen over the
past five years a dramatic increase in
suicide attempts and self-harm among
younger and younger children and I
cannot stress the fact that anything we
do to jeopardize their mental health
when especially when we're talking about
a system that is already under serving
this population
would constitute child abuse and I thank
you for taking the time this morning to
hear me
thank you any questions representative
panic
thank you I thank you representative
long
um for allowing me to ask the question
are there cases where
um
when they're using the puberty blockers
and the hormones
that the parents are not
aware of that treatment or they always
I'm not qualified to address that
question I think there are probably
medical professionals in here that are
more aware of the Privacy practices
between practitioners young adolescents
and parents
sorry thank you
any further questions
see you then
thank you ma'am
next I'll call uh Chris virtual
just a reminder that we're about two
minutes thank you
good afternoon chair Pearson members of
the committee thank you for hearing my
testimony in opposition to this bill
this is probably the third or fourth
time I've been before this committee
um in consecutive years to uh to to to
to testify against this same exact bill
um you will hear plenty of information
about uh the benefits of gender
affirming health care for transgender
Youth and other youth experiencing
gender dysphoria you will also hear
plenty about the harms that come from
denying access to health care I want to
focus I'm an attorney with glbtq legal
Advocates and Defenders glad based in
Boston my New Hampshire licensed
attorney and
um I want to focus on the legal issues
that uh come into play with respect to
this bill
um I think that you probably know that
similar legislation has been passed
prohibiting uh parents from being able
to obtain health care for their children
who are experiencing gender dysphoria in
other states and
um in two states there have been
lawsuits uh both of which have resulted
in the injunctions against the laws and
the basis for those lawsuits is
constitutional claims that they violate
both the rights of the parents because
parents have the right to direct the
upbringing of their children and nothing
is more essential to that right than
making Health Care decisions in
partnership with medical professionals
adherent to widely accepted standards of
care nothing could be more Central to
your role as a parent than making those
Health Care decisions for your child
second I want to establish that there is
an equal protection issue the 14th
Amendment of the U.S Constitution as
well as the New Hampshire Constitution
prohibit discrimination against a class
of people if that just if that
discrimination is irrational or
otherwise uh you know violates the
rights of a protected group in seconds
and so um transgender people are a class
of people who are singled out by this
legislation and denied access to health
care and by targeting that group of
people the legislation is
unconstitutional I'm happy to take any
questions
any questions
thank you thank you attorney thank you
for your time
the chair recognizes Kimberly Hester
from Nashua
hi my name is Pastor Kim Hester and I'm
resident of Nashua New Hampshire and
serve as pastor of the Lutheran Church
there I come before you today to urge
you to reject House Bill 417 and to
protect the rights of all citizens of
the State of New Hampshire to make
physical and mental health decisions in
conversation with their doctors family
and caregivers
the core of this bill is to seek to
instill fear and Levy criminal penalties
at parents and medical professionals who
are seeking to provide the best
medically supported care for their
children and patients
what kind of society are we living in
we're the same people who in another
place today we are advocating for the
rights of parents while seeking to
threaten teachers for being safe spaces
for Children and Youth are at the same
time seeking to take the right to make
decisions for the Health and Welfare of
their children away and make it criminal
to provide love and care
what kind of world are we living in when
medically trained certified Health Care
Professionals are restricted from
providing that medical care that for too
many of our kids and youth is the
difference between life and death
as a pastor an educator a parent a step
parent of a trans young adult and as a
citizen of New Hampshire I call on all
of you to stop with the politics to end
the ignorance and hatred and simply
leave the medical decisions up to the
medical professionals and parents and
caregivers as they do what is needed for
their children together
providing the best medical and mental
health care for anyone is never a crime
and should not be treated as such
remember our state motto Live Free or
Die let's stay on the side of living
free protect our kids and youth and
those who care for them and stay out of
their health care and simply say no to
House Bill 417 thank you
chair recognizes Derek burnt
hey I'm here to testify in opposition to
HB 417 uh before I get deeply personal
I'm going to talk for a moment about the
economy because I'm told people care
about it remember you have two minutes
total yep
[Music]
um
New Hampshire has a booming Technical
and scientific sector I have a highly
skilled job within this field and could
have worked in any state I chose I chose
to move to New Hampshire in no small
part because it's a Haven where my
family can be safe if this bill passes
and I one day have a trans child I would
choose their life over my job most of my
colleagues are allies to the trans
community and I believe they would make
the same choice this bill would
absolutely create a massive brain drain
in New Hampshire damage our property tax
base and make the lives of everyone
worse but now on to the real problems
with this bill
I have a dear friend whose information
I'm not going to share for obvious
reasons because an amazing trans
daughter who I met this Summer She's
vibrant joyful and happy as any teenager
hopefully can be
if this bill passes my friend will be
faced with a choice option A she can
stop providing her child with access to
gender performing care a choice she
tells me would almost certainly make her
daughter suicidal option b she could
continue to provide access to care for
her daughter covertly and risk losing
her child altogether to the Foster
system do not let anyone tell you that
the Foster system will not steal kids if
this bill is passed
if this does happen
that transgender daughters care her
health care is even worse she could lose
her parents and her health care at the
same time and the third option is flee
the state all these options in the same
place one less human who is transgender
getting to live their free life will
free of State violence in New Hampshire
there's no mincing words the impact of
this bill would be to kill trans kids in
New Hampshire or force them to flee it
wants to get trans kids out of this
state it is exterminationist it is
gender
you should not pass this bill you should
not have
honestly given this bill the time of day
I'll be done
thank you
chair recognizes MK kill coin from Dover
hello my name is MK mirror killcoin I
use they them pronouns I'm from Dover
New Hampshire I'm also 30 years old and
I identify as gender fluid and trans I'm
testifying in opposition to HB 417 the
bill before you today proposes to call
accepting and loving parents abusive for
supporting their children in their
gender expression I would like to tell
you my story of coming out to my family
and how that's affected them to this day
my first experience with questioning
gender identity actually came from my
cousin coming out as a trans woman when
I was 13 and she was the same age she
came out to me on MySpace she ended the
letter with I understand if you don't
consider me family anymore I completely
offered my support because she was right
Jenna was a woman
three years later an English class the
topic of trans people was brought up
alongside intersex folk a born class
tried to say it was unnatural and I was
able to tell him how wrong he was fast
forward to 2016 I'm working on college
campuses and I have the opportunity to
learn that transgender isn't just the
binary male to female or vice versa that
I had thought there was non-binary
agender and what ended up making self
making sense for myself as gender fluid
next came to him telling my family I
remember calling my sister and asking if
she'd still love me and making the words
my cousin had used a decade before she
said of course she just didn't know what
advice she could offer I told my mom
while sitting on the beach completely
unplanned she was understandably
confused by the terms but accepted it
and has done her best to stay educated
on gender identity finally it was my dad
he was I he's Irish Catholic and one I
was most worried about having been
Daddy's girl my entire life
we were in his truck moving some things
to my new apartment and I just blurted
it out
I was able to explain that I always felt
somewhere in between but definitely not
just a girl I said I know you love me
and I don't want to be scared to tell
you spoiler alert my whole family loves
me exactly as I am and supports me
now my dad uses titles like first of my
Offspring when referring to me my mom
loves being the educator for other folks
about queer terms they're not always
perfect but they're always trying when
my parents friends come to them
wondering how they handle me being me uh
they simply answer with they love me
that's it
I don't think they know how many lives
they've saved by being accepting of me
and letting people see that you got 15
seconds please wrapping up uh granted I
came out a lot later than the parameters
of this bill partly because I didn't
know there was anything else I could be
I probably wouldn't have been as
eloquent even though I wasn't to begin
with and my parents even more confused
but I know the result would be the same
and that is not abuse uh as such I urge
you to oppose HB 417. thank you so much
chair recognizes Abby Maxwell
should I wait no okay
my name is Abby Maxwell I'm here
representing myself speaking in
opposition to HBO HB 417 my daughter is
10 years old when she was born we
thought she was a boy
she spent ages three four and five
begging for long hair and dresses but we
lived in a small town where already she
was mocked for her pink shoes my husband
and I wanted to protect her so we said
no when she was six she asked me if it
was illegal for her to wear a dress I
still remember how I froze horrified by
the impression I was giving my child I
called my mother that day and together
we sewed the Halloween costume my child
had been begging for for years she would
be a witch in a dress
that costume was the First dress my
daughter ever got to wear but it was
just a costume by winter of that year
she was banging her head against the
wall insisting that she could not go out
in boy clothes she was staying up crying
half the night and then one day as we
drove to visit my mother my child said
from the back seat that she did not want
to exist anymore if I kept making her
live as a boy
finally I woke up to the suffering I was
causing my child and I sought help my
husband daughter and I visited the best
Children's Hospital in New England there
we learned about transgender children
and how to care for them my husband and
I were scared but we knew that we had to
follow the research and Trust the
experts
soon after that appointment we finally
let our daughter change her name and
pronouns I'm not exaggerating when I say
that she transformed overnight a weight
she had carried her entire life fell off
her shoulders and a light came on inside
of her everyone saw it
I don't know what care my daughter will
need in the future but if this bill were
to pass it would not only mean that the
life-saving option of puberty blockers
would be banned it would also mean that
her therapist could not affirm her as a
girl her primary care doctor could not
it would mean that we would have to
leave please wrap it up your overtime
now sure I spent my entire life thinking
about these bills with all due respect
you cannot imagine the amount of time
this takes out of my life so I will take
about 30 more seconds no you're finished
thank you everyone else went along
the chair now recognizes Candace Moulton
everyone else wanted to speak longer too
and they went along we understand
Candace Moulton do you wish to testify
I do thank you come on up to the table
please
together
thank you Mr chairman too much I just I
just want to share from a personal
perspective
um my son uh currently identifies as a
boy
um but I would call him gender fluid and
his name is Kyle
um a day without Kyle is a day without
Sunshine
um he likes Hot Wheels he also likes
unicorns
he likes Shopkins he likes LOL toys he
likes scruffaluffs
um but he also likes you know blocks and
and Legos you know he likes them all
um
as a mom one other thing too uh his hair
is currently about the same length as
mine
um
I love him and I would have to if this
if this bill was to go through I would
have to not buy him the toys that he
wants Maybe
um I don't know what it would look like
on a day-to-day basis but I do know just
as a parent like if I'm going to give
him a hundred dollars to spend for his
birthday like why if he wants if he
wants lol toys my only concern as the
financer of his birthday gifts is that
he's going to play with whatever he asks
me to buy to be honest
um I just don't want to like buy
something that he's just never going to
play with so uh
honestly whatever makes him happy is
what I want to do as a mom
um so whatever he enjoys is fine to be
honest
um if he wants to add to his unicorn
collection
um I just want to make sure he has
somewhere to store it in uh in our house
so uh I just want to give this
perspective as as a mom whose child is
still developing their gender identity
um 10 seconds please thank you uh just
that I I would feel that it would be in
his best interest to affirm whatever he
wants to be
um that's my role as a mom thank you
thank you
chair recognizes Christine hegerty
sorry thank you for this opportunity to
speak to you today my name is Christine
hegarty I have been here before
um I am strongly opposed hb417
as a parent of a trans child who just
happened to turn 18 yesterday
I am absolutely appalled offended and
distressed that I could be considered as
a child abuser
this bill is dangerous for all children
but especially for those seeking gender
affirming care
there is more abuse happening in
families where parents cannot understand
or support their children's call for
help
I have worked very hard to pay attention
learn and understand who my child is
the parents who do not take the time
take the same care are the ones that are
damaging the lives of their children
they are the the abusers
getting Medical Care and mental health
guidance is the best scenario for kids
who are questioning or struggling to
live their lives and there are so many
that do not have access
or adults that can support them in
finding it
how in the world could you accuse
parents in this case of child abuse
my daughter was so lucky so I have been
told many times over to have her dad and
I as parents we have not pushed her to
be anyone other than who she truly is
we have let her guide us in this process
since she was four years old I've been
listening to her
you might think a six-year-old would not
be capable of communicating their needs
but just as a child who scrapes their
knee or Cuts their finger can scream in
pain so can a child who is struggling
with gender dysphoria good thank you
please do not punish parents and
endanger families who are actually
caring and protecting these most
vulnerable children
thank you thank you
chair recognizes Karen testerman
for two minutes
and you've got handouts you can give to
our
representative Bickford two minutes
thank you Mr chairman and committee I am
the David in the Goliath
uh thank you for your dedication to give
us strong and serving the people of the
State of New Hampshire
I come before you to testify on H before
17 and in support of HB sub 417 while a
truly believe parents were gifted with
responsibility to govern in the Affairs
of their children in their care actions
by the legislature and executive
branches of New Hampshire have literally
thrown a monkey Ranch into the works
through their actions in 2019 and
codifying the existence of other than
biological male and female in the
recognition of gender identity
this action causes a Pandora's Box
allowing parents to make the decision to
alter by chemical or surgical means the
natural biological sex of their child
some of the unintended consequences of
this decision are suicide lifelong
dependency on Pharmaceuticals depression
and other psychological maladies in this
situation it is my opinion that such
action is child abuse so when the
situation is the right of the parents to
cause confusion and physical harm to one
or more of their natural born or Court
granted children I submit this testimony
and ask you to support 4-17 I would also
like to address a question that was
posed to representative Pearson early
um
approximately 92 percent of children who
are confused in their gender identity as
a child growing up by the time they meet
reach puberty have changed that opinion
Additionally the American College of
Pediatricians also supports this as
being child abuse and I have one more
quick thing to say to you because like
15 seconds certainly uh the
um excuse me puberty blockers
and sex hormones do not have FD the U.S
Food and Drug Administration FDA
approval for children
for gender care no clinical trials have
established this precise their safety
and such labeled use and there are no
long-term studies that show us what's
going to happen in the future in these
children think thank you very much and
with that I end the hearing on this bill
there are no more pink cards in my
position on House Bill 417.
there was a question for represent for
Miss testerman I'm sorry
um that that backlighting has there we
go thank you so much representative Greg
I do apologize for that
yes so as you heard when we have
statistics we do like to see what what's
your source for that so you said 92
percent changed their mind or whatever
what's your source for that please
I would have to research that again for
you I just know it from the back of my
my other research that I've done I am
also a microbiology trained person so I
do do a lot of research thank you
I can get that to you thank you okay now
we're done
we will come back at 1 15.
is call you to an on Deck Circle so you
can walk down and be ready to testify
when the person testifying is finished
so if you wish to go down to 201 203
they've set that up as the Overflow room
we are sorry that both reps Hall and the
ice arena in Manchester are occupied at
the time
committee members coming around is an
amendment to the bill could you all pay
attention it is an amended version of
the bill which is really what they
wanted in the beginning and so the
reason I'm giving it to you is there may
be you may have a comment and if you're
commenting on the original Bill the
language may not be in the original bill
so you know it's sincere but it's
useless so we're going to try to work
off this
anybody who just came in who does not
have a seat either you will be standing
for the next several hours or there is
an overflow room in 201 203 that will
have this hearing piped in there
so if you want to go there you may
oh joy
what's that
I can't
well
Mr chair
this is
you have lots of piles I don't want it
to get lost you know I do no thank you
if you were here for hearing on 417 that
was opened and continued and closed this
morning we plan on rescheduling that for
next Tuesday at 9 30. House bill 417.
Mr chairman can you repeat that those of
us in the corner are confused
the the hearing on House Bill 417
okay what's the one we didn't do
that's the other one
475 sorry
the hearing on 475 is postponed to next
week at 9 30.
Mr chairman
committee members a lot of extra copies
are now coming around from various
testimony of the last bill where the
people making presentations either had
one copy or only a handful and the team
made photocopies for everybody uh
and they are coming around now so pardon
our Indulgence here as we get caught up
I have a class I got this
commitment
I know what the Ross wants at the moment
yep that's Raymond's system and
foreign
and now open the hearing on House Bill
and recognize the Speaker of the House
The Honorable Sherman Packard
the committee members should have
received the desired presentation of the
bill which is an amendment
720 this is important for you to know
now so if you ask questions based on the
old version and those words are not in
the new version you didn't need to do
that so this is how you know
Mr Speaker
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee
as you just pointed out Mr chairman this
is the final version
um
and that's what we're requesting that
the committee take up and vote on uh the
original version that you have in front
of you the original bill that was filed
was a placeholder and uh
it's gone this has gone through numerous
different uh
layers that I will explain
um Mr chairman
I'm having a hard time understanding why
any legislator or parent be against this
legislation
parents are responsible for the
upbringing of their own children
with the help and support of government
not the opposite
that's what hb10 protects
protects parents rights and the ability
to be 100 involved in their children's
daily lives
came close to passing a similar Bill
last year
we went to work on it
and have spent months working with
Advocates legal experts and parents
this result was Common Sense legislation
that protects the rights of parents
while supporting our most vulnerable
population our children
this builds products of months of
collaboration
with the Senate and the Attorney
General's office
and it is the fourth version of this
bill
in a recent poll
of 1 000 New Hampshire voters taken last
month
respondents Joan parents over state
employees to have the final say of what
their children are taught nearly two to
one margin
when pacifically asked about schools
keeping students behavior regarding sex
and gender secret 78 supported the
parents right to know
we support parents right to know what is
happening to their children when in
school
and I and many others believe parents
make the best decision for their
families
I'm a father
I had a daughter in school
and I certainly would have wanted to
know what was happening in school with
my child
we support the parents who want to be
involved in their children's lives and
take an active role in their education
rhetoric perpetuates that lie that
school Personnel no more than we do and
what is best for our children
it was a time when parents were being
labeled as terrorists and being attacked
simply for wanting basic transparency
this happened in many of the school
district meetings
some which I attended in my local town
opponents of this bill say the
legislation is dangerous and harmful
what is dangerous and harmful is not
having parents involved in their
children's lives
in future
the first line of the bill it says the
general court affirms that it's a
fundamental right of parents
to direct the upbringing Education and
Care of children
their children show me what is dangerous
and harmful about that
the only thing dangerous and harmful is
believing that parents are not ever
right to protect their own children
parents deserve transparency and hb10
provides a protection they deserve to
have
Mr chairman I will not be taking any
questions and I will let representative
Grayson who is the original sponsor
dissect the bill for the members he is
much more knowledgeable about it than I
admit I am
I was a prime sponsor of this bill
because I truly believe
that is the parents not the state who
should be responsible for the upbringing
of these children of our children
I truly believe this is one of the most
important issues of our time and we must
keep parents completely involved in
their children's lives
with that Mr chairman uh I will let
representative Grayson dissect the bill
for you uh and that's why I've chosen
not to take any questions thank you
thank you Mr Speaker the chair
recognizes representative Grayson and
also representative Paul Terry who is
one of the other co-sponsors and knows
some details that representative Gleason
says he doesn't know so it sounds like a
good team those of you who are standing
the Overflow room is 201 203 where this
hearing is being broadcast if you filled
out a pink card but go to the Overflow
room I will call the names uh in in such
way that you will have time to walk down
carefully to this room from the other
one with that Representatives Terry and
Grayson
good afternoon Mr chair and committee
members uh thank you for the opportunity
I am privileged to introduce uh House
Bill tend to follow uh the speaker in uh
in introducing house bill 10. I do want
to bring your attention primarily to the
amendment 0720 this was supposed to be
the original bill that you would have
seen you never would have seen the other
version uh and it's okay that you did
there's no secrets in there uh the
amendment makes it more streamlined and
it did go through a a more stringent
vetting process to make sure that there
were no conflicts with the Constitution
or the or any other laws the attorney
general has has reviewed it uh to to
give us the uh the language that would
be necessary and so what I do want to do
is to just very quickly go through and
show you highlight the the the
differences the changes that you will
see in the amendment versus the original
copy that you have uh that way uh we
don't we can avoid some questions that
may not be pertinent to the bill
uh first of all there is a
a section in the original version that
defines compelling State interest
that has been deleted from the amendment
at the direction of the Attorney General
because the concept of compelling State
interest is throughout our rsas every
judge every attorney understands that
principle but to try to Define it in any
one particular in in any one particular
piece of legislation could potentially
compromise is the definition in other
aspects or in applications of the law so
that become became problematic by trying
to Define it too narrowly or being too
broad and so that has been deleted but
the expression or the phrase compelling
State interest is still in there because
that is an essential part of the
government's uh ability or the power or
the authority to infringe on anyone's
rights regardless of the nature of those
rights they have to have a compelling
State interest
secondly
a large portion of the of the original
what is uh section I it's it's going to
be on the original version page three uh
beginning at line 25 section i5
says School Board notifications of
parental rights
most of this entire section
has been deleted
I can get to it real quick
let's see
uh that would be beginning at line 25
that section the school board it goes
out to just do to outline uh that the
school board School District or school
administrative unit child in
consultation with parents teachers and
administrators develop adopt and
promulgate publicly a policy to promote
parental involvement in the public
school system and it goes out and
outlines what those things might be
there was a concern that this might
inter become a an unfunded mandate it
wasn't directly one but it could be
perceived as being when we don't want to
even come close to uh having that
perception that it could be a 28-a
violation so we eliminated that entire
section it's and has actually not even
necessary uh it makes the the law much
more uh just longer than it needs to be
and more and may perhaps even introduce
some confusion into it so we don't want
it to be confusing in any way and we
certainly don't want there to be any
unfunded mandates which would violate
the law so we deleted that out of the
amended version so that's why the
amended version is much shorter than the
original version as well
if you go to the section that is
violations in the original is this the
amended or the
uh it's the of the
of the original bill that section five
has been deleted yep
the
in the amended version
section 7 is violations
the original version page number uh page
five of the amendment and page six of
the original version okay
in the original version it calls for
uh in in Roman numeral one a violation
of any provision of this chapter by an
individual shall constitute a Class A
misdemeanor and then it goes on to
explain the violations
in the amended version
this class A misdemeanor is uh has been
eliminated in The as a first offense we
don't want we don't want teachers
accidentally
committing a crime and so to eliminate
the the potential for inadvertent
Commission of a crime and then being
having a Class A misdemeanor we made it
an intentional on a repeated offense so
if you'll notice the first offense
becomes a civil action a right for of
parents for civil action and then a
repeat offense would then be subject to
a class A misdemeanor for for a teacher
who would intentionally violate on
multiple offenses so and this is not
unprecedented if you go through the
statutes there's actually a a senior
citizens Bill of Rights and if you
violate the provisions of the senior
citizens Bill of Rights that is a class
A misdemeanor so it's not unprecedented
for that to be a standard of punishment
for violating the rights of someone as
in our statutes those are the the
probably the the biggest changes oh
actually and one other thing I do want
to point out because I know this is
going to be hot button and so I'm going
to be ready for the dark to come flying
at me on these in these sections but if
you go to the the section 169 I4 page uh
let me get to that real quick that's
going to begin on
page two
page three also continues until you get
to page four and I want you to look at
page four
it's it's the amendment page four
hold on does everybody want to pay
Amendment page four
points w x and y
points w x and y those are probably the
most contentious of all of the of the
points everything else is explicitly
stated in rsas already uh these are the
only ones that don't have any other
references in the rsas
the original version uh we or the
amended version changes the original to
include the clause in each of the three
lines you'll see the Clause upon inquiry
the concern that came up when the bill
was first introduced last time was the
if it if a if a student confides in a
teacher
would the teacher then be compelled to
call the parent immediately and inform
the parent
we want to have a good relationship
between the students and the teachers
but we also must have a good
relationship between the children and
the parents and the school and the
parents so how do we do all that and to
compel the teacher to then immediately
inform the parents could could violate a
trust a relationship that the the
student may have with the with the
teacher but it also we need to be sure
and protect that relationship with the
parent as well and so we put in upon
inquiry on there which means that the
parent would have to ask
and then once the parent asks then the
teacher would be required to inform
what's happening that we see a lot of
and I mean just this morning every day
seems to be a new example of why this
bill becomes necessary but just this
morning I read of a School in Colorado
where the assistant principal asked how
do we deal with children that would come
out as transgendered or gay or whatever
anything it doesn't matter what it is uh
it could be an eating disorder we don't
know just how but it's specifically this
what happened to deal with with a
transgender child
but how do we
address the situation where the parents
have explicitly said
no
you will call my child by their birth
name and the appropriate pronouns etc
etc the parents have explicitly said
this is what you'll do but this the the
schools
were not abiding by the parents wishes
so the assistant principal asked the
question what do we do and the assistant
principle was advised to lie to the
parents
blatant lie to the parents you tell them
you what you do is you address the
student at school
by the name they've chosen and the
pronouns they've chosen but when the
parents ask about it you lie and you
tell them what they want to hear that's
what was done and that is why
a foundation that is built on lies will
crumble you undermine the relationship
between the the student the child
and their parents that's a natural
relationship the the student teacher
relationship is not a natural
relationship the relationship between
the parent and the child is a natural
relationship and you undermine that when
you lie
to the parents
and so I would ask the kids
next time somebody when you have an
opportunity ask the teachers and the
principals or anybody it doesn't matter
left or right or Center or whatever
if you would lie to my parents how do I
know you're not lying to me
and so we are trying to protect the
Integrity of the rent the parents child
relationship protecting the children not
from their parents
protecting the children and protecting
the parents rights to govern the all
those decisions that parents have to
make regarding their children and so I
will leave my those comments off there
so that we can answer specific questions
pertaining to the bill but one thing
that is important to understand in this
bill what this bill does not do none
whatsoever
this bill does not say a child cannot
transition
this does not say that the child cannot
come out at school and be whatever
whoever by called by whatever names or
pronouns it doesn't matter that's not
what this bill does it does not say they
cannot do that they CA it doesn't say
they can't join any particular clubs it
doesn't say they can't they can't
participate in any particular activities
all it says is that they must have
parental consent and knowledge
and I'm not really sure how that is
harmful and dangerous and that would
just as the as the speaker said how is
that harmful and dangerous and I know
one of the questions that's going to
come up because it came up last year
what about the parents that would abuse
their child because they found out well
we already have laws that deal with that
and if you will turn in the amended
version and in the original version but
in the amended version
there is a section that says
it's uh page four
line 23
this section does not authorize a parent
of a minor child in this state to engage
in conduct that is unlawful or to abuse
or neglect his or her minor child in
violation of General law
this bill also does not restrict
or or prevent
those who are mandatory reporters of any
suspicious or anything you might suspect
is being abuse it doesn't prevent them
from reporting that suspected abuse
so it's not about what they what the
kids can and cannot do it's that they
can and cannot do it without parental
permission and I think that's a pretty
reasonable thing to do
and I'll take your questions to them
representative Raymond uh thank you Mr
chairman um and thank you
representatives for being here Mr
chairman I would like to
um ask for a bit of personal privilege
here
um the representatives have clearly put
a lot of work into their Amendment
um it is six pages long and I cannot
read it while also attending to your
comments I just my brain doesn't work
that way
um so I would like to beg everyone's
Indulgence in giving the committee a few
minutes to actually read this so that I
can ask intelligent questions I had
prepared questions based on the original
but it sounds like there are some
significant changes and I would rather
spend five minutes reading and
understanding what's in front of me and
asking intelligent questions then spend
10 minutes asking you questions that you
tell me don't thank your representative
for bringing this up the chair will
recess for five minutes thank you
can we ask for just for a little bit of
Silence though because the recess is so
that we can have the time to to read
this thank you
thank you
Representatives you may continue
questions for the representatives so far
yeah Mr chair representative Raymond had
had was going to ask a question but she
asked to take the recess okay
representative Mr chairman I too have
prepared remarks but in view the fact
that there are questions on
representative greeson's testimony I
will wait until the questions have been
exhausted okay thank you
representative long
thank you Mr chairman uh
thank you for uh your test testimony and
thank you for articulating the amendment
um so on line five where it says uh
actually starts online for the general
court further finds that important
information related to minor child shall
not be purposely purposefully withheld
if inquiring
correct
uh the this was in in reference to
actually in the original version of the
bill the statement actually had to not
be withheld either inadvertently or
purposefully and so uh we don't want
someone accidentally committing a crime
we needed to eliminate the inadvertently
portion of it and so this is purposely
withheld okay
uh and I'll come back to questions I I
got a bunch of somebody else
representative Moulton thank you Mr
chairman I'm wondering how this applies
to
Psychological Services where there is
confidentiality built into the child and
therapist relationship
um and
I'm I'm just wondering if the terms
medical you know personnel and medical
professionals and things
encompasses
Psychological Services
thank you for your question except is
otherwise provided by law or a court
order
yep
that covers it representative Petrino
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
representatives for taking my question
um looking through the bill very
carefully
um
I I don't see what is in here
that doesn't already exist someplace
else as in federal or state statutes
Department of Education uh directives
you know having talked for 40 years I'm
looking at each item and I'm saying yeah
okay I get it I see it we do it for
example opting out of
sex education
kids can opt out of absolutely
everything and anything that a parent
says I don't want my kid to participate
in so can you just direct me to where in
this bill is there something different
from what I haven't experienced in 40
years as a high school teacher
well thank you for the question the
motivation behind
this bill
is because
despite being in law
there's a lot of infringement upon the
rights of parents so much so that a
judge in Manchester last year said that
parents don't have rights
and so we want to clarify that indeed
they do have rights these are their
rights that in fact this isn't even an
exhaustive list on this right of those
rights however the law can only enforce
that which is stated in in this in this
if this becomes law you can only enforce
what's written in here the language of
this bill is slightly different from the
original version in that the the
language outlining all the rights that
parents have is actually taken from a
technical advisory that was issued last
year uh by the Department of Education
the New Hampshire Department of
Education and so this was this was
submitted to remind schools that parents
do indeed have rights here's the
references to statute we just wanted to
codify this in one Clearinghouse this is
these are the rights that parents have
this is the enforcement mechanism behind
those rights if there's no enforcement
then there are no rights and there's
clearly been some infring and I'm sure
there's plenty of people who will
testify as to how school and it's just
like with right to know we have the 91a
laws I sit on the Judiciary Committee
and we have bills that are coming before
us because despite having laws on the
book referring to ever the citizens
right to know what's going on in their
government you still get obstruction by
the same government officials who refuse
to release the information under a right
to know request so just because it's
written in the law doesn't mean people
aren't going to violate it
representative Grossman
thank you Mr chairman
thank you for coming before us today and
bringing this bill
um
so as a former as an educator
my concern is and as a parent as well so
both sides I've got three teenagers
and they're in high school and we
regularly have meetings at school and I
hear the guidance counselor say to my
son
whatever we talk about We're not gonna
like there's a there's a privacy code in
those teenage years
um of of letting students know that
there's a safe place for them at school
to talk and that it won't all be
divulged to their parents
[Music]
um
my fear My worry is that those
relationships will become severed and
school will no longer necessarily be a
safe place
and then on the other side
the effect on our educators
um they're pretty important in our
community and
I'm concerned that this would affect
folks from going into education and
wanting to be in public service of
teaching our kids in community because
they would lose control of their
classroom to potential parents that
you know you get where I'm going at so
do you think that this would have an
effect on
the educator pool
I don't know who will and will not get
into education but I also to flip that
back around
I'm concerned about the relationship
between children and their parents and
what might undermine that relationship
uh why would why would teachers
intentionally Place themselves between
a a parent and their child
does that not then make the home a not
so safe place
you you are you are causing the child to
then question
whether their parents care for them or
love them uh I know that was it it
caught me just I was taken aback by by a
very disturbing comment that came out
some kids will be beaten to death if
their parents find out
about this this info find this find out
this information and that what that does
now is paint parents all parents as
being child abusers
just all you have to do is disagree with
the some school policy all you have to
do is oppose whatever all you have to do
is ask the question hey what's going on
with my child at school and now all of a
sudden you're being looked at as a child
abuser so how does that Foster trust
between the parents and the schools how
is that fostering a good positive
relationship why would parents then want
to put their children in schools I'm
pretty sure that kids are coming out of
the public schools because the parents
don't feel that their children are safe
in the schools because there's not even
a positive relationship between the
parents and the schools so that's
undermining the whole relationship at
home so it's it remember you we got to
go back to natural rights
the relationship between a parent and
the child is a natural right
there is no natural right of a student
or teacher and a student so I'm not
really sure where your concerns are
arising from when if you are purposely
misinforming parents if you're purposely
just lying to parents if you're
withholding information that's that
parents need to know about their own
children
separate it from any kind of abuse abuse
is a totally different and and and not a
anything that we can uh support or
condone in any way separate that
from just every other ordinary citizen
regardless of their political persuasion
you've now labeled them as a as a as an
abuser in a domestic terrorist
representative picking up on that shred
when you were describing the assistant
principal in Colorado who was told to
lie to the parents do you think if that
either is and we discovered it or is
becoming more common this will
accelerate the drive amongst many people
for Education accounts and charter
schools and religious schools and
homeschooling and so on because the
distrust has
now grown and for palpable reason
I absolutely agree that this would only
exacerbate the problem of distrust it
would so Discord in the community
between the the parents and the schools
with the teachers children are just
they're just not going to know who to
trust they won't trust their parents and
they won't trust the teachers they're
not going to have anyone to turn to
because who if if my parents are lying
to me or if my teachers are lying to me
then who do I turn to why are we having
to put the National Suicide Hotline on
the back of their ID card I think
they're going to get busier if we cannot
even form a a a relationship based on
trust and so and by the way we know
about that uh issue of the school in
Colorado because of a right to know
request
thank you representative representative
Grossman you wanted a follow-up I
believe
you're done uh representative Raymond
thank you Mr chairman um and thank you
so much for indulging me and letting me
have a chance to read this I really
appreciate it
um so I have a couple questions on the
amendment and then I have a couple
questions that your testimony has been
just two questions and we'll give others
a chance and we may get back to you so
my I will ask first about your testimony
um you're citing a case in
um Colorado and you cited a judge saying
parents don't have rights here in New
Hampshire so I'm asking you to please
send the committee that information so
that we can see that news article or
write to no request or whatever it is
and then any case law regarding office
of civil rights complaints that allege
that schools are violating parents
rights uh in this way
um and then on the
um Amendment
um my question I'll have to boil it down
my question is on page
um three
um if you look down to
um lines
22 and 26
it says on 22
the right to review medical records and
then there's some exceptions if there's
a if there's a criminal component what
about dcyf involvement so for example if
there is a dcyf case alleging medical
neglect or some sort of abuse or any
other type of dcyf involvement where
dcyf is investigating using medical
records would that also be appropriate
to have an exception here or are you
thinking only if it's a criminal
investigation
when dcyf is involved there is a
compelling State interest for there to
be an action
hopefully theoretically dcyf does not
interject itself into domestic
situations uninvitedly or not directed
by an authority to no someone makes a
report dcif goes out so when the parents
are
and by nature of an investigation there
is
an investigation of a crime committed
either neglect or abuse
so dcyf being involved is the right to
access and review all medical records of
his or her minor child unless prohibited
by law if the parent has been convicted
of any crime against me or if the parent
is the subject of an investigation of a
crime perhaps neglect or abuse so the
investigation may be by dcyf and law
enforcement agency has requested of the
applicable court that the information
not be released and so to be able to
investigate is is uh is part of the
compelling State interest and is not
interfered with they're still able to do
that and so that becomes a court
directed uh order at that point so dcyf
can still investigate and the medical
records if the judge determines that
they shall not have access to the
records then the judge can then issue
that the parents cannot have access at
that point so it's all within law
enforcement and the investigative uh
process so it's not a conflict at all
other questions from other
Representatives representative Petrino
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
again representatives for taking another
question
um I'm a parent I'm a grandparent I was
also an educator for 40 years
um vast majority of teachers School
administrators and so forth are parents
themselves why do you think they would
put forth policies that would deny them
their rights as parents and we're
talking teachers and parents vast
majority of teachers our parents do you
think that they would put forth policies
that would deny them their own personal
rights
I don't know
I don't know why they would I don't
maybe they don't understand that they
are
um
these are their rights as well as
parents if you are an educator and you
have a child in a school you are not
directly teaching that that child let's
say you're a fifth grade teacher and
your child is now in 10th Grade you're
not directly teaching that child
um but let's say something's going on at
the school that you disagree with you
would be covered by these rights right
here to be informed about what's going
on it doesn't matter what it is
everybody keeps thinking all these worst
case scenarios oh my God the sky is
going to fall
and it's like just basic you have the
right to know what's going on with your
kid don't you want the right to know
what's going on with your kid at school
and so it they don't understand I don't
know whether they don't understand they
don't care they don't know I don't know
why they would do it I don't think it's
a simple answer
so
understanding that these rights as a
parent apply to you regardless of your
profession
I would just add to that that one of the
reasons why this bill has been put forth
in this state as well as in other states
and now a bill introduced in Congress
along the same lines is the bill that
we're looking at today is because there
have been numerous instances across this
country where policies have been put in
place or individuals have acted in a way
that effectively
uh
uh prohibit
by the action of the individual the
parent from knowing what is going on
with respect to his or her child or
children in that school or in that
Medical Care Facility this is
essentially a right to know Bill and
what it does is it brings together all
of the rights of parents and and
publishes it requires that they be
distributed to parents so that parents
know what their rights are whether they
exercise them or not is a function of
their understanding of their parental
responsibility and how they can how they
conduct themselves as parents however to
to even begin to think that there are uh
that there are things going on that do
not need to be addressed in legislation
such as this goes against the grain of
what is happening across this country
representative DeSimone
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
isn't it true that when you spoke
earlier about
um the possibility of a parent abusing a
child when they become
uh knowledgeable of something that
happens in school you in this amendment
have addressed that on page four uh
section three Roman numeral three uh the
first uh lowercase
parenthetical a
uthorizes a parent of a minor child to
in this state to engage in contact that
is unlawful or to abuse or neglect his
or her minor child
you have addressed all of that which was
something that I asked for last year and
I thank you very much for addressing
that although the abusive parents
are not
in numbers that good parents are thank
you God this takes care of that is that
correct
it it does take care of that actually
that Clause was in the bill last year
unfortunately it didn't pass last year
but but it was actually in there that's
a very key component to this we want
everyone to understand there's
absolutely no
can't even begin to Fathom condoning
anyone abusing their child
and and under under any guys whatsoever
and so that is a key component of this
law and always had or this bill and
always has been you do not have the
right this is where natural rights and
where government is allowed to infringe
because no rights are absolute
government has the right or the power
excuse me and the authority
to then step in and say you do not have
the right to abuse your child
uncharacteristically for me I will be
brief in responding and adding and
saying and summing and saying under no
circumstances
under no circumstances is child abuse
ever condoned under the law there's no
exemption this bill does not provide any
exemption whatsoever for holding
accountable any parent who on the basis
of information allegedly received from a
school official or employee or a medical
practitioner then has the right to do
something that otherwise under law that
parent cannot do
I have a question here is it true to say
that this bill across the board
is dealing with outliers that is to say
abusive parents
bad acting teachers we're not talking
about all the parents we're not talking
about all or probably even many of the
teachers are we not talking about those
exception cases
on across the Spectrum yes and in
addition what we have is a phenomenon
that is occurring that has emerged in
the culture
such that there are parties who believe
that they have a superior we believe
that they have they believe they have a
superior right to be able to educate
children in a way that is contrary to
the way that children have been educated
in the past and in in and contravenes
the authority and otherwise the
authority of the parent the primary
relationship
this is a cultural phenomenon that is
growing and is re one of the reasons why
we are seeing the the veritable plethora
of cases that are going to court and the
bills that are being introduced in state
legislatures and now in the Congress of
the United States we have a problem yes
thank you representative Perez
thank you
um can you give me some examples of what
is happening in the school that they
that you feel didn't need this to be
this bill to be introduced and can you
give me an example what stays are you
talking about that these issues been
happening because when I take when I
make another decision I'm listen to
every single testimony with all my
respect
but when you told me that it's happening
another state when you told me that that
parents have an issue when you told me
all this
I hear you
but I just don't just go with what
you're saying I would love to have an
examples I would love to have exactly
information in front of my my face that
I can make the right decision but I just
by going by other states and other parts
of the country it doesn't mean anything
to me I would love to see clear
information exactly what is happening
what is happening and you know I I would
love to see that and and and to be
honest I want to know what exactly is
being introduced to the students that
you feel like uh never been introduced
before and is hurting the student is
always making the parents uncomfortable
the parents don't know what is happening
in the school system I would love to see
that
that way when I make the decision can
can I have that information can can you
provide me that information that's my
question
how many examples would you like
and many as you can I would love to see
because more information more data
it's better for me to to you know to
make my own decision
I would agree
um
for um for wanting to to look at real
life examples
um and and for your candor in indicating
that you're not aware of of many of any
of these situations uh we would be we'd
be happy to be and pleased to be able to
sit down with you and provide you with
that information we will do so
representative Grossman
thank you Mr chairman
I ever one of my biggest concerns is for
our trans and lgbtq youth
um
and that in many situations it is life
and death in terms of
um mental health and care for them
to be living in the light so if a
student
requests that their pronouns be changed
and the teacher then goes to the parents
then the parents have requested to know
what's going on
the school lets the parents know that
their child is now requested different
pronouns
that child goes home
is abused because even if it's in law
we know that abuse happens and it
happens in Dark Places it's not in the
light
um
what is that child student teenager do
after they've been abused by their
parents
because their teacher
told them that they refer to different
pronouns so what's the recourse for that
child
student
again
there is absolutely
no provision that would allow for a
parent to abuse their child regardless
of the circumstances so what does the
child do you can call the police you
could tell your the we asked about what
about dcyf there's I'm being abused at
home you there's mandatory reporting so
there is recourse for the child how
would they do it now if a child is being
abused for any reason six-year-old child
wets the bed gets abused by the parent
they go to school and the child or the
teacher sees bruises on the child
are you know is is is Mommy hitting you
in the morning what why is Mommy
whatever that gets a reported there are
already
the means for the saying you're singling
at lgbtq kids it's all kids any child
that would be abused for whatever reason
though and the re and the recourse is
the same there is absolutely no excuse
whatsoever for abuse and this law would
say you can't abuse your kids and if you
do abuse your kids we have the law that
says how you can be punished and that
there is no cover for the for the parent
that would abuse the child none
whatsoever so I'm not I'm not really
sure what you're what you're trying to
get at as far as what if this lgbtq
child gets abused by their parents what
if any child gets abused by their
parents for any reason
would you like a follow-up
representative just
worried about protecting children and
their rights representative Perez
okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
ask you a question
this is hard for me to ask this question
but I'm gonna ask it
why do you tell a child like myself okay
I grew up in a family when I where I
went to a Catholic School
my dad
it was the one who was sexually abusing
me okay
but my dad was
very well-known person and he was given
donations to the school a Catholic
School
so when my dad was pulling me from the
school to abuse me sexual assault me
and bring me about this bring me back to
school
after he abused me
and the school stayed quiet
why do you tell a child like myself
when you told me that we are protected
or the kids are protected I wasn't
protected and that scar is on me for the
rest of my life can you tell me why can
I tell a child like my like myself when
you told me that the kids are protected
representative I I'm sorry for for the
abuse that you experienced but you were
also talking about a very extraordinary
case where you were abused by your
parent and then protected at the school
from that abuse that is a an
extraordinary case uh you said that your
dad gave money to the school and you
that they
whatever the collusion was between the
school and your dad that would allow
that to be covered up there are
cover-ups of sexual abuse in all kinds
of of organizations not just schools
it's not just parents there's you name
the organization Boy Scouts Girl Scouts
Public Schools private schools it you
you pick the organization and you could
find Creeps in every single one of them
you can find bad parents if you want to
focus on just the bad parents we could
do that but I don't think we're going to
get anywhere by just trying to what
about all these different bad parents
when the focus is not on the bad parents
do you wish to follow up yes please
again you know my question is we we here
to protect the children if you taken
away
that protection by taking away that
child to be able to go back to that that
teacher and explain to that teacher
what happened because when that child
went home it got beat up it got beat up
really hard
and that kid is so so scared to speak up
because they have black and blue bruises
that has to hide
how can that child and we're not talking
about parents here only but we're
talking about teachers but we're taking
but can you explain to me how we're not
going to take the ability of the
teachers when we're gonna like tell the
teacher they can get in trouble if they
you know if they they hide some things
from the parents our teachers mandatory
yes
teachers are required by law to report
abuse if they are not doing that then
they are in violation of the law so
who's protecting the children from the
negligent teachers
and who's protecting the children from
the from the teachers who are providing
pornography to them where where are they
where are the who's protecting the
children we're talking about protecting
the children but who are we protecting
the children from
who are we protecting the children from
and it's always this example of all
these bad parents out there when
most parents aren't bad parents so why
are why are we hiding things from
parents why are we undermining the
relationship between the child and the
parent
representative Petrino
thank you Mr chairman thank you again
for taking uh one of my questions
um my observation is that uh
this matter was never an issue in the
past it seems to be something that's
relatively recent and I'm trying to
think of the motivation behind it
I'm thinking and correct me if I'm wrong
that this really comes down to uh
matters regarding the lgbtq community if
Johnny gives Billy a Valentine's in
School Mom wants to know is this the
impetus I really want to get to the
heart of the matter uh no there is not
I'll just go ahead and I'll just go and
answer it no it is not what then would
be the assessment
it is
it is the things that are happening in
school regardless of the nature of what
it is
the parent has the right to know this
law would not prevent kids from Little
Johnny giving Tommy a valentine
it does not prevent Tommy from wearing a
dress and being called Sally
it does not stop anything whatsoever it
just says that parents have the right to
know what's going on in the life of
their child that's it no it is not
motivated by the lgbtq community that is
one aspect of it it's one thing that's
happening in the schools you've got the
closets where you can go in and and
change clothes and it doesn't even stop
that from happening
it just says the parents have the right
to know what's going on and and guide
the upbringing of their own children the
parents have the right to make those
education decisions if they decide that
that's not where I want my child I want
to do something else they would have the
right to then do that as well it has
nothing to do with what they can and
cannot do as far as the activities go
it's anything and everything the parents
have the right to know what's going on
representative Greg
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I appreciate you
being here to support your bill as
someone who has great insight into what
happens in abusive situations and this
is kind of a two-part question is that
okay
so
um would it would it surprise you to
know that some kids who are in abusive
situations actually don't know its abuse
because it's the only reality they know
that doesn't surprise me at all
so would it also
because it's so hard to word and just
keep it down to one question I apologize
parents who have we're taught you want
to talk about the good parents right
because obviously there's a lot of talk
about abusive parents
why is it that a good parent doesn't
already have communication with their
child open communication where the child
is talking to them about all of these
things if we're talking about good
parents being able to parent
I had a wonderful relationship with my
parents and I didn't tell them much of
anything that was going on in my life
adolescence is a very weird experience
girls are different than boys I'm pretty
sure anyway uh we all experience
different things in our lives but I can
promise you this there are things that
my parents still don't know to this day
having a good relationship with your
parent and telling them everything is
two completely different things
yeah once again there's there's
absolutely no protection whatsoever for
abuse by anybody
in any and on in any venue under any
circumstance and when someone becomes
aware of abuse just like if you go to
the hospital and um I had a situation a
number of years ago where my son had a
very adverse reaction to poison ivy well
immediately uh the the medical personnel
were questioning uh my wife and me as to
whether we uh beat him uh with a rod on
his heels because they had to do their
due diligence
by the way let me assure all of you that
we were cleared rather quickly and we
were not charged with abusing our son
because he caught poison ivy on his on
his heels but these are real life
examples here and real people who when
they become aware of abuse they are
required
um a clergy are required lawyers are
required teachers are required everybody
is required if they see something they
have to say something and there are
child protective services in all of our
states and all students have access to
that you know you can lead a horse to
water but you can't make him drink but
you can encourage a child if a child and
and part of the educational experience
for children can be if something if
something is happening in your home that
is not good that doesn't make you feel
good then then tell me about it and if
told about it then the teacher has a
responsibility to act upon that now
where the the but the main main focus of
this bill is a parent's right to know
what is going on in a classroom or with
a health care practitioner we we that
right is a natural fundamental primary
right that has been established in in in
in natural law and also in judicial law
the Supreme Court has ruled on many
occasions and in circuit courts of
appeal that the parents or the primary
caretakers of their children and will
direct their upbringing and they cannot
be impeded in in that upbringing unless
there is something nefarious that's
going on in which case there are
remedies that are prescribed in law
do you wish to follow up representative
I do please thank you so what is to you
said something about the child being
able to tell the teacher if something's
happening or whatever what's to make
them feel confident that that's going to
be secret if they know that anything
else that they tell their parents or
tell is going to go directly back to the
parents how does that keep kids safe and
feeling confident in talking to the
teacher well I think the question that I
hear you asking is what makes a child
feel would make a child feel safe and
confident to be able to confide in abuse
that is taking place in the home to
confide in the teacher that abuse is
taking place in the home and that
nothing will be done about it
the the the the point here is that
something must be done about it and will
be done about it if the teacher doesn't
do that then the teacher has failed
I want to rephrase it yes so if if we
pass say we pass this bill and it's you
know the say the kid has something weird
happen where they want to change their
middle name to shark and maybe they're
being abused at home so maybe it's like
their dad's you know name that they
don't want to identify with anymore so
they tell the teacher that but
the parent says did my kiddo change
their middle name and he says yes well
then they get in trouble at home what
confidence does that child have that
they can say hey you know what my
teacher just my my dad beat me when I
got home because I didn't because I
changed my name what confidence do they
have to be able to go find safety at
school because a lot of homes are not
safe I hate to say
at that point okay first of all the the
teacher does not know that the child is
going to get beat right the time the
child May suspect that he will get beat
the child is told this the student the
the teacher I want to change my middle
name
for whatever reason but the you know the
the the child has not yet told the
teacher
I might get beat for this
you are asking about what to do after
the fact
If the child wants to be called by some
other name
if the parent asks the teacher would be
obligated to tell the parent not lie to
the parent the problem is is If the
child is then beaten by the parents and
the child says
I would just got beaten because I I
change now the teacher has to act why
would the T why would the the student
now trust the teacher
because the teacher then acted on their
responsibility the teacher's not going
to know
what's going to make the child feel safe
they told the teacher that I got I got
beaten by my dad because I changed my
name now the teacher acts in accordance
with the law as the teacher is supposed
to act now the T this the the child
trusts the teacher because the teacher
has now protected them from the abuse
you that that's that's the proper
response
but otherwise T child wants to change
their name to something else
parent asks is my child going by some
other name
the teacher says yes
that's it representative my follow-up
question to this very specific question
is over the 50 years I've done a fair
bit of counseling I've discovered the
danger in families of too many secrets
and I have seen so many families where
the parents did not learn it from the
child
the parents learned it from a neighbor
whose child told the neighbor whose
neighbor told the parents and the anger
in the family was not so much the action
but the duplicity
the skulking about the secrecies and so
on and I knew growing up that if I did
something downtown it didn't have to be
my teacher it was a generic teacher in
that City I my parents would know before
I get home and that kinda you know this
is not in any way
making light of the all too real
situations where there are abusive
parents that's correct I am just saying
that it doesn't solve the problem right
if the child changes the name at school
right
except now the parent distressed the
teacher and looks on the neighbor's
child as the rat
so and I think that was that started off
as a question
is is that within the framework of what
you're saying here
are we asking kids to rat out their
neighbors no
no we are suggesting the possibility
that if the teacher does not report
something
and the neighbor's child does
that now the parents have another reason
to distrust the teacher who's supposed
to be working in tandem with the parents
that's what I'm asking if the teacher
does not report abuse then the teacher
would be in violation of the law
representative Nelson
uh I don't even remember what I was
gonna ask I'm sorry I representative
Raymond while representative Nelson
remembers thank you Mr chairman I want
to get back to understanding the
language of the Bell
um and and kind of away from
hypothetical
um situations so
um there are a couple of areas where I
am still seeking understanding
um the first one is page one line seven
um it talks about
um that information about a child
shouldn't be purposely withheld from
their parents etc etc while the child is
in the custody of the school district
it's a really weird
um phrase and I'm curious if you mean
while the child is attending school or
and also whether this only applies to
school public school districts or if
this will also apply to Charter Schools
and private schools well thank you for
the question it is a good question
actually yeah because the questions are
bad
she's pretty good for first year there
is a concept of what's called in loco
parentis
and this this deals yeah so in here is
the concept of in local parentis this is
actually down on the same page SEC uh
Roman numeral three line 20
notwithstanding a belly state region to
the concept of in local parentis and any
interpretation application thereof shall
not infringe upon the natural and
statutory rights of of parents as
recognized in existing law or by
adoption of this statute so this goes
back up this relates to the concept of
inloco-parentus so a a a school Acts
as a representative of the parents with
their given Authority and responsibility
uh to to take care of the kids to
educate the kids in lieu of the parents
or in place of the parents so what I'm
really getting at with the question
though is by saying in the custody of
the school district is this
legally is this going to be interpreted
as public school districts or does it
cover private schools boarding schools
charter schools
this should cover schools everyone
because I noticed all the other places
it just says schools which schools was
helpful
if if you would need to to to remove the
the district from there or or just
because the phrase is freaking me out
okay
um and then well it's it's a custody the
children are at the school they're
actually compelled to be at school right
by the law and so that is they are in
the in the temporary if you will custody
of the school they have responsibility
of the child for that period of time and
so while they are there parents don't
lose their rights because the child is
not in their physical presence under
their direct direct supervision they're
at the school okay and so this does
apply to all schools uh but that that
custody is it relates to in local
parentis okay that's awesome and in
addition with respect to in loco
parentis the whole concept of in loco
parentis implies that there is a uh de
facto trust relationship that exists
between the parents and the school or
the parents and the and the health care
provider such that
the parents need to be knowledgeable of
what it is that they have entrusted or
their medical practitioner the parents
need to know what they have entrusted
their children to that school and school
Personnel teachers Educators Health Care
Providers they need to understand
uh and have delineated what in fact that
is and part of that goes to curriculum
of course and we have laws that that
speak to that but in loco parentis means
there is an implied trust relationship
between the parents and and the school
that's fair and therefore therefore the
school officials are subsidiary to and
should be supportive of the parents
rather than to assume a complementary
role or one that is uh that asserts that
they have the same kind of authority
that parents do
and that's that's part of the issue
that's that's in play here in the
Manchester case which is I understand is
on appeal okay yeah I would love to read
up on that case um so on
make a follow-up I would I have two
other areas of language questions and
then I'm done that was it so just if you
can bear with me actually you're done
when I say you're done but please
continue thank you all right I'm Paige
too many of us have watched C-SPAN and
we think we're in Congress all right on
page three uh uh line 26
um it says uh item T the right to
consent in writing before a record of
their minor child's blood or DNA is
created stored or shared Etc
um this is not anywhere else in the law
and I'm curious as to the Genesis of
this and how it will affect secondary
science classes who
um occasionally do blood typing or
um you know they do the gel
electrophoresis with DNA
um you don't really learn anything
except what DNA looks like
this this does not interfere with the
education process a science class that
would
do blood type and we did that as well
yeah I don't even think we had DNA back
when I was in elementary school that's a
new phenomenon
it's pretty fun actually but uh it's it
the idea is that this um
the the keeping of a of a DNA record
this is all about uh your child's
information being kept by someone
somewhere for some reason and the
parents would have the right to know
who who's collecting the data
this is not science class this is
somebody collecting data on your child
okay and then the last
um one is on page six number five
article seven
um when you're talking about
consequences for violating the law
um so it says in there that if you're
found guilty knowingly violating any
section of the law etc etc so my
question is what is the
um vehicle by which this would be tried
is it through an office of civil rights
complaint is it through the Department
of Education is it police are arresting
people and then it's going through the
criminal court process like who's making
that determination and what are the
standards of evidence that will then be
required
going back to the to the first point is
that it would be a court of competent
jurisdiction
it starts out as a civil action that's
step one actually step one would be a
complaint right I mean one would expect
that a parent would call up the
principal and say I have a complaint go
through the Normal public complaint
process so so we've gotten No
Satisfaction whatsoever Step One is a
civil action
if the teacher
continues down that it becomes a
criminal action
so it would be the the parent would have
the right to file a a complaint
this would be tried in a court of law
because it's a violation of a civil
right so does this parent have to
potentially hire an attorney and file
their own civil complaint do they go to
the department do they go to the
Department of Education like how do they
because right now there's a system right
you appeal appeal representative you're
going on way too far sorry I'm just
leave the question and let them ask it
please all right answer it excuse me
it is a legal process
the burden of filing the complaint is on
the parent if they believe that their
rights have been violated then they file
the complaint on that
than whether it be a trial there'd be
the the the uh the what evidence would
be necessary to convict for a for a
class A misdemeanor that's what the
judges are to decide
thank you any other questions from
anyone else who hasn't asked gets first
dibs representative ball
chairman Pearson and thank you gave my
question
um
I worked in a middle school as the
emotional behavioral specialist which
provided me a lot of opportunity to work
with parents of children who were having
difficulties whether it was emotionally
or oftentimes behaviorally
um would you agree that actually
including the parent in those meetings
that we had to address the children's
Behavior or social emotional components
um Ashley made the allowed the child to
feel safer at home because we now I
wrote a town we now had an Avenue to
provide help for the parents and
education which in special education we
must educate the parents on the child
um disability I'm not saying that this
is disability but
um but it does provide that opportunity
to educate the parent and it also puts
the parent on notice that we know the
child is going home is something that
may not make the parent happy and we
made sure the parent knew we would be
checking in with the child frequently to
be sure they continue to feel safe at
home absolutely so you agree with that
absolutely
um
and would you like another go yes sir
that we've
we've um testimonies saying that the
dance children
tended to me more like I think that was
very high 19 more likely to commit
suicide and so what concerns me is if we
don't would you agree that if we don't
include the parents in on this
conversation
um aren't we putting the child at more
risk at home to lead a double life and
not be allowed to share this with the
parent and get the help they need as a
family unit absolutely absolutely it
goes back to the keeping of Secrets uh a
young man who's a friend of my family my
son one of my sons
um we did not find out or his parents
didn't find out until he was 25 years
old that he had been molested by a man
in his church
it happened when he was nine years old
kept it a secret
it wound up destroying him so that he he
did not succeed at committing suicide
when secrets are kept families and their
and individual lives are destroyed
schools should be fostering a
communication between the children and
the parents if they're mediators in the
to facilitate that conversation God
bless them for being that that that
mediator that referee during those
awkward uh adolescent years whatever the
regardless of the situation someone's
being bullied at school somebody who's
coming out of the closet or whatever
whatever this it doesn't matter what the
situation is parents if that the schools
can provide an um an incredible resource
to provide that relationship between the
parents and the children I think it's
essential thank you
representative Nelson
um going back to um page four uh thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question
um on page four going back to
um lines four through
eight
um isn't it true that the representative
of the school isn't bound to freely
um share the information once received
but actually would only be required to
share information
if the parent asks inquires yes and
that's a very important point the parent
has the the burden is placed on the
parent to ask for the information
the the school is then obligated to not
lie to the parents and actually provide
correct information adequate information
so it's upon inquiry that the that the
parent receives the information it is
only required on the school when it's a
mandatory reporting situation otherwise
not
correct as detailed in the in the in the
law correct just clarify yes I have a
follow-up Mr chairman if okay if you
don't mind thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my follow-up and my
follow-up would be this inquiry would be
at the time asked so it wouldn't be like
a standing order inquiry where the
parent would be allowed to say
I'm inquiring and this inquiry lasts the
entire school year
hadn't really thought about a standing
order I've been out of the Navy for 10
years now so
um no it is upon inquiry it's not a
standing order if if my son ever changes
his pronouns you will tell me no it's a
they need it's the constant
communication thank you appreciate it
thank you for your testimony
accept for representative logs
thank you Mr chairman welcome
um yeah I I'm just trying to get the
need of this uh you know as a parent I
never depended on my children to give me
any information they weren't going to do
that it was my job to know my child my
job to know my child if there's
something I didn't know about my child
I'm not sitting sitting down and having
a conversation with my child enough so
the I'm glad you answered the question I
had the same question with respect to
the school district meaning just the
public schools you're saying no then uh
when you look at page six
um the uh on nine and eleven
uh 2500 be restricted from any further
access to all schools in the district so
if I'm at St Paul's School in Concord
and I'm a teacher that violated I get a
twenty five hundred dollar fine I cannot
teach in Concord for a year uh actually
that 2500 fine is for a contractor or
third party employed by the school that
violates the section yes okay and okay
so has it that'd be like the custodian
or an outside vendor that comes in and
makes a presentation okay so I'm a
custodian at St Paul's and I and I'm
violating this I can't be a custodian at
any school in Concord
District
it is Saint Paul's in Concord
correct nope okay
it
yes okay but I could go to Manchester
and and be a custodian
but you could apply
well like Canada you could you could
have you're not prohibited by the
language in in this particular in these
in these sentences okay you could apply
and um assuming uh you have honest
references that that District would have
to determine whether or not it opted to
employ you whereas the other District
could not for one year yes that's
correct
okay so so the other the other District
if I could follow up the other the other
District that I'm applying for this
doesn't prohibit them from hiring me
this bill doesn't
so it would be an unfair
labor
I don't know if it'd be NFA Labor
practice but it would be unfair labor
law that they wouldn't refuse to hire me
because of the incident I had at St
Paul's
because where does the Lord state that
they can't hire me
right
well if you believe that if if you're if
your reasoning is correct here and I'm
not challenging it but if your reason
Bears out as being correct then you
would want to make some sort of a change
here because you don't want to have an
unfair Labor practice in in in the law
right okay so so either gonna take it
out entirely or what you're going to do
is you're going to make it applicable in
every school district throughout the
state so it's either for everybody or
for nobody okay yeah I think that's a
that's a that's a good option I
appreciate that thank you so uh just one
more question which the um
all the all the laws that are here
federal or statutory laws are there
remedies already
so my teacher didn't tell me that my son
has joined a
um
joined a rugby uh club that I told them
I didn't want him to be in a rugby class
the rugby I didn't want to play in rugby
so they didn't they didn't tell me
um so
do I have remedies now that it's statute
I've not found any remedies where if if
the teacher allows or the school allows
your child to participate in an activity
joins the Rugby Club against your
permission or without your permission or
without your knowledge I have I've not
found where there is any remedy today
and then you inquire and then you're
told
and then you say I I don't want my child
participating in the chess club or rugby
or whatever I'm not aware of there being
any
um any sanction for that at this time so
the answer is no I don't we don't know
okay thank you
Bickford thank you Mr chairman you know
thank you take my question
what about
uh police or sros can I go up to them
and say I want to know what my children
are up to
sros are the school resource officer can
I expect them to report about my
children
as well as teachers Etc
because they're they're Gathering all
kinds of information on students that's
their job actually
you know it's always nice to know about
the party too that's going to happen
before it happens
you'll get an invite next time sir
we do not specifically
they are they are
they are employees but they are some of
them may be employees some of them may
be third party because they may be not
actually part of the school or school
that they might be and a police
department an actual police officer of
say Concord Police Department I don't
know each School may be different uh but
if they are we do not specify that sros
would would that the parent could go and
inquire it about the at the school
resource officer
well I think the question is um what is
the chain of accountability here with
respect to the employment of the school
resource officer is the school resource
officer and employee of the school or is
the school res officer an employee of
the of the local police department in
which case that would then give us an
indication of where we need to uh to
raise some further questions
particularly if it's the police
department in my school district if I
may the school pays for the uh police
officer during the school hours
it's on the warrant right now okay but I
that's a resource talk about you know we
want information that's their job is to
gather information and I'm saying you
know maybe it's a good idea parents know
what
what's going that's the place early
ought to know the parents have the right
to the information
that's what we're getting at is the
parents have the right to make the
inquiry and obtain the information well
do we have a confidential issue going on
here
a confidential issue with juvenile they
haven't committed a crime but they
gather the information about you know
sexting and that sort of thing
and but the parents aren't I'm not sure
if they're getting the information
about it
I was just
well once again the only way that they
would be able to uh to to to gain such
information would be to make an inquiry
of the school resource officer because
the school resource officer is not
required to contact the parents and tell
the parents uh under the under under the
provisions of of this proposed
legislation now the school resource
officer it may be a policy of the school
it may be a policy in the community that
uh that the school resource officer is
obligated to do that but that that's
separate from what is encompassed within
this bill
yeah right okay okay I'm disappointed as
we currently understand it well uh it
you know it we thought it was perfect
but maybe it's not quite there yet and
maybe you could help to perfect it yeah
thank you
seriously
thank you so much for coming up here uh
representative would you like your
presentation uh yes and I'm going to
truncate this out of Mercy for uh the
members of the public is behind me and
just for the Reformation of the public
if everyone who signed the pink card
speaks for 10 minutes
it is 10 hours we will be here yeah
you're not going to testify for 10
minutes you're going to testify for two
because we are kind to you
so if you had a long testimony this is
the good time to boil it down to two
minutes the last hearing demonstrated it
could be done
go so thank you I'm I thank you
colleagues for the opportunity I'm
pleased to be once again be able to
speak in support of hb10 this year's
version of the parents Rights bill uh
the the version that I sponsored uh last
year along with uh Jeff is a co-sponsor
almost made it we hope that it will be
uh uh sufficiently if acceptable uh to
Representatives such that it can pass
this year uh remembering that no piece
of legislation is uh is perfect and if
it needs to be tweaked in as we as the
saying goes in the future of course
we're more than willing for that to be
supportive of those uh suggestions
um I believe we're in the throes of a
great philosophical and political
struggle that goes to the heart of the
question of the proper role in place of
Educators and health care providers for
minor children in relationship to the
children whose parents have entrusted to
them for their educations in health care
including the skull of both
the Educators and the healthcare
professionals what we know is that the
judicial record is clear
a child according to the fourth Circuit
Court of Appeals and their decision was
not appealed to the Supreme Court
therefore this their ruling in this
opinion stands is quote not the mere
creature creature of the state
close quote now this is an important
assertion uh or recognition and
assertion in my view and the reason for
that is because we have actually had
countries
in within the 20th century that we can
look back upon who asserted that
children were actually the property of
the state
maybe most of you are so young you do
not remember the Soviet Union but that
was the case in Bolshevik and stalinist
Soviet Union
we take a different view here in this in
this country and we're clear that a
child is quote not the mere creature of
the state
that decision was Troxel versus
Granville in the year 2000 further the
Court ruled and declared quote it is
difficult to Envision why a school
would even claim much less how a school
could establish a generalized interest
in withholding or concealing from the
parents of minor children information
fundamental to a child's identity
personhood and mental and emotional
well-being such as their preferred name
and pronouns close quote
I didn't even know that we were
discussing such things in 2000 I was too
busy parenting I guess
so therefore absent any established
compelling State interests the right of
parents to determine the educations in
health care of their children is primary
inherent in such a recognition is a
tenet that parents have a right to know
what their children are being taught and
how they're being treated by ones who
stand in a de facto and professionally
determined relationship of Trustee of
parents and to their into whom they are
therefore accountable
I believe that the greatest point of
tension in our time is the teaching of
children by school Personnel that their
gender identity is fluid in a matter of
choice
but more is the assertion that the
teaching of these precepts is protected
against parental inquiry
they're being claimed by many that a
parent has no right to know
what this amounts to is an assertion of
a right that has no basis in law or
nature
and that effectively challenges the
primary role of a parent to direct the
upbringing and care of children
in one sense hb10 is a corrective to
this departure from law and historic
practice but in another and even just as
more important sense and I want to
underscore this
because it's it's a perspective that
only was begun to be scratched at here a
little while ago hb10 provides for
greater clarity
in the proper role of Educators and
health care providers with regard to
their relationship with both parents and
children while in one sense it may be
seen as a corrective in a larger sense
it serves the purpose of advancing the
people's will to better Define and
encourage greater Trust
between schools and their personnel
Health Care Providers parents and their
children hb10 recognizes that parents
and Guardians have multiple statutory
rights to direct the education and care
of their minor children
regrettably not all parents children and
school Personnel are aware of these
statutory rights
what hb10 accomplishes is the bringing
together in one place so to speak an
enumeration of these rights establishes
a handful of new ones wxy and requires
that all affected parties be made aware
of what they are
we have a right we have a responsibility
to inform parents what their rights are
and what their responsibilities are
in my life and career I devoted a great
deal of time to help people know what
they did not know
and to encourage them to live into the
knowledge and practice of those things
that would raise their quality of life
and enhance their relationships with
others and this is how I see hb10 not as
a weapon
but as a tool
a tool for parents and Educators and
Health Care practitioners to more
effectively work together to care for
children to which each respectively and
specifically have been entrusted
parents are at the center yes and they
are the primary decision makers yes
professional Educators and health care
providers are resource persons
their helpers
clarifying and securing these roles in
relationships is in view in hb10 and so
I urge that you consider it favorably
and move it forward for the betterment
of everyone here in the state of New
Hampshire thank you
thank you representative before we move
on to testimony I have uh about two
minutes for the committee
um next Tuesday is town meeting day
and the note came from our committee
assistant would we be interested
therefore in changing the day of our
meeting next week to Wednesday
the chairman of Judiciary who normally
gets this room on Wednesdays will not be
needing it next Wednesday so we could
meet here and not at stores garage
but it's just are you thinking this is a
good idea I can be here either day are
you interested in Tuesday next week town
meeting day will affect some of you or
Wednesday
you're good you look good you look very
good yeah but that's not what you meant
is it no okay how many would how many uh
and you can vote twice here uh how many
would like Tuesday
I can do Tuesday that's pretty much
everybody except couple how many would
like Wednesday
looks like Tuesday has it
sorry
now as I said I put my watch away and
instead I have a calendar
and that was a laugh line and if I hold
up the cards on one side and the cards
on another side 10 minutes equals 10
hours I did the math so we're going into
a two minute rule we do that so those of
you who have been patiently waiting and
will be long patiently waiting will not
be here at 10 o'clock tonight or you'll
have invested a whole day and you never
testified because you had to go home at
nine so I'm asking my vice chair who has
abilities on his phone to do countdowns
and at a minute 45 he can wave something
or say a minute 45 to let you know it is
time to wrap it up and you're not going
to be punished by me shutting off your
mic go to but I will do that if you go
much longer so with that in mind I'm
going to take people from Bo Stacks call
two names and so if somebody's in the
other room you've got a few minutes
actually two to walk down here first up
is
[Music]
representative Sean from Cheshire
district 7 and pronounce your last name
for me please
okay of course yeah and Sarah Smith is
in the on Deck circle of Sarah here
if she's in the other room she can
wander down
so thank you representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee I will be
amending the testimony that I had
planned today for the interests of
parsimony a little bit about my
background I have a law degree and
worked for the Massachusetts Attorney
General's office in the Civil Rights
Division I also hold a PhD in health
promotion and was a tenured faculty
member at Flinders University in South
Australia and it published over two
dozen peer-reviewed articles in the
areas of human sexuality and health
promotion
I come today to give you a brief tour of
the academic literature in the areas of
lgbtq mental health a little bit more
brief than what I had initially planned
the academic literature is unequivocal
according to data from the U.S Surgeon
General as a whole lgbtq youth are six
times more likely to commit suicide as
are their straight peers and some
estimates put that as 20 times more
likely that statistic remains true when
we control for factors like race
socioeconomic status and other
potentially confounding variables
why is it that lgbtq youth are
substantially more likely to commit
suicide it's that we live in a culture
that is tremendously hostile towards
lgbtq people
you don't need to look any further than
the Nightly News to confirm that fact
representative if you have about a
minute so steer it back into the bill
please
unfortunately lgbtq youth oftentimes
have a negative experience coming out
the title of a 2016 academic article
aptly sums it up family support would
have been like amazing indeed recent
academic research demonstrates that the
median experience of coming out to
family is negative or hostile but
I know that sometimes as a legislator
hearing research Falls in deaf ears so
listen to my experience of working on
the Trevor Project which is an lgbtq
suicide hotline
a youth called in with gun in hand after
he had been outed to his mother against
his will you now have 20 seconds Sir
this youth
said that his mother told him that she
no longer loved him that he was an
Abomination before God
and that she wanted him out of the house
I spoke to him for over an hour and we
talked about ways to deal with stress
and how we could talk to his mother
again
and then the chat went silent
I tried to contact him to see if he was
there but
he wasn't
I don't know what happened to him and
perhaps I never will
how many chats like that will it take
for you to find this bill in expedient
to legislate
I now call Sarah Smith if she's in the
room there she is and in the on Deck
circle is representative Sellers from
Grafton District 18.
foreign
on the bottom and it turns right at the
top
that bottom thank you uh my name is
Sarah Smith uh and uh I live in Pembroke
New Hampshire I'm a retired teacher
um and uh I'll be short I had just a
couple things I wanted to say about this
um if I was morally faced with a
situation where I was talking to
somebody
who who and they were they wanted to
they were telling me about their
pronouns for instance and I knew that I
had to report them to their parents for
that and at the same time they were also
telling me
don't tell my parents they'll kill me
you know which is how they kid would
speak maybe they literally would kill
them but
um
you you're saying you're putting me in
the situation where I would have to
report that knowing that they would be
harmed and I find that morally
um reprehensible that I would be put in
the position of putting someone in the
way of harm that's my objection to this
bill
and
um
I but if you had to have a bill like
this I did find an area that you could
fix
and that is that you've left out the
idea of
uh
the you mentioned military recruiters
but you failed to mention ROTC and in
some states kids are put into ROTC
without their parents permission that
should be included too
are there any questions
thank you thank you very much the chair
next recognizes representative Sellers
from Grafton district 18 to come up and
in the on Deck Circle flown in at Great
expense is Emma Greg
thank you Mr chairman thank you
committee members for hearing my
testimony
I just want to I as I was sitting here I
was just taking notes I don't really
have anything prepared to say I just
wanted
to say a few statements and let you know
a few things here
one thing I noticed that you know the a
child goes to school for about 12 years
all right during that time it's about 12
960 hours of the child's life
six hours a day
180 days a year
during that same 12 years
are at that point they're 18 years old
so during that time there they have
actually you know lived 50 uh 156 780
hours so basically the school has the
child for eight point eight point two
percent of their life during the entire
12 years
it comes back that the parental rights
here is the parents and then at that at
this point here it's
the um you know we have to come back and
say is it is it the
and I don't want to use the word
ownership because it's not the right
word but does the government does the
school own the child
or is the child the property and the
upbringing of the parents are the
parents and I think we're getting things
confused there and things are getting
backwards and another thing I want to
bring up is you know we see we see out
there it says
you see something say something
but when it comes to schools and parents
you hear something you don't say
anything
it doesn't make sense
so some of these things we're trying to
protect the parents so the parents have
that choice of knowing if something's
going on with their child and I think
that is important that the parent needs
the right to know and you need to be
protecting the parent not the government
thank you
thank you representative next up is Emma
Greg and in the on Deck circle is Aubrey
Friedman
do we have an Audrey Freeman
right in front of me
uh hi can you guys hear me clearly okay
good afternoon Mr chairman and committee
thank you for your time my name is Emma
Gregg I'm 16 years old a sophomore in
high school and I'm a Survivor of
domestic violence I'm here to ask you to
vote against hb10 as a Survivor I know
the importance of being able to have
trusted teachers and faculty at schools
while some parents are good and
trustworthy I know firsthand the damage
a parent can inflict according to the
National Children's Alliance in 2020 618
000 children were victims of abuse and
neglect 77 of those cases were abused by
a parent
as many as 10 million children witness
violence between their parents or
caregivers each year
growing up in my household we hit a
secret one that included holes in the
walls bruises constant yelling and
threats my biological thought that we
were his property that he could own
everything about us and what we did we
were told what happened at home was
family business then one day he was
taken out of our house as we started to
figure out that this wasn't how
everybody lived we became more scared of
my dad and what he might do
my mom had me and my siblings pick a
teacher that we trusted at school that I
could talk that we could talk to I
picked the school counselor and my
fourth grade teacher
and as having hard and scary days I knew
I could talk to them some things I
didn't care if my mom knew about and
other things I wasn't ready to talk to
her about
I was confused and working through a lot
of emotions at home there was still a
feeling of being scared about what might
happen I didn't want my dad to know
any of it he had been very violent and I
knew that he would hurt us after
knocking out and strangling my brother
while he was in our house my dad told us
that if we told anyone he would finish
the job
if a billic HP 10 was in place at that
time I can't imagine I would be able to
be sitting here today to testify
my mom has always made sure that we know
that this journey in our in survival is
our own that we get to make choices on
how we deal with this she also empowers
us to ask teachers and get different
perspectives between even because even
adults can make mistakes
sorry teachers and counselors are
required to go to school and get degrees
to teach and advise kids but anyone can
be a parent with no degree or classes
required
without the ability to be able to talk
through some very confusing times with
my teacher and knowing that I was
protected my journey in surviving would
not would be very different and not as
successful
I have many friends who have trusted
conversations with teachers because they
are scared of their parents we need to
empower we need to we need to be
empowered to figure things out without
retribution from a retribution from
abusive and violent parents even though
not every house was like mine many are
and you can't tell the difference on
behalf of my friends and other students
I ask you to understand the damage a
bill like this can do please vote
against hb10 thank you thank you Emma
chair now recognizes Aubrey Friedman
with Brian Harlow as Brian Harlow around
for the on Deck Circle
um anyway go ahead
Aubrey Friedman Bridgewater I speak in
support of this bill uh there's a few
things I don't like about it but it's
definitely a step in the right direction
I think it doesn't the thing that people
freak out about is this a changing
excuse me changing the names and the
pronoun thing at school the thing I
think more people these days are
accepting of if you're gay or I know
people will dispute that but I think
it's more accepted these days gay
bisexual whatever but if the kid goes to
school and they want to change their
pronouns and do all that stuff that's
where people freak out and that to me
goes beyond the line and that's where
parents have to know so people also say
well you're this will force people to uh
teachers to out the kids that's not true
if a kid confides to a teacher or a
counselor or whoever at school people
that they're gay or bisexual or
transgender I don't see anything in this
bill that requires the teacher to tell
the parents
and they really shouldn't you know it's
a confidential thing but if they go over
the line they go no we're going to
change I'm now a different gender and
you've got to have a different name that
goes over the line that's crazy as far
as I'm concerned and this bill I know in
sau4 we have pushed the administration
on this and they say the policy is that
we will encourage the kids to tell their
parents but we will not tell the parents
themselves and we're talking about
changing the name and the pronoun and
all that stuff at school that's crazy so
I think that parents need to be informed
of that but there's no reason nothing in
this bill that would force a teacher to
being like an informant or uh
you know to uh
you know inform on the kids so I think
there's a lot of emotionalism there and
it's just not in the bill that I can see
and also thank you very much you have
hit the two minute mark
chair recognizes Brian Harlem
representative J.R Hull in the on Deck
Circle
okay
Mr chairman in the committee thank you
for providing me with this opportunity
um the sponsors of HP 10 wonder why the
lgbtq community seems concerned
I'd just like to say children are well
aware if they're loved at home
children are also inherently aware if
their home is safe
safe is in safe to divulge I'm queer gay
trans bi non-binary what have you
safe as in safe for Mom to know
Dad Grandma Uncle what have you
is abusing me
and will take action to protect me
or dad to know I'm being abused by my
other dad whatever it may be
this bill will put some kids at risk all
kids
no of course not but I guarantee more
than we can imagine
mark my words not all priest abuse not
all coaches abuse not all Scout leaders
at all abuse
but trans kids do get kicked out of
their homes for Having the courage to
live authentically
lgbtq kids do have
the gay beat out of them
by some parents not all
when they find out am I talking about
all parents of course not but it does
happen
I volunteered in Cambridge with Bagley
which is a non-profit working with LGBT
kids lgbtq kids who find themselves on
the streets homeless
I didn't learn what I'm telling you now
from Twitter or from the guy next to me
I heard their stories they were
heartbreaking
I'm not looking for your Provisions to
protect kids I'm looking for you to vote
in expedient to legislate which will in
my opinion protect those kids
I have one question which I know can't
be answered now but just rhetorically
and okay real quick the sponsors keep
hammering home this doesn't green light
abuse
in crafting the test and crafting hb10
did the sponsor's contact the New
Hampshire Coalition against Domestic and
Sexual Violence or any of the 12 crisis
centers in our state
to read and look at the problematic
aspects if so
please share that view and if not why
not seek expert guidance thank you for
listening and
thank you very much itl
chair recognizes representative J.R hole
with Emily Perez and the on-dike circle
is erili here
thank you chairman representative hole
serving the District of Merrimack 27
here in support of hb10 as filed
I think everybody in this room
shares the view that children are
important and we should do whatever we
can within our power to protect them
that's clear how we may go about it
might differ but we all have a common
goal to make sure children
in typically in their home environment
if at all possible
are provided for are protected are
supported are loved or cherished
and are raised to be responsible adults
um we also know
that not every family is perfect I wish
I wish that was the case you can get you
need a license to drive a car but not be
a dad
um
not that I'm arguing for licenses for
either but my point there is right there
it's easier to be a parent some in some
cases than it would be
um to learn how to drive something as
simple as a car that most adults do
I also want everybody to realize that
when the state gets involved with a
family
okay
no matter what their goal is there will
be harm that happens the goal when the
state gets involved is to minimize the
harm to the child meaning the state's
involvement and the harm that comes from
that is less than the harm that the
child is experiencing at that present
time
in the ideal world that would be a
hundred percent of the time and
unfortunately sometimes that isn't the
case
I think putting a bill forward to make
it clear relative to the best interest
of the child thank you
um
that when the state gets involved their
goal should be to support the child
at the best interest and sometimes that
means not getting involved with that
I'll close my testimony and ask that you
passed this as filed thank you
thank you representative
the chair recognizes early Perez and in
the index circle is Derek burnt do we
have Derek burnt anywhere just wait
thank you Derek burn for waving Eric Lee
Perez come on up
foreign
I'm reading on behalf of Erica Perez
from the New Hampshire youth movement
got it thank you good afternoon members
of the committee
I am from Manchester and today I will be
speaking in opposition to hb10 my
biggest issue with the bill is the
punishment put in place for teachers
for a first-time offense credentials
for a first-time offense credentials are
to be suspended for a year do we really
think that a bill that is written to be
so vague that this is a practical
repercussion we are trying to get more
teachers to quit at a time when we need
teachers the most
teachers are often part of a safe space
for students this bill would find any
teacher who encourages or courses or
attempts to encourage or coerce a minor
trial to withhold information from his
or her parent as breaking the law I
don't think that Educators would be
purposefully encourage any student to
withhold information from a parent but
what if the parent isn't providing a
safe space for their child
I come from a Catholic household myself
my mom despite being generally accepted
of other people always made comments
about how she would never want me to be
gay I was out as a bisexual at school
and some teachers were aware of that had
I been out at home at that age it would
have put me in an uncomfortable
situation with my parents I wasn't ready
to have that hard conversation yet
because I didn't know what the outcome
of that conversation would be would I be
accepted or put down would my housing be
at risk these are hard questions but
they're even harder at 17 even now at 24
I can't get myself to tell my family
that I'm non-binary because I'm scared
of how damaging that information could
be to our relationship
this bill also mentions a guarantee for
a parent to opt his or her minor child
out of any portion of the school
district's health education program that
relates to sex education instruction and
acquired immunity immune deficiency
syndrome education you have 15 seconds
to finish institution regarding
sexuality my question is why why would
we take away a student's decision to
learn about those things in an
educational setting where they can ask
questions and be prepared to make good
decisions about their health thank you
for your testimony and would you please
fill out a pink card with your name on
it for the record indicating whose
testimony you read thank you
and next up is I I read it as Darrell
burnt with Elaine plant up behind next
okay there's a lane here
put your hand up if you are that'll do
thank you
hi I'm here to testify in opposition to
hb10 as a child my parents made it their
goal to opt me out of every form of sex
education that was an abstinence only
and they made their goal to convince me
to be as homophobic and transphobic as
possible I'd like to summarize for you
the impact that this did and did not
have in my life
it didn't prevent me from realizing I'm
trans it didn't prevent me from learning
about sexual sexuality and it didn't
stop me from falling in love with a
trans person
who's now my life partner
here's what it did do though it caused
me to lose years of Friendship with my
high school best friend who came out
before I had moved away from the harmful
beliefs that my parents gave me caused
me to seek out sexual information from
unreliable and dangerous sources and it
stunted my knowledge of basic Sexual
Health in such a way that my intimacy
and Trust in marriage was and in smaller
ways continues to be harmed when I think
about the lives of my high school
friends with the same experience many of
them CIS straight kids this last Point
sticks out I know so many people who
when they got married they experienced
pain and suffering because they were not
given education and rather made to feel
ashamed of their bodies my life
experience has shown me that it is
impossible to stigmatize and shame queer
sexuality without also stigmatizing and
shaming the monogamous sexuality that
the writers of this bill would hold up
is morally correct
the right that this bill upholds is not
the parental right to keep their child
from learning information I don't know
that that's even possible rather it's
the right of a parent to harm their
child's ability to form intimate and
loving relationships and friendships to
grow into a healthy and well-connected
adult I hope after you hear this that
you can understand that this bill uses
the language of protecting children but
it provides the legal framework for
parents to do great harm please vote in
opposition I'd also like to add that our
law only provides to protect kids after
they have been abused kids know their
parents will abuse them if they come out
and the law provides no protection for
theoretical abuse and this makes it
easier for that abuse to happen
I'll take any questions
representative Raymond thank you I'm
sorry one question I just didn't get
your name and I like to take notes huh
Derek burnt thank you
thank you chair recognizes it looks like
Elaine plant I think I have that correct
and on the on Deck circle is Cameron
muns
and then uh representative Perez
from Londonderry
ah thank you so Elaine plant Dover New
Hampshire
um I agree that it is a fundamental
right of parents to direct the
upbringing in Education and Care of
their minor children
important information relating to a
minor should not be withheld from his or
her parent including information
relating to the miners child's health
well-being education and education while
the minor is in the custody of the
school district
parents have a fundal fundamental and
inalienable right to be the influencers
and Moral Moral Compass of their family
and their children
this begs the question that's being
asked why why is a parent's
Rights bill necessary and the answer is
that the school have overstepped their
boundaries in all these areas and are
usurping the fundamental rights of
parents as the gentleman had said before
in the in the beginning of this meeting
that there is an attitude that our
children should be educated differently
from how they've been educated in the
past and that parents are abusive
the amount of information of a sexually
explicit nature being provided in the
schools is overwhelming over 90 sexually
explicit books in our school libraries
and on Sora why are we hypersexualizing
our children to begin with the American
School counseling Association has
encouraged their trainees to lie
undermine and withhold information from
parents this does not make schools a
safe place if this is where the training
is coming from in their training program
titled No Limits there is video of this
lead leadership detailing this
undermining in their own words this is
discoverable you can find it on
Courageous habit.org by Alvin Louie
um and in addition there are surveys
designed to be self-fulfilling
prophecies in there through the data
mining of the surveys that we have
um I agree with representative ball that
connecting the parents with counseling
is one of the best things you can do
include the parents in the conversation
and this will then build trust where
there currently is none thank you for
your testimony
the chair recognizes Cameron munz with
representative Christine Perez in the on
Deck Circle
so just to give you some context I was a
public educator in Nashua for 11 years
before I chose to resign because of
well because of why I'm here today
second of all I just want to comment
that if you want to
make a claim on over sexualizing
children then I would like to see you at
Target in front of the baby section
um with uh you know protesting against
the
uh the baby like onesies of like
Ladies Man or you know anything like
that so if that's what you're actually
worried about I'll see you at Target
um so I'm in complete opposition of this
bill due to its blatant anti-trans
government overreach and it would be an
offense to anyone in this room to think
that it is not anti-trans uh if you
notice all the people coming up they're
mentioning uh trans rights they're
mentioning heaven forbid their child
actually
um you know uses the English language
and and plays with pronouns
um I'm also in opposition to it because
it it goes in quite contrast to hb619
which was heard earlier today which
takes the rights of medical decisions
away from parents with their trans
children and yet in hb10
um someone actually sitting just here
one of the co-sponsors said parents and
not the state are responsible for
upbringing of their children so I'm
concerned with some obvious
um hypocrisy in that
hb619 also says that public school
schools K through 12 in New Hampshire
shall refer to children by the name and
gender that they're enrolled as but hb10
says that parents have their rights
um so that would
potentially get rid of the rights of the
appearance of trans students so
essentially basically everything that
I've been listening to today has been
contradicting itself in the name of
protecting children but really what it
is is its anti-trans legislature and
someone earlier today said that tools
can be uh this is a tool not a weapon
but tools can be used as Weapons when
wielded to cause harm
thank you for your testimony
um
Aaron
pankajuk I'm sorry representative is
next then Aaron and please correct me
when you come up here I have penkachik
is in the on Deck Circle
first I'd like to thank apologize for
overstepping my bouncing coming up to
you welcome I mean forgiven whatever
welcome thank you hi my name is
Christine Perez I am from Londonderry I
am a retired nurse I am a mother I'm a
grandmother and I'm now a state
representative about three years ago
um I had a bunch of parents that I was
going and speaking at school board
meetings with who were having a terrible
time getting any response from their
school board to find out what was going
on with their children to find out what
books were in the library what their
children what Choose Love was
um they were having a horrible time many
of these parents withdrew their children
from public school based on that last
May these parents approached me and
asked me to become a state
representative never did I think I would
I ended up on the Judiciary committed
committee and I believe that I was put
there for a reason although it wasn't
one of my choices
um I keep wondering so I decided that I
was going to be a rep because one of my
main goals was to stand up for parents
and children not my only but parents and
children and I keep wondering why we're
here even discussing this what has
happened to our society that we have to
have laws protecting parents whether
they be biological adoptive custodial or
whatever these parents were not having
problems with sexual orientation for
their children it was much more General
things that were going on so this is not
just a bill to protect parents of lbgq
children on March 1st 2020 through 2023
a representative and six co-sponsors
introduced in the U.S House of
Representatives a parental rights
amendment to the Constitution the
amendment would ensure enshrine that
means Preserve in a form that ensures it
to be protected and respected the
traditional Liberty you have 10 seconds
left okay and direct the child's
upbringing in education this is common
sense
children are not given Advil in schools
without permission can't go on field
trips there is a bill right now that to
raise the age thank you for your
testimony we will now hear Aaron Penick
chick and followed by Zoe Hill thank you
you're gonna hit the red button first
I'm going to give you back some of your
time because most of what I wanted to
say has already been said but uh and in
particular the lady that just testified
thought about most of it I keep hearing
everybody's falling back on the lgbtq
issues on this bill we've been hearing
all day on this testimony it's not just
about that it's about teaching materials
it's about books it's about electronic
access to books including the Sora app
it's about counseling it's about health
it's about surveys being taken from the
kids it's about bullying it's about
disciplinary action
why can't parents have I don't even know
why we're having this conversation to be
honest with you like the lady there just
said
it boggles my mind frankly that we have
to have a bill that allows parents to be
participating completely and holy in
their children's education so I urge you
to vote this bill OTP for those reasons
and I'll give you back the rest of my
time sir thank you sir
chair recognizes representative Emily
Phillips from Rockingham district 7 and
friend
did the friend sign a pink card
more than a friend this is Teddy uh so
I'm Emily Phillips I represent Fremont
New Hampshire Rockingham 7.
um I ran for office based on the
parental rights uh issue I want you to
know that I stood out front as an
activist before I decided to run because
it was so important for the last term
parental Bill of Rights to pass and it
didn't happen
um so here I am I want you to know that
we represent the people of New Hampshire
the people of New Hampshire on both
sides
I believe want this bill to pass so
that's also the only thing I want to get
a parent speak about I think that um
a lot of people are pinning this to be a
trans issue I don't think it is I just
want transparency I was on the school
board for three years in my town I've
seen a lack of transparency as far as
what parents have access to know what's
going on in the school with their kids
and I think this is a very important
issue and then it's going to keep coming
up so if we don't pass it now it's going
to continue to come back parents want to
know what's going on in um their kids
school so open to questions I'm sure you
guys want to move along
that's it
you have about 10 seconds more and we
can look at the cute one for about 10
seconds
oh
oh I'll see you in the in the House of
Representatives in about 16 years yeah
hopefully
hopefully I'll be gone by then
how's that well they do let older people
in but thank you thank you
and Zoe Hill is next with Stephen Lafond
in the on Deck Circle
no Stephen Lafond so far I mean no uh
somebody do we have Stephen Lafond
I do not see if he walks in from next
door actually we have plenty of choice
seats down here in um
the regular room then uh Janine
um babarat
Andrew McPherson
Sally stoud
with Heather Mullins I think next
foreign
hello
this bill isn't about concern of what
individual teachers think of doing with
a child that they do or they don't do
this is about dealing with what a school
system or District plans in a very
organized fashion
to have more control in the students
lives
representative ball suggested school
meetings with students parents and staff
and that is a very good idea because it
takes away the secrecy
parents have no idea what's going on in
their kids schools I've been testifying
in my school district school board
meetings for two years and I ran for
school board and I can tell you what's
going on
obscene books in the library we've
already identified 85 in the Dover
School libraries that are horrendous 85
I can give you a list
um access to pornography via Soro Sora
which is the online the library the
schools you use
with links to pornographic websites
on the school issued computers
bathroom issues affecting all the
students with destruction of bathrooms
drug use people being afraid to use the
bathrooms
students being surveyed and counseled by
Behavior Specialists and teachers with
very little if any training to be doing
that
Equity walks in K-12
less than adequate class time focused on
academics as evidenced by the very low
proficiency scores for 10 years in Dover
you have 15 seconds left get the
juiciest sentence
and curriculum content
parents have no clue I have all of it I
filed a 91a and I have it
I think we need to pass this bill
because we need transparency for parents
thank you
uh yes will you take a quick question
yes certainly
thank you for taking my question
um I've been doing a little bit of
research and I was shocked uh to see and
would you believe that uh three quarters
of parents are unaware that ninety
percent of children beginning at the age
of eight have been exposed to online
pornography on their telephones on their
tablets more often than not in their
homes
well but they but they're doing it on
the school issued Chromebooks and
they're doing it through Sora the
library link but they're also doing it
through Spotify which is a music link
and kinks.com
uh grindr.com these are these links and
worse are connected by these books
online from the school
Sora app
thank you
thank you so much the chair recognizes
uh Heather Mullins with Andy Bemis in
the on Deck Circle
well Helen Mullins will get another
chance then I will recognize Andy Bemis
with Paul Santos in the on Deck Circle
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Andy Bemis I'm
opposed to hb10 I grew up in New
Hampshire at a time when the environment
for lgbtq minors and adults was more
hostile than it is now as a parent of
two teens I've been lucky to see how
much better things have gone gotten for
my kids and their families the support
they get from their friends their
families and their teachers uh growing
up as transgender is still uniquely
challenging under the best circumstances
but the love and affirmation these kids
receive makes a world of difference and
I wish I had had the same when I was
growing up
powering individual parents to object to
lgbtq affirming curriculum and punishing
teachers for respecting the confidence
of students who may not feel safe
disclosing their gender identities to
their parents would undermine the
support our children rely on
parents who object to curriculum related
to sexuality already have the freedom to
discuss alternate assignments with their
students teachers and New Hampshire
already requires any adult not only
teachers to respect to report suspected
child abuse or negligence the
representatives who presented this bill
have already made a good case for how
redundant it is
this bill would only succeed in making
some of our most vulnerable children
less safe and in some cases enable their
abuse
if the Bill's authors are motivated by
parents rights as they say they are then
I urge you to listen to the families
that have presented their stories today
um there's this idea that keeps coming
up I'd like to add that this isn't
actually about lgbtq issues so I look
forward to the circumstance where a
teacher overhears a male student talking
about how they have the Huts for a girl
and then are compelled to have to tell
uh their parents that their son is in
fact straight uh so don't tell me that's
not what this is about like if we're
here to be honest let's be honest
and as for those of you who have
testified in opposition for the bill
um it's been wonderful hearing your
stories today and uh you know I think
it's given me strength and I hope you
all feel the same
thank you very much
thank you for your testimony Paul Santos
with David Trumbull
behind him
thank you very much I appreciate being
here I'm Paul Sontag from the Amherst
Milford area South Union Valley and uh
before I shot I only have one point I
really want to cover from all the rest
that's been touched
um but I would just wanted to say that
I'm totally
um affirming and supportive of all the
services that go out to LGBT community
so whatever I say please realize that
all those services are necessary for you
folks to get what you need for mental
health Etc
my um topic would be it would be talking
about
um the relationship between teachers and
parents and and superintendents and
School administration we talked a lot
about
um confidentiality and transparency and
um so I've been a teacher principal for
30 years and then with extra um
experience later on I'm also a recovery
coach at the present time but what I'd
like to say is about this is that all
the teachers that I know look for a
school district where they can work with
parents they love parents that's why
they're there they did not come just to
teach to teach subjects they came
together and be a relationship with the
students and the parents you might not
believe that but it's really true and so
the idea is for my suggestion here to
mitigate a lot of this stuff without a
lot of money I would really look for an
initiative where parents and and
teachers and the administrator can start
building relationships one of the issues
down here as we said you know if
teachers love working with parents
that's what I always did you know and
parents really want to have a great
relationship with their their teachers
because they know they're going to get a
good education if they have a good
relationship with them so what's the key
relation what's the key Point here the
key point is trust and if you can if
parents and teachers can have trust
relationship together what do you think
the children are going to model
what do you think they're going to model
they're going to model the adults that
are in their life you're already over
could you wrap it up in about 10 seconds
exactly I could it says you cannot you
can't mandate relationship but it'll
mitigate a whole lot and I still would
suggest that if you get the two to come
together and listen to one another we
would have great success thank you sir
David Trumbull with
um
Kerry Coventry up next
foreign
good afternoon thank you for having me I
opposed this bill for a couple reasons
first of all if this bill is just the
catalog of parents rights all listed in
one place except for w x and y as was
said by one of the presenters then just
take out WX and Y why don't we just have
a discussion about whether or not we
should have a parent's Bill of Rights
and then next time talk about lgbtq
rights because this is getting conflated
into two completely different issues and
the losers are going to be the lgbtq
children in this state second parents
rights are important I'm a parent I have
two kids that went through the public
schools but they're not absolute they
don't all of a sudden get 100 of the
rights when they turn 18 it's developed
it comes over time just look at your
custody cases and divorces the Supreme
Court of New Hampshire says that around
the age of 13 or 14 the child's wishes
become crucial we should recognize and
respect children's wishes parents are
important but they shouldn't be given
extreme Supreme rights number three this
bill is only going to affect two
situations in the real world homes that
are not safe the homes that are safe the
parents who support their lgbtq children
this bill isn't going to affect them but
the places where they're not safe this
bill is going to make that child's life
much more unsafe and it's not going to
necessarily lead to abuse it will
probably lead to homelessness somewhere
between 30 and 40 percent of lgbtq kids
especially transgender children end up
being homeless that's what's going to
happen they're going to get outed and
the parent asks a question and they're
going to end up out on the street and
that's a dangerous place for a young
person to be and lastly the person who's
also going to lose in this is the lgbtq
kids who lose a safe place to be 22
percent of high school children in this
country according to the CDC or lgbtq
this bill is going to be perceived as an
anti-lgbtq bill by all of these children
they're not going to feel like they can
talk to their teachers anymore so
they're going to lose that one safe
place you think that's important one
trusted adult reduces the risk of
suicide 40 percent I urge you to look up
online the Amicus curiai brief in that
Manchester lawsuit it's available to
everybody it's great reading it's filled
with citations and sources with data
it's got every single argument you need
to know why this bill is bad thank you
very much wow you get so much packed in
just over two minutes
amazing it can be done
um it's either Kerry Kerry commentary is
it
don't see Paige wood
Paige wood now up
hi my name is Paige wood I live in
Greenfield New Hampshire
uh and I strongly oppose hb10 this bill
endangers lgbtq plus youth as it would
dissolve safe and affirming spaces in
schools and open them up to abuse
rates of depression and suicide among
trans youth drop dramatically when they
are supported by their family schools
and communities unfortunately not all
families are supportive a fact that the
sponsors of this bill would rather not
think about
this bill eliminates a child's autonomy
in favor of the absolute Authority of a
parent
I would ask those who support this bill
why the rights of a parent trumps the
rights of a child
the sponsors of this bill claim that the
this bill does not permit parents to
abuse their children and while that is
true
it severely limits the ability for
educators and medical professionals
to prevent abuse
this bill is nothing but cultural War
nonsense masquerading is parental rights
and is intended to force lgbtq Plus
children back into the closet thank you
thank you for your testimony Merrick
Finn followed by Maxine Mosley
do I have a Merrick Finn
do I have a Maxine Mosley
do I have a merry cousins
uh one Mary cousins please
with a Maggie O'Neill in the on Deck
Circle do we have a Maggie O'Neill we
have a Maggie O'Neill's hand I real
Maxine that is Maxine Mosley it is wow
okay I'll take that card back I'll swap
you for a Maxine mostly thank you
it's like baseball cards
good afternoon thank you for the
opportunity to testify I actually wrote
a testament testimony and then I changed
it nine thousand times I'm going to go
back and stick with the original not to
confuse everyone
my name is Maxine Mosley I am a retired
school counselor from Manchester in 43
years in my career I served thousands of
young people from kindergarten to high
school
on the middle school and high school
levels I was very often one of the few
sounding boards and support systems for
glbtq youth it was never my job to tell
them what to think or to tell them who
they were but to listen and encourage
them when they were ready to share their
identity with whomever they felt safe
sharing that information with including
their families
it was and never is my role to out
anyone to their parents or guardians or
families
and in many cases and you've heard this
term already I was one of the trusted
adults let me share a story that just
happened two weeks ago I met a 19 year
old young person who's now living at a
friend's house a friend of mine
this youth was kicked out of their
parents house because they came out as
trans when I met them my first question
is what are your pronouns my friend who
is considerably older than me was
confused about why I would ask that
question I explained because I wanted to
communicate with this person
respectfully and how they wished to be
referred to and as the most amazing
thing happened and this has happened
throughout my professional career
this youth gave me a big smile a hug and
just started talking about their
struggles and their pain
they shared with me how they had thought
about joining the military
because they knew they would put be put
in a position to die
and I will add that they said and die so
my parents would think that I would I
could be honored
their parents wanted them to be fixed
changed and to make an active decision
not to be a trans person I am still
evolving and learning at almost 68 years
old
but my heart knows how wrong this is in
a world where compassion and connection
is everything this young person was
considering Ways to Die
because of the shame that was thrust
upon them for who they were and now
you're over time would you give us about
15 seconds more to wrap it up I will
thank you turning the page over didn't
count against it you can go now
um criminalizing Educators is what this
bill will do I've been an educator my
entire life we have continued to be
muzzled about how we care for children
this has nothing to do with the parental
rights about curriculum
assemblies guest speakers I'm all for
that but when you ask an educator to
respond to a parent about sexualized
questions about their children it's
wrong thank you so much for your
testimony the chair now recognizes
Maggie O'Neill with Katie Masters
in the on Deck Circle
it's high tech
thank you good morning my name is Maggie
O'Neill I drove about an hour from
Newmarket to be here so thank you for
hearing my testimony
um I want to express my opposition to
The Spill
um it concerns me for several reasons
one I'll go back to my eighth grade year
when I did not yet know that I was queer
but a teacher figured it out actually
before I did and informed me and luckily
they did not out me to my parents
because I grew up in a Catholic
household so it was a bit of a question
of when I could come out to my parents
safely I eventually did on my own terms
and we have a beautiful loving
relationship now but it was my choice
um and so for Trans students who are
experiencing
questions about their pronouns and
trying out new names
this is a real a real issue when I
eventually went to college I became a
teacher I've taught in schools I've
taught in after school programs and I've
had students come out to me and try out
new pronouns with me let me know hey I'm
going by the this name and please don't
tell my parents the reason they try this
out is because it's a safe space and
it's lower Stakes their most important
relationship is with their caretaker
their Guardian they want to make sure
that they can safely make this change in
a lower Stakes atmosphere and I respect
teenagers
autonomy nobody's going to be harmed by
trying out new pronouns and trying out a
new name so to include that kind of
information in a bill that's purporting
to protect children from all kinds of
dangers is quite frankly an insulting to
those in the trans Community I urge you
to oppose this legislation thank you
very much thank you and now the chair
recognizes Katie master with Bill Blum
on the on Deck Circle
no Katie Masters
Bill Blum
I'll give him a second shot and you you
are
Katie Masters you are Katie
sorry that's all right all right good
afternoon uh my name is Katie Masters
and I am a resident of Littleton I am
testing testifying today in opposition
of hb10 my opposition stems from the
language of the bill that allows parents
to call for restriction of access to
peer-reviewed data on gender and sexual
orientation
I grew up in Stewartstown where there
were nine kids in my class from a young
age I was ostracized by my classmates
for a myriad of reasons from being the
stereotypical nerd to being overweight
to not being interested in sports or
other recreational activities well I've
only realized as an adult is that I also
felt othered because I did not fit into
our society's gender Norms if given the
knowledge and opportunity I could have
come to terms with who I am at a younger
age and while I would not have found my
people in that group of nine kids I
could have found peace that people like
me exist and could be found Even in our
rural Northern Communities hb10 would
ensure that kids like me have no chance
of accessing information that could not
only show them a whole world beyond our
smaller isolated communities where they
don't fit in but it could save their
lives as someone who can be counted in
the statistics of lgbtq Youth who have
suffered from depression and suicide
attempts I strongly urge this committee
to oppose furthering this bill our
children deserve every opportunity to
grow into their full potential with
compassion understanding and the ability
to access information beyond their
family group which like my own may not
have been a safe may not be a safe space
to Foster that potential to say that
this is a protectionist bill is a lie as
it hides State interference in the
rights of our children for
self-discovery in favor of fear of
anything different and parading it as
rights for parents being different and
accepting that has Set Me Free and
brought me joy in ways that I have never
felt in the three decades of my life
leading up to the present I am better
for it and others like me would be as
well
thank you so much
Bill Blum and uh following is Merry
cousins
good afternoon everyone my name is Bill
Blum
I'm here to speak in opposition against
this legislation it's been identified
and
there was some last minute changes to it
I didn't have time to sit there and read
six pages of it so I apologize I'm
speaking against
something that was in the original bill
um that is no longer present uh this
bill is called the parental Bill of
Rights
um very similar legislation passed in
Florida also known as don't say gay
so I want to recognize that
as being what it is
the lgbtq plus Community is under attack
right now and I feel that this bill is a
direct attack to my community
as a parent
my child my oldest one who's 17 did in
fact change their name as well as a
pronoun at the school that I was unaware
of that had happened but guess what it
didn't change
anything at home
you're still my child
we talked about parental Bill of Rights
earlier about how we need to make sure
that the parents are in charge of the
situation this reminds me of colonial
times
kids not property they're not dogs
they're not your piece of land
they're actual human beings my job as a
parent is not to control them my job is
to provide a safe space for them to
thrive whatever they that may be it may
be my son my daughter my non-binary
individual don't care
um
things happen a lot that parents won't
understand and without safe spaces
I.E schools
our children won't have a safe place to
talk the
earlier a few minutes ago the gentleman
in front of me created his own safe
Space by having a pistol in his
waistband guess what I didn't really
care about that
this is New Hampshire where I'll have
our own rights
I also want to recognize that that brief
pause
was
a moment of silence
for the people who will take their life
if harmful legislation is passed like
this I may not know your name ever they
were a few successful in taking your
life but I will recognize that passing
this legislation will provide an outlet
for that to happen thank you for your
testimony
merry cousins followed by Haley Brown
thank you chairman
I'm a little nervous I've never done
this before
um my name is Mary and I'm from Loudon
New Hampshire
I'm a veteran I'm a parent a grandparent
I feel like we are on a very slippery
slope
China
children are governed by the government
through their school systems
we are the United States of America we
are Live Free or Die state
I believe everyone has an opportunity to
live their life the way that they choose
I don't feel
I am in support of the parental rights
because I do believe that every parent
has a right to raise their children as
they see fit and not somebody else and
what their ideas are
I believe that open communication is
successful
between teachers and parents and the
children
sometimes children are confused more
often than not and if you lie to the
parents or you conceal from the parents
how are they supposed to be part of the
solution of their children's upbringing
one other thing is that it's not really
just about
lgbtq whatever it's
um it could be a young girl who got
pregnant it could be someone who's gay
that
their parents are really okay with it if
they only knew but if it's held from
them they're not part of that nurturing
process
the bottom line that I believe is that I
don't believe I don't understand why
we're here talking about if we should
have parental rights over our children
but I believe that it's important that
we don't go down that slippery slope and
avoid or cut off parental rights for our
children so I am in support of it and
thank you you did great for your first
time thank you is there any questions
thank you so much Haley Brown
followed by Michael
gulielmo the Italian guy next to me is
monitoring my pronunciation
hello my name is Haley and I'm here
today in opposition of hb10
I believe from my own experience this
bill puts New Hampshire Children at Risk
apart we must believe our children who
report abuse no child lives in fear of
their parents for no reason I grew up in
a violent religious household
when a close relative was outed when I
was eight years old I learned that I
could not safely come out while living
at home no Outsider could have
adequately assessed this risk like many
abuses abusers my parents coached us on
how to lie to Child Protective Services
I needed adults to believe me about the
abuse I experienced in spite of my
parents carefully curated good
reputation
no child is too young to disclose abuse
we would not deny a child protection
when they disclose any other reason to
fear their parents abuse most parents
are good and loving but my faith as a
Christian teaches me that the shepherd
leaves the 99 to save the one queer
children are the one even one child
dying or being abused as a result of
this bill is a disgrace to us all even
if there are repercussions for abuse
even the spill if this bill does not
condone that abuse it will trigger it it
will cause it and we need to ask
ourselves how we can be preventing that
proactively children are not closeted
for no reason parents need to Bear the
responsibility to be safe and
trustworthy you are responsible for your
relationship with your child coercing
teachers to break this trust will not
improve your relationship you cannot
coerce your child if he feels safe with
you my parents homeschooled me and I
lived under the total ideological
authoritarianism that is being glorified
in this bill it did not make me straight
it facilitated my abuse if homophobic
parents choose to exercise the right to
know they will also be exercising the
right to ruin their relationship with
their children by violating their
children's trust in them this won't
legalize abuse but it will result in it
it will undermine children disclosing
abuse it will undermine good parents
relationship and trustworthiness to
their children I do not have a single
safe adult my childhood talking to a
safe adult might have prevented years of
Shame suffering and suicidal ideation
your overtime you know have 15 seconds
to wrap it up please teachers are a
Haven for at-risk and abused children
and we need to be empowering them and
making them be trustworthy to their
students so that students who are
experiencing violence will go to them
thank you
now let's see we call upon Michael
gullielmo and remove your hats sir
that's inappropriate here
I am telling you to remove your hat
really yes sir I am doing that
my name is Michael gugliamo
Google me
I am here in support of this bill and
anybody that opposes this bill doesn't
have a right to be a parent as taxpayers
the school district has one duty and
that is to protect the best interest of
a child your duty as an educator is to
teach the truth not lies facts not
fiction and biology not a social agenda
that propagates non-gender
I'm going to stand here as Julia sees
right now I'm Julius Caesar and I'm a
female you believe that if you believe
that you're crazy okay
non-binary philosophy ideology is not to
be taught in schools we don't teach
ideology in schools we teach facts we
teach
the truth
and if you oppose this bill you have no
right to be a parent
that's all I got to say should I put my
hat back on now
it would be I'm courteous not to I'm
done because of the wedding I am on the
record all right
I recognizes Katie burns with Kim
Paisley of to follow
thank you chairman and committee members
I'm here I'm Katie Burns I'm here
testifying on behalf of new Futures new
Futures is a nonpartisan non-profit
organization that Advocates educates and
collaborates to improve health and
wellness of all Granite Staters new
Futures opposes House Bill 10 because it
prevents students from establishing
supportive networks outside of their
families which has been shown to
mitigate
the factors of adverse childhood
experiences are better known as Aces the
students who are most vulnerable to the
dangerous implications of this bill are
students exposed to these Aces and
particularly students who are living in
homes where parents are struggling with
with substance abuse mental illness
domestic violence and a messy divorce
these Aces oftentimes accumulate and
lead to negative mental physical and
behavioral health health outcomes the
accumulation of Aces can reduce a
child's future lifespan by up to 20
years making these toxic home
environments a major public health
concern
in Manchester alone over a thousand
children were mentioned in police
reports last year for these students
schools are their only safe space to
have a safe trusted adult
it's important that these students feel
safe in Sharing sensitive and personal
information and when a child is able to
share their challenges with a trusted
adult in these schools the risk of
dangerous consequences as a result of
their aces are reduced communities
across New Hampshire have invested in
building collaborative Partnerships to
address Aces including many police
departments from all over the state who
have dedicated efforts to collaborate
with schools and mental health agencies
to reduce barriers for children
accessing therapeutic supports offered
by licensed mental health clinicians
this bill will counteract efforts by
discouraging students from accessing
in-school supports especially if these
students are fearful of apparent
exercising newly granted rights to
breach their confidential therapeutic
relationships and Records
if passed this bill will reinstate
barriers that our First Responders
Educators and health professionals have
worked so hard to break down if you
would like to see New Hampshire continue
to be recognized as a national innovator
in programs addressing Aces and
advancing children's positive Health
outcomes then you will oppose the spell
for this reasons for these reasons I've
shared new Futures strongly urges the
committee to vote itl on House Bill 10.
thank you so much for your testimony the
chair recognizes now above you or Kim no
you were um Katie now Kim that's right
and then after that is Bob Keating
I first want to say thank you it's been
a very long day an awful lot of bills
today that we've been active in and um
appreciate your time when we don't run
the clock when you're thanking us oh
good I could go on I'm just kidding yeah
we there may be a moment when we may
come back to you but uh you're now on uh
I'm a professional and I live and work
in Concord and I'm a parent of a
transgender son I'm testifying in
opposition to hb10 and SB 272 and the
other anti-trans bills today
I would be remiss if I didn't note the
lack of decorum that I feel in
presenting a six-page Amendment right
before testimony began and also not in
Red Line it made it incredibly difficult
I'm an attorney and it made it very
difficult for me to assess what was been
changed and I find that interesting at
best
these bills are aimed at suppressing
fundamental rights and interfering with
the students autonomy and matters that
are deeply personal and best known to
the individual student these bills
require parents to be completely and
truthfully informed if a student is
being identified as a different name
gender or pronouns then they were
enrolled as these bills also require
that parents be informed as to any
extratricular correct activities clubs
or organizations their students
participate again this begs the question
why would a parent with a healthy
relationship with their child be unable
to have these conversations directly
why are we being led to believe that
there's a need for the step to the state
to step in it seems clear that the
children being targeted by these bills
are likely living in a home that's not
safe
and the state has no business in
advancing any agenda that puts these
children at a higher risk
these bills overreach by requiring
school districts to provide an opt-out
for certain instruction about sexuality
these bills establish a path toward
discipline for any School employee and
encourages our courses or attempts to
encourage our course A minor child to
withhold information from their parent
and contain a requirement that school
districts develop procedures for a
parent to learn about the nature and
purpose of clubs and activities offered
to his or her minor child's School
including those that are extracurricular
I have heard several times today that
some don't understand why we're even
here
I would note that that's a privilege
you are at two minutes and give us 15
seconds more please I'll wrap it up as a
parent of a transgender son it's bills
like these that encourage daily
systematic attacks on his very existence
and they put him in danger as a
legislator voting in favor of these
bills you are in fact culpable
according to every Major Medical
Association in the U.S the presence of
gender affirming care is a is a strong
predictor lack of it is a strong
predictor of suicide risk
um
thank you counselor I appreciate your
testimony we now uh call upon Bob
Keating with uh Hayden Smith
in the on Deck Circle
hit the button in the front
all right my name is Bob Keating and I
want to thank the committee for the
opportunity to speak uh I am a retired
uh marriage and family therapist of over
50 years I spent 40 years working as a
clinical supervisor in residential uh
care with many children uh coming there
as a result of abuse and neglect and
significant mental health issues I I
have and I'm just looking at the faces I
I think likewise have been strongly
affected by the voices of of Emma and
Paige and Derek who spoke about their
direct experience about this I'm also a
parent a grandparent and a great
grandparent and in my in my profession
we spoke about this very briefly is
about confidentiality confidentiality is
a central tenet of our culture saying
that there needs to be places that
people can share their stories uh one of
the sponsors of the bill talked about
things that they never said to their to
their parents almost all of us who have
been parents know that we are fortunate
that other people have been there to
listen to our parents not about problems
with uh the parenting but the simple
fact to be able to have somebody else to
be able to share and work it through so
that's why we have confidentiality laws
and they're very specific
um about what are their protections and
what what has to be disclosed and
generally that's around the framework
which what that which is dangerous to
the person or dangerous outside so we
have that already uh built in we we have
stories here that have been showed about
things that went uh wrong and uh about
uh allegedly when uh
professionals don't share their stories
but we also know the stories about when
things went wrong in the other ways I
have direct experience at one of my
colleagues was involved with a family
and the the family particularly the
father was so opposed by the
intervention quote by the state uh so
you're over if you could give his 15
second wrap-up
foreign
excuse me thank you
um that
this bill
um and I'm opposed to it is that I'm
fear unintentionally what it does is it
makes more kids at risk 40 percent uh
Improvement rate when trans kids have
somebody to talk to
thank you now so much and the chair
calls on Hayden Smiths followed by
representative Potenza
uh good afternoon members of the
committee my name is Hayden Smith and
I'm from Hanover and I'm here
representing New Hampshire youth
movement to testify in opposition to
hb10 our movement includes many New
Hampshire High School students who would
be affected by this legislation but are
not able to be here today to speak on it
due to school so I'd like to speak a bit
on their behalf on why this bill is
unnecessary and even harmful
our students have told us time and again
that they want what they want out of
school is a stimulating education that
will prepare them to navigate and thrive
in the complicated worlds they'll be
living in as adults this includes
engaging with topics that may be
uncomfortable to their parents but still
necessary to make informed decisions
about their health and livelihood I
remember learning about HIV AIDS in
fifth grade and while the topic may have
produced some awkward conversations with
my parents it proved to be Vital
Information for safeguarding my health
unfortunately this Bill runs counter to
what our students want by encouraging
students to unilaterally cut their their
children off from learning about issues
in school that they're not comfortable
with now parental discomfort with
certain topics in their children's
education is understandable but there
are more constructive and less
confrontational ways of approaching the
situation than what this bill prescribes
I think this bill is also an example of
why we need to be over why we need to be
cautious about over legislating HP 10
includes many statements about what
parents can and can't do that are
already widely recognized
and they're accepted by the public and
by local law but it mixes them with
provisions and enforcement mechanisms
that are unnecessary and could carry
harmful consequences most if not all
school districts in the state for
example already have a process through
which a parent can inquire about their
child schooling and even request that
their student not have access to certain
materials but this bill creates its own
rather vague definition
of what these processes must look like
along with harsh penalties for School
Employees found in violation while some
school districts could foreseeably
benefit from improving these processes
the solution should be made at the local
level and not through a vague top-down
mandate in the state legislature about
what this process would include
especially when such a mandate carries
heavy punishments for those found in
violation
we need muscles okay you're in wrap up
territory you've got about 15 seconds
okay we must be careful to treat our
state's young students as people with
their own agency and needs not as pawns
and some made up conflict between
parents and the world ultimately our
movements members see this bill as
unnecessary as an unnecessary piece of
legislation that would create animosity
between parents and Educators where none
need exists all while disregarding the
needs of the very people in the
Hampshire's educational system must
serve thank you very much and now we
call Representative Potenza with Sean
McDonough in the on Deck Circle
thank you chair my name is
representative Kelly batenza of
Stratford District 19.
Rochester Wards one two three four and
six
the framework of opposition in this bill
is all based upon the premise of abusive
parents and where is the due process
that's what's missing in all of this
opposition testimony
and I want to be clear about previous
testimony here these are not new granted
rights and I assume that the committee
is going to do their homework and I'll
make sure to send this testimony in as
well
there's a long history which shows these
rights that we already naturally have as
parents
so going back to 1923 it is the natural
duty of the parent to give his children
education suitable to their station in
life the fundamental theory of Liberty
upon which all governments in this Union
Repose excludes any general power of the
state to standardize its children by
forcing them to accept instruction from
public teachers only the child is not
the mere creature of the state those who
nurture him and direct his Destiny have
the right coupled with the high duty to
recognize and prepare him for additional
obligations that was pierce versus
versus society sisters that was another
these are all U.S Supreme Court cases
going back from 1923 all the way up into
1997.
I do want to say
um that I I do agree with there's been a
couple testimony about that amendment
being delivered at the last minute I
don't like that either I don't think
that that's transparent
I support HB
um
hb10fn as introduced I do not support
the amendment everything in here spells
out the rights that we already have as
parents to ask questions and I just want
to say that
um I could give lots of EX lots of
examples but I won't because there's no
time you've got 10 seconds to wrap it up
okay
um but these uh these these rights are
are parents that want to be involved and
they've probably had a roadblock that's
happened to them so spelling out the
right of getting information not about
sexual
thank you very much the chair recognizes
Sean McDonald
McDonough with Frank Knack on the on
Deck Circle
and I gotta go back to
potentially wristwatch oops that's
cockies there it is
my name is Sean McDonough I'm a student
attorney from the Harvard Law School
lgbtq advocacy Clinic here representing
Seacoast outright
I am deeply concerned about the ways
this bill would Target and harm lgbtq
students by restricting instruction on
objectionable material HP 10 would
intimidate teachers out of discussing
lgbtq people
and lgbtq issues it's invitation for
scrutiny of instructional materials
would only exacerbate the risk of
discriminatory enforcement against lgbtq
topics
further with Provisions designed to
force teachers to interfere in
transgender students families hb10 would
risk causing tremendous harm to
vulnerable youth
the moment of coming out to one's
parents can have significant effects on
a Young Person's mental health positive
or negative depending on how it goes
with the stakes so high it's important
to empower schools to help youth prepare
and come out when they're ready
the last thing anyone needs is
inflexible State mandated interference
with that sensitive moment
because of the frequent risk of harm
from bills like this I worry that
sometimes we lose sight of the important
fact that lgbtq youth can Thrive when
treated with dignity and respect
coming out as LGBT in an affirming home
can increase feelings of safety and
confidence
lgbtq students who feel supported by
School staff get better grades are more
likely to come to school and graduate
and have a greater sense of belonging in
their school communities and when
transgender students receive the care
they need they can succeed and Thrive at
the same rates as their non-transgender
peers
this legislature took an important step
toward protecting lgbtq youth in 2019
with school non-discrimination law
please reject today's attempt to reverse
course and Target these vulnerable youth
thank you so much
chair recognizes now Frank knack
with Aaron George Kelly up next
Mr chairman of the committee thank you
so much for the opportunity to testify
today my name is Frank kinack I'm the
policy director with the ACLU of New
Hampshire I apologize I don't have
written testimony because of the
amendment so we'll be submitting that
once we can take a closer look at the
language so I'll keep my comments um
somewhat high level
um so from hearing the the amendment
outlined by the uh sponsor it sounds
like now we're much closer to the Senate
version of this bill uh which we have
serious problems with uh many of the
kind of railroad concerns and how this
is really going to harm uh lgbtq
especially trans youth um in New
Hampshire have already been articulated
um quite strongly by others
um I'll focus on a few things that have
not been lifted up so far
and you know because of the the
amendment to the new language around uh
really trying to focus on lgbtq youth in
particularly trans youth in particular
we're really creating a special tier of
surveillance in schools for Trans youth
uh which violates privacy rights and
also sets um New Hampshire up for
potential violations of
of federal law and so to give an example
U.S department of education's office of
civil rights issued a notice of
interpretation explaining how it would
enforce Title IX prohibition on
discrimination on the basis of sex to
include
discrimination based on sexual
orientation and discrimination based on
gender identity and so when you're
looking at the new language of the
amendments
um uh as written transgender youth are
subjected to a distinct level of
surveillance in schools and we think
that is a serious concern that you all
should be looking into more seriously
and I just want to flag one other issue
that hasn't been lifted up uh is that
New Hampshire Department of Education is
currently invested pretty pretty heavily
in the one trusted adult program and
this bill would really undermine that
work you know that program is really
about ensuring that students know that
they have a trusted person at the school
who they can confide in and what this
bill would do would be to gut that
program so we hope that you all will
consider italying this bill and have to
answer any questions
saying none thank you so much chair
recognizes Aaron George Kelly with Betsy
Harrington up next
good afternoon chairman and committee
members thank you for the opportunity to
speak to you today my name is Aaron
George Kelly and I'm the director of
homeless Youth and Young Adult Services
for Waypoint I have come to express
waypoint's opposition of house bill 10.
I've worked with youth and families in
New Hampshire for over 20 years and in
homeless Youth and Young Adult Services
in our state for over 15 years I have
seen firsthand that Educators and School
staff members are often the safest
adults in a young person's life
especially youth who identify as lgbtq
this legislation targets these exact
people Educators and lgbtq Youth parents
rights may seem like common sense but
when you look behind the curtain these
terms are used to strip teenagers of
their basic rights to education physical
safety and freedom this bill unfairly
stigmatizes lgbtq students because their
Journey will be policed and reported
back to their parents teenagers are at a
crucial stage of development and
beginning to establish some independence
from their parents and figuring out who
they are all students deserve to feel
safe in school they should be able to
trust staff members to support them and
not surveil them
this does not mean hiding information
from parents this means the
appropriately trained School staff
allowing youth to be experts in their
own lives and share with parents when
they are ready and able to do so safely
the Trevor projects 2022 National survey
on lgbtq Mental Health in New Hampshire
states that 39 of lgbtq in our state
have considered suicide and 10 percent
of them have made at least one attempt
in the last year
forcing lgbtq youth to be outed is not
just harmful it could lead to increased
suicide attempts and death
this same survey tells us that 44
percent of New Hampshire's lgbtq youth
identify home as not being an lgbtq
affirming space
got about 15 seconds to wrap it up you
may assume that establishing a parent's
right Bill of Rights means connecting
loving caring and supportive parents
with what is occurring in children's
educational setting that is not the
reality and we know that firsthand at
Waypoint because 25 of the Youth and
Young adults that walk through the doors
of our homeless Youth and Young Adult
Services are lgbtq young people thank
you for your testimony you have come to
the end of your time and Betsy
Harrington is up next with Jama Wilder
to follow
thank you for the opportunity to speak
today my name is Betsy Harrington from
Deering
I worked as a dcyf investigator and as a
state at the state prison as a sex
offender counselor in my work I have
never had to remove a child from a
parent rejecting their gender or
sexuality I know it's happened but it's
very uncommon I have had Parents
struggle with the news of their kids
coming out but I have never had a parent
reject a child or beat a child for their
differences
abuse usually had to do with the parents
issues often drug or alcohol related I
have worked with sex offenders and I
know intimately of their plots to abuse
children
they found the loopholes they became
teachers Camp counselors and coaches
they found a way to get close to
children and to be trusted predators are
surrounding our children and parents are
the ultimate protectors to their
children teachers can be a wonderful
resource to our kids but they are 180
day resource maybe as much as four years
but they ultimately abandoned their
students
parents are forever and we house our
children not the school staff if you
support secrets and special
relationships it damages the child
parent relationship you cut off this
child from the only people responsible
for caring for them until adulthood if
you allow secrets you will have good
parents removing our highest testing
students for a safer educational
environment I am at that door
I'm ready to go I see the dangers and
I'm not sure I can allow my kids to be
put at risk anymore our public schools
are Distributing exploitive porn through
our libraries and hiding secrets from
parents why would any decent parents
sign their kids up for that I'm ready to
leave we will all soon be paying taxes
to say State sanctioned abuse I pay a
thousand dollars a month to property
taxes I'd like that to cover a safe
education for my kids otherwise why
would I want to pay such high taxes for
something that's too dangerous to use if
I ask my son's teacher a question about
my son I expect the truth or I won't
trust that teacher with my kids 15
seconds no more secrets support house
built in thank you so much
chair recognizes Jama Wilder with Lynn's
Jacobs next
it's you thank you
good afternoon my name is Jama Wilder
and I'm the parent of five children
Aging in or arranging in ages from 4 to
18 years old
over a year ago I was denied my request
for a public hearing for my District
School Board I wanted the opportunity to
share with parents the things that were
going on in our district
my children's curriculum was riddled
with inappropriate sexual content many
subjects were presented with divisive
Concepts that left my children confused
and questioning why the information was
being presented
I have the opportunity to speak to my
children on multiple occasions and they
came to me and they told me it was there
the school district said that it was
posted on their Google classrooms but
the teachers weren't uploading it so
what they said was transparency never
existed at all and I know from my
children telling me
I grew up in Hollis and went through
preschool through graduation of the high
school there and it is a very different
place today since I moved back to town
there have been two suicides in our
district the most recent suicide took
place one week after the school
illegally gave the children the youth
risk assessment survey they never gave
us the option to opt out and when the
state gave them a slap on the wrist
because they had broken the law they
simply said that they were destroying
the surveys they never gave it to the
parents or showed them what those
questions were asking their children
the school is incorporating toxic ideas
they present as helpful through their
social emotional learning programs the
mental health of these children is
plummeting and instead of pausing and
looking at what harm they're doing to
continue to make it harder and harder
for parents to be involved if they don't
agree with this the last day that my
children attended Public School my
daughter was denied the right to present
a project because the teacher told her
it was argumentative it was a PowerPoint
presentation with six or seven slides 15
seconds to go she used a direct quote
and she gave what her interpretation was
from the first president of the teachers
union John Dewey since my daughter's
views did not align with the narrative
she was told she would have to redo the
project and only use biography.com for
her research they did not question the
direct quote but she was silenced many
times my my children expressed their
fears and inabilities to share their
thoughts for fear of persecution thank
you and that will end your testimony we
appreciate what you gave us for about
two minutes and 20 seconds next the
chair recognizes Lynn's Jack house with
Heather Mullins to follow
good afternoon my name is Lynn's Jake
house and you see them pronounced
three equality
I I would like to State for the record
that I also opposed a senate side
version of this bill and I oppose HB set
10. this bill would established a path
toward discipline for any School
employee who encourages or courses or
attempts to encourage your coerce a
minor child to withhold information from
his or her parent no educator should
ever coerce students period however many
conversations between a student and
trusted teacher or other School employee
might look like this the student says
I'm gay or I'm trans or I think I might
be bi the teacher says thank you for
telling me have you told your parents
the student says I don't feel safe doing
that I know my parents believe being gay
or trans is wrong or I'm not sure if I'm
ready for that conversation yet the
teacher says it's okay to not be sure or
it's okay to come out on your own
timeline that's how my conversation with
my favorite High School teacher went
when I knew it wasn't safe to come out
to my father who believes being lgbtq is
a sin I can easily see how many people
who fear Monger against trans people
would try to say that a teacher is
encouraging a student under those
circumstances even though it's a simple
neutral response that lets a student who
knows their family better than any
teacher think through their own coming
out timeline it is not clear how
encourage is defined or interpreted when
my father did find out I had feelings
for my best friend and that we would
kiss sometimes by hacking into my
personal internet accounts he told me
homosexuality was disgusting and immoral
and not how I was raised took away my
phone and I thought I might be sent to
conversion therapy I was limited to
applying only to colleges that
specifically did not affirm lgbtq
students he Gaslight me by telling me I
wasn't queer just confused constantly
criticized and shamed me to the point of
only talking about me like my true self
was an entirely different person and
that I was only worthy of love if I
adhered exactly to his worldview and
telling me that I was so immoral that he
was concerned for the state of my soul
this never changed continuing into
adulthood these are also the reasons
that I gradually came out to a few close
friends and teachers at my high school
because I desperately needed the few
people I trusted too I've got 15 seconds
to finish up to wrap up I'm also
concerned about the line that requires
parental consent for Health Care
practitioners does this include
school-based Behavioral Health
Counselors if so that's cutting off
another Lifeline for lgbtq kids like my
younger self whose parents deny any need
for Health Care itl hb10 thank you so
much now the chair recognized
the Holly Stevens
afterwards
all right thank you guys for calling me
again when I had stepped out of the room
but I appreciate that um so my name is
Heather Mullins I have a 13 year old
daughter
um I'll tell you right now like I would
take a bullet for my child and I think
I'm probably one of the only people in
the in the room that would and so while
I hear her stories about parents having
abused their child like I guarantee you
the majority of parents are the biggest
Protectors of their children every
single one of you up there can probably
say that your children you would do
anything for and you can't give away my
rights as a parent without giving away
your own so if at some point in time
you're not sitting behind that bench and
you're a parent just like me and you
disagree with Allah or something that
gets passed you want that being pushed
on your children a lot of what I'm
hearing with this lgbtq stuff as being
like sort of the prerequisite to remove
parents rights is really like a
fundamental lifestyle choice right the
idea that a child is going to get abused
if they have let's say a Christian or
Catholic family because they disagree
with you know pronouns or things of that
nature it's just ludicrous right like
most parents even if they don't agree
with changing their child's pronoun
they'll be like you know what you want
to change your name you want to change
your pronouns when you're 18 you're not
under my roof do it they're not going to
beat their child for for having like
these peer groups at school and the
other thing that I want to point out is
that there's actually a group called
gaze against groomers and there's ones
called the changed movement which are
lgbtq former lgbtq that that have gone
through transitions including a
gentleman behind me who is is living
proof that some of these ideologies
they're pushing on kids whose brains
haven't fully developed have lifelong
irreversible consequences that are
life-threatening and so I appreciate
everyone caring about children but
there's two sides of this equation and
two sides of this conversation but on a
national media standpoint only one
narrative is being allowed to get talked
about and it's actually within the lgbtq
community it's frowned upon to
de-transition or to say you know what
I'm more suicidal post-operate Nation we
really need to say the kids genuinely
suffering from gender dysphoria when
they are 18 and older if they want to
make that decision that is on them but
to take our children and use this lgbtq
stuff as an excuse to remove parents
from having a seat at the table for
what's best for their kids to me it's
just it's horrifying as a mom thank
thank you so much we left you go a
couple of well about 15 seconds over
thank you so much for your testimony
next we call Holly Stevens from Nami and
um after that Brian blaketon blackton
excuse me
good afternoon chairman Pearson members
of the committee my name is Holly
Stevens and I'm the director of public
policy at Nami New Hampshire
now I mean New Hampshire is a non-profit
Grassroots organization whose mission is
to improve the lives of all people
impacted by mental illness and suicide
we are here today in opposition to house
bill 10. I did notice as I think some
folks had mentioned the date on the
amendment is March 1st and being in a
small non-profit with limited resources
it would have been really helpful if we
were able to have we would have liked to
have had it too there was some glitches
not of our doing can you take that off
my time
give the lady an extra 30 seconds
but is it just going back to that it
would have been helpful to have it
before the start of the hearing today I
heard from uh
speaker
Sherman Packard mentioned that this this
has been in the works for a while
um also when he was bringing uh the bill
uh to the committee my written testimony
may not seem as relevant now as the bill
has changed I will send my written
testimony on Senate Bill 272 to the
committee since it seems similar to the
amendment but even though my original
written testimony may not seem relevant
to this amendment it is we are in the
middle of a Children's Mental Health
crisis and we need all hands on deck we
need to come together and neither the
original Bill nor the amendment will
accomplish this goal the bill and the
amendment Amendment destroy the trusted
adult relationship that students have
with school Personnel this relationship
is critical in suicide prevention one of
the biggest missions of Nami New
Hampshire
this relationship is critical as a this
excuse me this bill vilifies School
personnel which will further the
perceived divide between parents and
teachers it calls out trans youth in
particular which are extremely
vulnerable population of which 43
of in New Hampshire report being
negatively affected by politics 43 of
the trans youth Community report being
negatively affected by politics I'll
give you an extra 20 seconds to wrap it
up thank you one sentence left therefore
Nami New Hampshire urges the committee
to recommend this bill in expedient I
owe you 15 next time called me to it
thank you so much appreciate your work
and your testimony Brian blackton
pleased with Brian Hawkins next
thank you
foreign
very broken
I'm Brian blackton from Concord
I'm a supporter of this bill I'm a
conservative former police officer
federal firearms licensee Independent
Baptist who has a King James Bible on my
nightstand
that May Scare some people here today
because I remember when the Twin Towers
were hit I was teaching seventh grade
English class
some may assume I took the opportunity
to try to indoctrinate my students to my
beliefs that day but I only taught the
daily curriculum
I firmly believe parents are in charge
of their children's education not
indoctrinated to another person's
direction that was attempted to me thank
God not to today's levels but my
children's were exposed to it at today's
levels
I do not believe any school has the
power or right to not inform parents of
any aspect of their childhood education
health or try to indoctrinate their
moral gender or religious beliefs upon
them that is a parent's job and a
parent's right
by taking God out of school this is part
of the outcome I think the way to fix
this is to remove children from public
school
until the parents are heard if this bill
is not passed thank you thank you sir
and the chair
recognizes Brian Hawkins with Stephen
scare up Beyond
him
thank you
thank you Mr chairman for the record
Brian Hawkins uh representing Nea New
Hampshire today we represent more than
17 000 Educators across the state
including many of the local education
associations uh for many that are in
many of your districts
um and I am here to testify in
opposition to hospital 10 today and I
will try to hit just the points that I I
tried to see were the similarities
between the original bill and the
amendment and also not to repeat a lot
of what has been said
we have several concerns with this piece
of legislation first and foremost
included including the the stated
penalties of the bill this is similar to
our opposition of the bill last year uh
which will actually take at least some
of those were taken out when it made
over to to the Senate uh
um the some of the overbroad language
that are tied to those violations
as well as the numerous areas that um
or at least duplicative or con or
confusing uh so first with the penalties
um the bill states that
um any person who violates any provision
of this chapter shall be guilty of a
Class A misdemeanor violations of a bill
such as this result resulting in
criminal penalties are unacceptable I
think especially as was
noted earlier we were in an educator
shortage we are desperately trying to
find teachers paraprofessionals other
staff who work in the school and so what
kind of message does it send when the
legislature is passing bills such as
this that criminal I think was referred
to earlier criminalizing education
um
so I don't see any point to that other
than to create a climate of fear and
intimidation among employees in the
school
one of the other paragraphs related to
violations also uh seemed confusing I
think was originally paragraph three you
now have 15 seconds right okay uh where
it refers to a certified educator being
found guilty of violating any section of
this law I shall have their teaching
credentials suspended
uh confusing on how this would work
because uh does this mean that they are
found guilty by the school district by
the doe
um the sentences mixes uh credentialing
and their employment which are handled
by different entities so if you're a
credentialed educator that means you're
uh you have a license uh that okay
you've gone way over and thank you for
your testimony
yes please uh the chair recognizes
Stephen scare with Cassandra Sanchez on
Deck
microphone please sir
good afternoon I'm Steven scare of
Nashua and I'm here to speak in favor of
this bill because parents need to
protect their children from the belief
systems that have become the established
religions in public schools
transgenderism teaches that children
that they're born with gendered souls or
gender identities and these not their
bodies are their authentic selves those
who claim that it isn't an ideology cite
its recognitions by Professional Medical
associations but it's a mistake to thank
these professionals are less vulnerable
to Dogma than anyone else
for example Jeremy Coswell the director
of gender services at Boston children
said a child will know they are
transgender from the moment they have an
ability to express themselves we have
parents that tell us their children knew
from the minute they were born
practically signs a toddler is trans
include refusing to get a haircut trying
to stand to urinate refusing to stand to
urinate crying on a siblings clothing
playing with quote the opposite gender
toys there's nothing scientific and
claiming that a newborn with no concept
of sex or gender has an immutable
identity which is expressed through
gender stereotypes even though these
stereotypes vary among cultures and eras
these these ideas can only be understood
in a religious context and the religion
doesn't belong in public schools
excluding cases of abuse when children
are young they understand that when
children When someone tells them to keep
secrets from their moms and dads they're
up to no good when they enter
adolescence they push back against the
parents activists are using the school
to drive a wedge between their parents
and children during this vulnerable
stage regarding the suicide stats you've
heard they come from online solicited
surveys on LGBT sites we know that the
real rate is less than a tenth of a
percent and autism and anorexia have
higher suicide rates thank you thank you
sir
chair recognizes Cassandra Sanchez with
Lily Tang Williams to follow
good afternoon Mr chairman and committee
members thank you for your time for the
record Cassandra Sanchez child advocate
for the State of New Hampshire
I much like others had prepared
testimony for the bill is introduced so
I will share that written testimony with
you today and I will follow up with an
email with additional testimony that
further covers some of the additions in
the in the amendment
um so as many of you know the office of
the child advocate is an independent
impartial state agency that is tasked
through statute to ensure protections
for all and I say all very clearly not
some all New Hampshire children and that
includes our lgbtq plus community and
that includes all children that could be
affected by this bill because there are
others that have not been discussed
before us today that could absolutely be
impacted by this bill I spend much time
meeting with children in the community
and I also want to clarify for some that
there has been misinformation shared
here today
there are absolutely children who are
abused when they disclose
their gender identity to their families
my office reviews these on a daily basis
we also spend a lot of time meeting with
these children much of most of which end
up in residential facilities many ending
up out of the state of New Hampshire
with minimal oversight and minimal
trusted adults to check in on them
these children matter and we need to
protect these children I have respect
for parental rights but they should not
come before the safety of our children
I also believe that this bill leaves
room for interference in law enforcement
and dcyf investigations
the as many had come before and
mentioned trusted adults are very
important for disclosures for children
by severing that or um
or the liability over the heads of those
trusted adults and concerns for them to
be able to protect those children and
report we understand that children are
at risk of not disclosing abuse in the
home including as far as sexual abuse
that can be occurring that they will not
be disclosing that abuse and therefore
it will not either get to law
enforcement or if shared with law
enforcement and the school is then
tasked with sharing with a parent it
could interfere with the law enforcement
in this regard
um so lastly as I had mentioned I meet
with these children in residential
facilities and what I hear from these
children the voice I want you to hear
today from my office is that these
children want to have adults that care
for them they want to be in safe
environments but they unfortunately
understand that that is not always going
to happen
thank you so much for your testimony the
chair now recognizes Lily Tang Williams
with Allison Jaeger to follow
and uh Lily Tang Williams is here I was
asked if
I was asked if I ever met you to say hi
from Peter Boyles to you
I was on his radio show for 20 minutes
every other week for two and a half
years and he says to say hi so anyway hi
yep
it's like radio
you got to have the button on yeah and
it makes it red is that better much
better
thank you chairman and thank you you
call me the members my name is Lily Tang
Williams I am a Chinese immigrant
American citizen by choice I am here as
a mother of three and to support
strongly support parental rights Bill HP
10 grow up in China during miles regime
I never heard of concept of parental
rights and everything child in China
even today belong to the government
and I remember when I was growing up I'm
totally subject to the whims of Central
plannings and the centralized education
and the first induct relation I was a
young Pioneer Red Guard and throughout
my school years and the CCB is still
controlling all education I was
forbidden to see my own student file
think about I'm gonna I brought my
picture of my Middle School Portraits
here okay you want to see
every year as a student in schools I
have to take a portrait to put into my
secret student file and my parents were
not allowed to see it and I was never
allowed to see it you know why because
it's only belongs to this state the the
government and the future employers can
see it but not my parents
I came to America
1988 thinking freedom and individual
rights I got involvement in education
because my kids were going to Public
Schools 20 years ago what a concern me
is what I see today in America kind of
remind me what my personal experience in
China under a Communist Regime the fact
I have to come here to defend parental
rights it's a very very
and concerning I think this bill right
now is absolutely necessary in today's
political climate and it clarifies and
protects one of the most ancient natural
rights of human beings parental
sovereignty 15 seconds to go the deepest
human pound is between parents and their
children if you're opposed to this bill
I wonder what has American become and
also today
you see this National
things going on all over the country I
feel like we have a more opposition
today than supporting parental rights
thank you thank you Miss Williams we
appreciate your testimony you've gone
well over and now the chair recognizes
Allison Yeager with Anne-Marie Banfield
next
uh you may go
um my name is Allison Yeager and I have
been transitioning for two years
I have been transitioning for two years
and I had spent
eight years prior to this year in the
closet
one of those years I had spent being a
jerk to everybody I knew because of how
much I thought that they would never
accept me
so
I've been doing my best to make amends
now that I'm able to be happy
what's up
um
thank you for your time and that is all
thank you for your testimony
and the chair now recognizes Anne-Marie
Benfield with Chris urchil up next
thank you
honorable members and of the children
and family law committee my name is
Anne-Marie Banfield I'm a parental
rights Advocate New Hampshire primarily
focused on academic excellence in
education which is why I'm normally in
front of the education committee I do
urge you to vote ought to pass on hb10
I'm just going to Briefly summarize what
I'm saying or whatever it's going to say
is I will highlight some of the more
glaring problems that pit parents
against schools this can also drive a
division between parent and child
School administrators are not following
federal law and ethical codes of conduct
by assessing and treating mental health
of students with when they are treating
mental the mental health of students
without informed consent by parents
children attending some of our public
schools have had their Mental Health
Data shared with outside organizations
like Plymouth State Antioch University
and Keene State this is a violation of
the school counselor's code of ethics
school counselors are to maintain
privacy
on those records but that is not
happening in our Public Schools parents
have been shocked to hear the sensitive
data is leaving the district without any
informed consent
I'm happy to expand on that if you would
like
so who's being targeted right now School
Board policy jbab if you're not familiar
with it was developed by the New
Hampshire school boards Association the
policy included a provision that told
staff that they must slide appearance
now so under the privacy policy J
Babbitt reads School Personnel shall not
disclose information that may reveal a
student's transgender status or gender
non-conforming presentation to others
including parents so parents are
actually the ones that have been
targeted in these schools the New
Hampshire school boards Administration
did finally withdraw their support for
jbab after a lawsuit was filed in
Manchester this case is being taken to
the Supreme Court and it's currently
pending there this parent was never
given due process which is a lot of what
I'm hearing today a lot of guilty
parents with absolutely no talk about
due process to them
um
we now have policies in place that
require School Personnel to to lie to
loving parents this child was
transferred out of the Manchester
schools and now going to a charter
school
statements from those against parental
rights paint parents as abusive or
neglectful with no due process even
cases of sexual abuse that abuse that
happened in by school personnel and
teachers go through due process first we
don't paint all teachers as possible
child molesters anti-parent policies
Drive families away from their Public
Schools so when this when this is
happening what's happening what I'm
seeing is parents are pulling their kids
out of the public school you've got 10
seconds to wrap it up okay
um I do want to mention that the FERPA
law does require that or this allow for
parents to review their their child's
records so that's already in law so I'm
not sure how we're going to how there's
policy in place that says that you can
lie to a parent
um jbab clearly violates FERPA thank you
for your testimony appreciate it Chris
urchil and um uh Karen Hill as I can
read it here is next
thank you
thank you chair Pearson thank you
members of the committee it's been a
long day bear with me
um my name is Chris Churchill I'm an
attorney with glbtq legal Advocates and
Defenders better known as glad I am here
to talk exclusively about page four
lines four through nine subsections WX
and Y other people have done a great job
testifying about other aspects of the
bill but I'm here to talk speak in
opposition to those specific Provisions
um teachers at Public Schools come into
contact with information about students
identity development in countless ways
that might include
um for instance say a Muslim student who
decides she doesn't want to where he her
hijab in class anymore is it a teacher's
obligation to disclose that information
to a parent maybe it is maybe it isn't
maybe the circumstances uh are dependent
what this bill does which is uh which is
unusual and untenable is it singles out
one characteristic of student an
identity and that's a student's gender
identity and says that's subject to a
different standard for for teachers this
bill could easily uh say that that that
whenever information is requested by a
parent about any aspect of a student's
development at school that the teacher
or School personnel must tell the truth
instead the bill doesn't do that it uh
it singles out transgender students
because of their gender identity and
that's it that's the only identity
aspect that's identified in here and
that's a huge problem that's
unconstitutional it singles out a group
of people for different treatment under
the law and that's not what the law does
and not in New Hampshire and not in the
United States I also want to flag that
subsection y uh which refers to the
right to know about what extracurricular
activities are clubs a student is
participating in is especially
problematic for students who are
questioning their identity and are
looking for a safe space to join a club
to talk to their peers in a safe space
and I know you've heard countless people
talk about this today but it cannot be
underestimated how critical that can be
for a child's safe and healthy
development it doesn't mean the kid's
not going to talk to their parents it
means the kid is having a moment where
they need to be able to go into a safe
place and that access to that place is
in those seconds okay access to that
place uh a kid is not going to feel
comfortable going in there if they know
that it's going to be broadcast to other
people even back home so in conclusion
schools work in partnership with parents
I think that's great I think it's bad
that this bill singles that transgender
people I got a question actually I have
to
um back to the hijab if a Muslim parent
asked a teacher
is your child wearing one
would you be comfortable with the
teacher giving the truth
this bill says nothing about it I'm not
asking that
if any question is asked about student
development I think the teacher should
on it I honestly I don't think teachers
should ever be giving misinformation to
parents or lying to parents
um about any aspect of a student's
development or a student's identity this
bill could could like you know address
that potentiality by by prohibiting it
but instead it singles out one aspect of
student identity and says that's subject
to a special a special version of
scrutiny that's what's untenable about I
know you brought us back to that just
now very well done by the way you're
welcome
um but you open the door because you
broadened it what about and you use that
example so I just wanted to see if the
teacher like so you're setting up a
hypothetical yes it is so setting up a
hypothetical that's an amendment parent
comes to comes to school personnel and
asks a question is my kid wearing her
hijab in class uh and if a teacher were
to say no I mean yes your kid is wearing
a hijab just like you expect and that's
not true that would be very unusual I've
never heard of a teacher blatantly lying
to a parent on upon an inquiry like that
but if that did happen I wouldn't be I
wouldn't be here opposing a law that
would prohibit that I'll just say that
okay and my other question is suppose
one of my grandchildren
um in spite of we could do everything
you can decides to join the Confederate
Army club and they go through battles
and they tweak them so their guys win
and everything that went behind that
and I thought some little strange things
were going on at the house and I said to
the teacher
did my kid join a Confederate Army Club
at school would you be comfortable with
the teacher saying yes he did
actually I think clubs are a special
case I think where where students want
to engage with ever who knows why the
kid is attending that club right teacher
doesn't know why uh the parents probably
have a better idea than anyone about why
and I think that's an excellent
opportunity for a teacher to say to that
parent uh
um I'm sorry excellent opportunity for
the teacher to say to that parent to
engage with that parent and say this is
a conversation you really need to be
having with your kid what support can we
give you as a school we have school
counselors School psychologists guidance
counselors and social workers
um what support can we give you to make
you able to have this conversation at
home with your kid
um about about the things that are
concerning you I think that there's a
that is a totally appropriate response
but I don't necessarily think that
joining a club especially a pride club
or a GSA I don't think that information
should be made available ever
thank you thank you any other questions
they want me to go to law school I'm
trying to resist
um thank you next up is uh city council
Karen Hill from Lebanon followed by
Merrick Finn is Merrick Finn here he
Merrick was called once before don't see
uh Kevin or Kerry
Coventry here
you
he's gone okay well anyway
we have councilor Hill great thank you
very much my name is Karen Leo Hill I'm
an 18-year Lebanon City councilor and
mother to two children one of whom is
here with me today and is also on your
list to testify
I'm 44. I was born in 1978 as a child
growing up in a small charismatic
Evangelical Church I remember that
homosexuality was a taboo topic
I remember when I was around 10 years
old the pastor of the church had
recently discovered that his teenage son
was gay and he rebuked his son in front
of the congregation and made him leave
the sanctuary
a couple years later my best friend's
older brother was outed to his parents
and they made him move out
most parents love their children and
want to have open and honest
communication and loving relationships
but unfortunately that is not always the
case for All Families as legislators you
are being asked to consider
those circumstances when people don't
have the safest home situation
that's what this legislation is about
unfortunately these stories that took
place 30 years ago are not relics of the
past some families today still cannot
accept their children
and will not allow them to freely
Express themselves at home and for some
children the only place they may be able
to express themselves freely is in
school
to me this bill is about safety and
health and what's in the best interest
of our children we know that teenagers
are facing a mental health crisis we
know that queer teenagers especially
trans youth are at the greatest risk of
harming themselves this legislation has
the potential to put many New Hampshire
youth in traumatic
and stressful situations like the ones
experienced by my pastor's Son by my
best friend's brother and even my own
uncle
we have a chance to make the world a
better place for today's kids at least
our beautiful independent Freedom loving
corner of the world in the interest of
the health and safety of Granite State
children please vote this itl thank you
counselor Stephen Lafond here or gone
Andrew McPherson
Janine babbert
I'm sorry gone Zoe Hill Zoe Hill
also from Lebanon do you know City
councilor hell
she and I go back it's gonna be five
minutes
good after I've been Representatives my
name is Zoe Hill I'm a 16 year old
Junior at Lebanon High School
I'm here today to oppose hb10
this bill will not directly affect me
because I am lucky enough to have
parents who support me and my identity
as a trans kid
but I know multiple people who could
face true harm if this bill passes
they are out in school but not
necessarily at home because their
families would not accept them if they
found out that they were trans
if this bill passes and their parents
did find out they are trans then their
homes would become an even more
dangerous place for them
in conclusion please oppose this bill
for the sake of trans kids all across
the state of New Hampshire thank you
and thank you for coming
Heather Mullins
Deborah house
Kendra Ford
hi Kendra Ford
need to speak up oh I'm sorry you are
not the microphone yet I didn't think
you were Kendra Ford I I can somewhat
remember
it happened then before your committee
before so
um
it's my first Deborah house yes Deborah
good evening it is after five okay
um thank you
thank you chairman
Pearson for hearing my testimony yep you
got your watch great okay uh my name is
Deborah has I am president of the
American Federation of teachers New
Hampshire we represent about 4 000 pre-k
through 12
um
teachers and other school staff
University faculty and public employees
across the state of New Hampshire and
I'm here today to oppose this bill it's
not that we don't want to be working
with parents we actually understand and
really crave the ability to work as a
support team with parents but we know
that that does not um
happen in all situations
um you know sometimes there are
situations where where we cannot uh be
on the same side with parents in all the
time but with this specific bill I want
to make a few quick points the penalties
in this bill are
um problematic where you could lose your
license for
um you know violating
um any part of the bill
um there's some vague wording here about
each parent directing their own child's
education which sounds lovely but when
you have a classroom of 20 kids and each
individual parent wants something
different for their child how do you
manage to teach all of those children in
the classroom that's a concern but the
biggest thing is that in a public school
teachers and School staff are
responsible for making sure that each
and every student is welcome and feels
safe at school
we are responsible under our code of
conduct for treating them with respect
and the parts that have been pointed out
here
would require discriminating against
some of our students and we just we
can't accept that I mean that's why
we're opposing this bill we will not
treat some of our students with you know
discriminatory practices uh as this bill
will call for and you put us in a
position of possibly losing our license
and our job if we do uh if we violate
that position or violating our code of
conduct which also comes with loss of
license and job it's not a great
position to be in and you are in a
shortage of educational staff in this
state in all positions so it really is
not the best thing for our students
who need teachers in the classroom to
educate them I had no idea how long
you've been testifying because I wasn't
looking and he left but it's you made a
great presentation I'll give you 15
seconds more if you want it
um about all I want to say you're good
otherwise I would have to go on to
another topic and it would be more than
15 seconds I could say more but I I
think you know in recognition of the
lateness of the day and your patience
would you believe in 16 years of
teaching graduate school all of my
students wanted individualized
curriculum too I'm sure they do thank
you very much it gets worse the older
they get all right uh Kendra Ford please
Kendra Ford no Kendra Ford
um Don Johnson
no Don Johnson
you know I run a loose committee I'll
take much more of that
um Russ and Chester
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members I'm going to keep this
very brief
um partially because I was not in here
for a lot of the testimony
um and I don't want to repeat anything
but I'm here today for two people one
was a trans kid and the other was her
mother I was the case manager she was an
abused child at young child the mother
did the appropriate thing and protected
her child she went on to school
she was part of the one trusted adult
program
um
she came out to a at 12 years old she
came out to a teacher
um and
um it was kept from the mother
uh they started her on transitioning
with uh hormones in the school system
without parents knowledge
they um
so at 12 12 years old they started
transitioning her at 16 years old she
took her life
but she took her life because she was
she wanted to de-transition and she
didn't feel like she had anyone to talk
to
but more importantly as the case manager
I hold some responsibility and that's
why I'm here for Desi today because Desi
was being abused
sexually by that one trusted adult
the bottom line is Predators exist in
our world today
secrets are what predators rely on
unfortunately predators are going to go
where they their resources are which is
our school systems same thing with
there's bad people in every profession
you got 15 seconds to wrap it up so one
of the things I heard a lot about today
is we're criminalizing educators
the other side is where criminalizing
parents this is not okay this should not
be about us and them we should be
working together collectively and that's
why we need a parental Bill of Rights I
call it parents right parental right to
know
thank you thank you so much
you have a question you may ask your
question thank you Mr chairman um and
thank you for indulging me you said that
a school district put a child on
hormonal medication without informing
their parent where was this that's
correct here in Concord New Hampshire
when
uh less than Desi's been gone two years
so uh 16 she started at 13.
four years ago I don't I guess I'm I'm
struggling to understand how a school
district has prescription abilities this
so on unfortunately the way our systems
are working right now is through our
behavioral health programs many other
behavioral health programs in the
schools are run by Planned Parenthood
and they have the ability to give kids
these prescriptions okay um thank you
politician that I remember once said
trust but verify
and I don't say you're giving false
information I'd like to have more direct
documentation and if you could mail it
to the committee I think that would help
your testimony along so thank you for
test testifying before us and the chair
recognizes Eliza Twitty
good evening now thank you so much for
your time
my name is Eliza Tweedy I'm the
excuse me pastor and First Church
Congregational in Rochester New
Hampshire
I am also a mother of three all of whom
have been educated in New Hampshire
Public Schools
one of the first things I learned as a
parent is that my children are their own
humans whether I like it or not
my faith tells me that they are not my
creation but Gods I have the privilege
of guarding and caring for them but that
is enough because through them I can see
the fullness of God's creation who they
are how they live their life may or may
not follow my values or morals and
that's okay because God's love is bigger
than my understandings
it is normal for a child to push back
against their parents to create a sense
of self separate from their parents to
explore experiment and learn that is
normal and natural and good for those of
us who want our children to become
members of society capable of critical
thinking and thoughtful engagement if my
children do not trust me enough to
include me in their lives their
questions and their Explorations that is
a failure on my part to be a person that
they trust that is a me problem
when I was a young person there were
many adults in my life who guided and
loved me I could express to them my
sense of self with less anxiety than I
could to my generally very supportive
and loving parents because losing that
adult would have been less traumatic
than losing my family and they gave me
the courage to live into my truth they
saw the image of God in Me and helped me
see it in myself I want the same for my
children and I am grateful to the
teachers and other adults in their lives
who have allowed them to become the
individuals that they are becoming
this bill does not speak as much to
parental rights as it does to parental
control it takes away a child's ability
to explore their sense of self outside
the family unit in ways that feel safe
to them and whatever you want to believe
this bill disproportionately affects
lgbtq plus students who may have been
perfectly safe at home while closeted
but will be targets of psychological
emotional spiritually spiritual and
possibly physical abuse if their
identity is disclosed my faith tells me
to stand firmly on the side of those who
are most likely to be harmed the removal
of safe spaces to be themselves is not a
question of parental rights but of
emotional spiritual and psychological
control and you have 15 seconds to wrap
it up yes sir it is correlated strongly
with increased depression anxiety
suicidal ideation and self-harm which is
not the outcome anyone wants for their
children because of that first lesson I
learned remains I can do my best to love
my children and try to guide them but I
cannot change who they are or force them
to trust me I can only hope that the
Beloved Community will I pray that there
will be someone else who can see the
fullness of God in my children until I
can get out of my own way and see it
myself thank you so much thank you so
much
Raymond Breslin we may have called him
this morning and the card got back over
here so if somebody else's name Raymond
Breslin I guess not
and we're getting to the end here
um
Christine Perez
do we have a Christine Perez we are
Christine perezless
was that
yes wow
okay David Kendall David Kendall has not
testified yet no
[Music]
good evening
I was the 14 year old runaway homeless
trans kid
that has been referred to here many
times today
I'm torn
because I'm a gay man
I was trans for over 20 years
and I know
I know that
that place
and so I'm torn
but I'm not
as torn
to oppose this bill
why
because I was a transgender woman for
over 20 years I was a member of the
lgbtqia gender movement for over 30
years
I have lived breathed and I have been
this movement I didn't live a liar
became the LIE
with very graphic sexualized books
making their way into schools
classrooms
you cannot tell me there's not an agenda
digital and and um analyzers
said nearly 350 K through 12 Educators
have been arrested on child sex crimes
in 2022.
I loved my teachers
parents must be the only ones making the
decisions on whether or not their
children are reading viewing or being
taught about same-sex
opposite sex sex or any sex at all
all of these terms all of these uh CIS
CIS
uh gender these were coined
by scientists these are theories that
were coined by scientists John money
Alfred Kinsey
these were these men were
documented pedophiles documented
pedophiles
I have heard the parents after their
sons and daughters have tried to take
their lives
I'm actually the one that they call
they've been secretly and aggressively
been told by teachers and counselors
that they will willingly hide crucial
information
which only tells these children that it
is okay to deceive to lie to and to hide
things from their parents
the parents are the sole decision makers
when it comes to their children
I was targeted
I was groomed
I was molested my entire childhood
I ran away from home because I couldn't
be trans
and I lived on the Streets of
Philadelphia
where I started hormone therapy
I stay I sit before you a 50 year old
gay man I'm LGB
you've got 20 seconds to finish up I
have osteoporosis which is an elderly
woman's disease and I've had it before
the age of 30. I've also been sterile
since before the age of 30 30. so these
are the concepts that are leading
children into so much darkness and we
need a medium because honestly I don't
know whether to oppose
yeah
or to affirm the bill
because there's no medium and there
there must be one
thank you would you take any questions
if people
representative Nelson thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for your bravery
today in speaking with us would you
please email to us your testimony today
absolutely I have copies right here as
well thank you if you could hand them
out absolutely yes thank you thank you
uh before you do
um
is there I really don't know the answer
to this I'm not you know pretending I
don't I don't is there a a group or a
movement of people who
went trans and
yes
come back I am what they call a
detransitioner okay and there are
thousands of us out there what
percentage to your knowledge of those
people those folks have had massive
hormonal
injections and or surgery all of the
detransitioners that I know have went
through hormone therapy and or surgical
procedures
and they regret it absolutely thank you
any other questions anybody other
questions thank you so much and we did
it uh as representative McMahon said
while we were yet Young
this concludes the uh hearing on House
Bill 10 it will be exact we will meet
next Tuesday you we will have the
hearing and the executive session on 475
we will exec everything that's left this
is crossover week next week coming
uh Mr chairman oh excuse me
I'm sorry representative excuse me for
that too attorney head I'm looking at
your card
I'm clearly not a head case though many
would deny it come on up I'm sorry
everybody I'm looking right at it if you
if you can after you've after you've
called the hearing I don't know if you
can actually
I'm gonna have to bang my head with the
gavel chairman
uh Mr chairman I have a question just to
clarify
um the ones that were on our agenda to
exec today we didn't get to will be next
week is that next week thank you I
appreciate it
or you can stay late but I'll be leaving
last witness after four hours thank you
Mr chairman members of committee my name
is Richard head I'm the government
Affairs coordinator for the judicial
branch I come with a request for a what
I think is a technical Amendment
um and I'll reference both on the bill
as introduced it's page 3 line 13 to 15
in the amendment of the Amendments after
if we go by the amendment it's page 4
line 28.
and uh and what I've handed out is the
proposed amendment and then the second
page of what I've handed out is the
statute that is referenced in the bill
um and I'll explain the reason why I'm
asking for the amendment the statute so
this section of the bill starts this
section shall not and it identifies what
that section does not apply to
um and B is it the section shall not
prohibit a court of competent
jurisdiction law enforcement officer or
employees of a government agency that is
responsible for child welfare from
acting in his or her official capacity
what we're asking is that there be a
period there because the rest of it
would would result in this paragraph
having no meaning because it then goes
on to say within the reasonable and
prudent scope of his or her authority
pursuant to RSA 186 119c 186 119c is a
duty of the Department of Education so
none of the none of the entities listed
in this paragraph are the department of
energy education
um actually I'm sorry this is a school
district obligation relative to the
State Board of Education so because none
of the entities including what I care
about is a court
has any duties under this statute they
would never be acting pursuant to it so
therefore this exception doesn't exist
in it as it's written so what I'm asking
for and I've I briefly spoke with the
speaker and the representatives who
introduced the bill about striking that
I didn't think it was an issue and I
don't think it is but I just wanted to
flag it for you
um it just simply gives the paragraph
the meaning I think it was intended to
have so this has nothing to do with
ideology wearing a hijab belonging to a
club this simply has to do with getting
the statute cited right needed a little
technical Amendment wow no position on
the bill thank you thank you all right
to anybody's knowledge is there
something else I'm supposed to do
is everybody with a pink card been heard
yes have you sold all your girl scout
cookies good okay we are now officially
done thank you
um